welcome to this new full course on
digital marketing by simply learn which
will prove a complete guide for your
digital marketing career a career in
digital marketing offers diverse
opportunities in a dynamic field with
high demand remote work options and
competitive salaries and the chance to
impact business it is an appealing
choice to succeed professional needs to
be creative and have analytical skills
stay updated with the industry changes
and maintain ethical practices this
career allows for specialization in the
areas like SEO content marketing social
media and more making it suitable for a
wide range of Interest so if you are
looking to grab a career in digital
marketing simply Lear has got you
covered with wide range of top-notch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skilled in SEO content
marketing PPC social media marketing and
much more with hands-on experience in
the tools like Google analytics Keyword
Planner s rush and there is huge list on
board however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course find
the course Link in the description box
before we begin consider subscribing to
Simply learn and hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from us so
without any further delay over to our
tutors digital marketing is all about
promoting products and services using
the internet and digital channels it's
an everchanging field that helps
businesses reach their customers and
achieve their marketing goals in 2024
there are few important Trends to keep
in mind First artificial intelligence
and machine learning are playing a big
role these Technologies helps businesses
personalize their marketing efforts and
provide better customer experiences
video content is also becoming more
popular platforms like YouTube YouTube
and Tik Tok are great for businesses to
engage with their audience and showcase
their products or Services social media
is still a big part of digital marketing
platforms like Facebook and Instagram
allow businesses to connect with their
customers and build brand awareness
influencer marketing is also on the rise
where businesses collaborate with
popular social media users to promote
their products digital marketing is not
just a tool for promotion it's a way to
build meaningful relationship with
customers and adapt to the changing
digital landscape so in this video on
digital marketing road map 2024 we will
learn about digital marketing and its C
structure we will also understand the
step-by-step road map in which we will
be covering the learning path to become
a digital marketing professional but
before we begin let me ask you a quick
question so what does ROI stand for in
digital marketing option A is return on
investment option b is reach of
Impressions option C is revenue on
investment and option D is rate of
interaction now you can pause this video
and answer in the comment section below
all right so let's start with the topic
which is digital marketing professional
salary so the salary of a digital
marketing professional can vary
depending on factors such as experience
location industry and the size of the
company in general digital marketing
professionals can earn a competitive
salary for an entry-level position or
those with less experience the average
Sal can range from $40,000 to $60,000
per year as professionals gain more
experience and expertise in the field
their salaries can increase
significantly midlevel digital marketing
professional with few years of
experience can expect to earn between
60,000 to $90,000 per year whereas
senior level digital marketing
professional with an extensive
experience and proven ta record of
success can earn salaries upwards to
$100,000 all right so this was about
digital marketing and digital Market
marketing celby now let's move on and
understand the digital marketing road
map for 2024 so here are the basic steps
and learning path if you're looking to
become a successful digital marketer
first is learn the essentials of digital
marketing digital marketing is a broad
term that encompasses various techniques
and methods used to promote websites or
products online it is not a single
discipline but rather a collection of
strategies that businesses can employ to
reach their target audience these
strategies include includ search engine
optimization social media marketing
content marketing email marketing and
more by utilizing these techniques
businesses can increase their online
visibility attract more website visitors
and ultimately Drive conversions and
sales digital marketing is essential in
today's digital age as it allows
businesses to effectively connect with
their audience and achieve their
marketing goals next is understanding
seo seo or search engine optimization is
a crucial aspect of digital marketing it
involves optimizing a website to improve
its visibility and ranking on search
engine results pages to master SEO one
must focus on keyword research and on
page optimization techniques this
involves identifying relevant keywords
and incorporating them strategically
into the website content additionally
understanding link building and backlink
analysis is important for building
authority and credibility technical SEO
knowledge is also necessary including
optimizing website speed and ensuring
well structured site by mastering
YouTube SEO Google SEO local SEO Etc
businesses can enhance their online
presence and attract organic traffic
from search engines PPC advertising or
payperclick advertising a powerful
digital marketing strategy that allows
you to create an oversee campaigns on
platforms like Google ads and Bing ads
this skillful approach involves keyword
biding where you choose the words or
phrases for which your ads will appear
you must learn Lear ad targeting
ensuring your ads reach the Right
audience Etc crafting compelling ad
copies is another essential aspect as it
entices potential customers to click
monitoring campaign performance is
crucial enabling you to tweak and
optimize for better results all right so
this was about PPC advertising coming to
the next one which is learn social media
marketing social media marketing is a
crucial aspect of promoting websit
effectively depending on the nature of
the websites it is essential to explore
various social media networks such as
Twitter Pinterest or LinkedIn each
platform offers unique opportunities to
engage with different Target audiences
and expand brand visibility to succeed
in social media marketing one must
possesses the necessary skills to create
and compel content engage with users and
analyze data to optimize strategies so
this was about social media marketing
all right coming to the next one which
is conduct content marketing campaigns
learning how to conduct marketing
campaigns is a crucial skill for
aspiring digital marketers it involves
identifying target audience creating
diverse content strategies and
maintaining consistency in content
delivery monitoring key metrics like
website traffic and engagement trades is
a vital for success by mastering these
skills individuals can excel in the
dynamic field of digital marketing
adapting strategies based on the
audience behavior and Data Insights
gaining Proficiency in campaign
management is a fundamental step towards
becoming a successful digital marketer
all right now coming to the next step to
become a digital marketer which is
knowledge of email marketing email
marketing is a powerful strategy for
businesses to engage with their Audience
by learning how to build effective email
marketing campaigns you can create
compelling content that resonates with
your subscribers understanding email
Automation and segmentations allows you
to send targeted messages based on
customer preference aners and behavior
utilizing email marketing platforms and
tools streamlines the process and helps
you track campaign performance all right
so this was about the knowledge of email
marketing now the next step for the
learning part to become a digital
marketer is to learn data analysis and
Reporting tools data analysis and
Reporting tools are essential for
digital marketers to make informed
decisions and optimize their compaigns
some popular tools include Google
analytics which provides detailed
insights into website traffic and user
behavior and Google data Studio which
allows marketers to create visually
appealing reports and dashboards other
tools like SCM rush and Mos help with
keyword research and competitor analysis
these tools enable marketers to track
key metrics identify Trends and measure
the success of their digital marketing
efforts ultimately leading to more
effective strategies and improved Roi so
this was about data analysis and
Reporting tools now coming to the next
step which which is be updated with the
latest trends so the digital marketing
industry is constantly evolving with
changes happening on a daily basis this
makes it an exciting and challenging
profession as experts must continuously
learn and adapt the dynamic nature of
digital marketing ensures that
professionals never get bored as there
are always new strategies Technologies
and Trends to explore staying updated is
crucial to success in this field as it
allows marketers to leverage the latest
tools and techniques to reach their
target audience effectively so this was
about getting or being updated now
coming to the last step which is start
looking for opportunities to Kickstart a
career in digital marketing it's crucial
to build a strong portfolio and resume
start by showcasing your skills and
expertise in various digital marketing
areas such as social media management
content creation SEO and analytics
include any relevant projects campaigns
or certifications you have completed one
once your portfolio is ready begin
searching for jobs that align with your
interest and goals tailor your resume to
highlight your relment experience and
skills and don't forget to network and
leverage online platforms to increase
your chances of Landing for your dream
job so this was about the road map that
you can follow if you're interested and
want to become a digital marketing
professional in 2024 digital marketing
has become an absolute GameChanger for
businesses all around the globe turning
into a skill that everyone wants to get
their hands on it is like having a
superpower that allows you to reach and
engage with customers on a whole new
level if you have ever dreamed of
becoming a digital marketing expert then
you are in for a treat we will be your
digital marketing Mentor guiding you
through each step with Clarity and
enthusiasm from mastering the
fundamental marketing principles to
unlocking the secrets of advanced
strategies we have got you covered so
learning marketing fundamentals is like
building the solid groundwork for your
digital marketing Empire it's all about
understanding the inner workings of
consumer Behavior unraveling the
mysteries of market research and
uncovering the secrets of effective
marketing strategies think of it as the
key that unlocks the door to success in
the digital realm to get started immerse
yourself in the world of marketing
through online courses insightful books
and Industry blogs these treasure
troughs of knowledge will equip you with
essential tools and insights needed to
navigate the everchanging landscape of
digital marketing once you have gained
the Basic Marketing knowledge then the
next thing you can do is create a web
page so imagine having your very own
Digital Playground a place where you can
Unleash Your creativity and showcase
your digital marketing skills to the
world that's exactly what creating a web
page is all about it is like having a
blank canvas where you can paint your
unique Brand Story and Captivate your
audience thank thanks to userfriendly
platforms like WordPress and vix
building a professional looking web page
has never been easier you don't need to
be a coding visard or a design Guru to
get started so once you have created a
web page you can start with learning
local SEO local SEO is vital for
businesses targeting a specific
geographic area optimizing websites for
local search results is key techniques
like optimizing Google my business
listings and obtaining online reviews
and targeting location specific keywords
are crucial by creating accurate and
comprehensive profiles on Google my
business businesses increase their
visibility positive reviews build trust
and credibility while location specific
keywords help businesses appear in
relevant local searches embracing local
SEO techniques ures businesses connect
with the potential customers in their
area gaining a Competitive Edge and
driving growth so learning local SEO is
also important the next step is SEO on
page off page to become a digital
marketing expert you must Master both
onpage and off-page SE techniques onpage
SE involves optimizing elements within
your website such as metat Texs headings
and content off-page SEO on the other
hand focuses on building high quality
backlinks and increase website Authority
through strategies like guest blogging
social media promotion and influencer
Outreach by understanding and
implementing these techniques
effectively you can boost your website's
visibility and rankings in search engine
results ultimately driving more organic
traffic and achieving digital marketing
success now the next step is one of the
most important step that is PPC
advertising So Paid media marketing like
PPC advertising is a GameChanger for
driving targeted traffic to websites
pick a platform like Google ads or
Facebook ads and become a master in it
learn the art of crafting compelling ad
campaigns conducting uh keyword research
and optimizing ad performance by
focusing on on one paid media platform
you will gain the expertise needed to
maximize your marketing efforts and
Achieve outstanding results so dive in
and master your chosen platform and
watch your website traffic s after this
you can go ahead and learn the
analytical tools so analyzing data is
like having a superpower in the world of
digital marketing it's like a secret
source that helps you understand what's
working and what's not working to become
a digital marketing expert you need to
get cozy with analytical tools like
Google analytics these tools are like
Treasure Chest filled with valuable
insights about your website traffic user
behavior and campaign performance so
start by learning how to set up tracking
codes which act as a digital blood
crumbs guiding you through the vast
online landscape then dive into creating
custom reports that give you a
personalized view of your data but don't
stop there the real magic happens when
you interpret the data and use it to
make informed marketing decisions so
learning analytical tools is also
important if you want to become a
digital marketing expert so now next is
learning marketing stack so learning
about the marketing stack is like
unlocking a treasure Trove of tools and
software that can supercharge your
digital marketing efforts picture it as
a collection of powerful weapons in Your
Arsenal you've got an email marketing
platform like MailChimp which help you
craft captivating campaigns that land
right in your audience's inbox then
there are social media management tools
and let's not forget about marketing
automation software like hubsoft which
takes care of repetitive tasks by
getting hands-on experience with these
tools you will become master of
efficiency streamlining your marketing
efforts and unleashing your full
potential after learning all of these
skills and tools you can go ahead and
learn Advanced topics first programmatic
advertising delve into programmatic
advertising which uses Ai and Auto
automation to purchase and optimize
digital ads in real time understand how
it works and its application in various
marketing campaigns next is affiliate
marketing learn the Ines of affiliate
marketing where you promote other
Company products or services and earn a
commission discover how to find and
manage affiliate partnership
effectively all right now the third one
on the list is app marketing so in the
age of mobile apps knowing how to Market
them is crucial explore strategies for
App Store optimization inapp advertising
and user acquisition techniques so these
three are the advanced topics that you
can Master if you want to become a
digital marketing expert all right so
becoming a digital marketing expert
requires continuous learning practical
experience and a passion for staying
updated with industry Trends by
following this stepbystep guide you can
develop a strong foundation in marketing
Master essential digital marketing
techniques and gain experience in
advanced topics welcome to this new
video by simply learn before we begin
with top five digital marketing
certifications for 2024 let me take you
through a quick walk through the history
of digital marketing with the birth of
personal computers the concept of
digital marketing began to take shape
early marketers started sharing emails
to reach out to their customers around
1994 the first ever digital Banner went
live on the website hotwire.com
the best part about this Banner was the
banner was clickable ad in late 1990
with the birth of search engines
marketers began to optimize their
websites to get higher rankings thereby
getting relevant traffic which impacted
positively on sales and the rest becomes
history today in the digital world
around 98% of Internet users are
influenced by social media platforms
because of this strong user base social
media has turned to one of the best
Marketplace if compared to traditional
marketing digital marketing has high Roi
thus making it more cost effective with
the evolution in marketing techniques a
lot of jobs are emerging in the Market
opening doors for skilled digital
marketers on an average a skilled
digital marketer earns up to 8 lakh
rupees annually in India whereas in us
the salaries may go as high as
$106,000 per year so without any further
delay let's begin with top five dig
marketing
certifications the number one on the
list is post-graduate program in digital
marketing by Purdue this comprehensive
course is One-Stop solution for any
aspiring digital marketer it offers
master classes from per University
Howard publishing cases capston projects
35 Plus digital marketing tools and much
more skills are necessary for growth
with this program you will gain most
needed skills for digital marketing
including Q key word research behavioral
marketing SEO sem social media marketing
content marketing and much more learn
tools like chat GPD Google Keyword
Planner Google ads YouTube analytics
Google Trends RFS and more gain
expertise in building and promoting your
website using live Interactive Learning
and year of experience is preferred for
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box at number
two on the list we have us Master
digital marketing course by I IM skills
this master program provides digital
marketing training with live online
interactive classroom covering all the
essentials of digital marketing gain
in-depth understanding of tools like
Facebook ads Facebook insights Google
analytics Keyword Planner Sim Rush MOS
Uber suggest and more check the complete
course details from the official website
of IM skills moving ahead to number
three we have digital marketing Masters
program this online Masters program in
digital marketing offers expertise in
SEO social media PPC conversion
optimization analytics content mobile
and email marketing with 12month access
to the course you will gain industry
ready skills work on real projects and
attend Facebook expert sessions tools
covered in this programs are the most
commonly used tools in the digital
marketing industry naming a few YouTube
analytics Google Keyword Planner Google
ads Bing ads hoot suit Facebook Linkin
Twitter and there is a huge list to go
with this master's program you get
hands-on experience with industry
projects and year of Prior experience is
preferred for this course get an amazing
discount by using the code ytb5 join the
course from the link in the description
box at number four we have digital
marketing specialist by LinkedIn
it is taught by various experienced
professionals linkedin's online course
provides no pressure environment for
entry-level marketers wishing to build
the knowledge of digital marketing this
course has almost 20 hours of on demand
videos broken down into 11 modules this
is an ideal course for people with
little or no experience with digital
marketing it provides comprehensive
overview of all the leading digital
channels including Google ads or bpc SE
email and social media learner will also
get a basic introduction of Google
analytics content marketing Facebook and
Instagram and even learn the
fundamentals of graphic design using
Adobe products each video module
includes a quiz to test how much you
have learned and you will receive a
certificate upon the completion of all
modules the number five on the list is
digital marketing courses by digital
Vidya digital Vidya is government of
India approved digital marketing
platform that provides various digital
marketing certifications in Google
AdWords Google analytics HubSpot and
more the course curriculum is designed
with six core modules making beginner to
learn SEO email marketing inbound
marketing search engine marketing search
engine optimization web analytics and
much more you can check the other
courses you can check the course details
on the official website of digital Vidya
now let's see what digital marketing is
in simple words digital marketing is the
promotion of a product or a brand
through one or more forms of electronic
media such as Internet mobile phones
Google search engine marketing Etc it's
a way to reach client on time and retain
them with interactive marketing using
digital Technologies also it is the most
accessible easy to use and contemporary
method of promotion which is also known
as online marketing so when we want to
go and promote our product or service
using a campaign we have different
options so there are different types of
digital marketing channels that we can
choose from and let's just go through
that list of digital marketing channels
and the first one is what I consider the
king of them all and that's SEO so SEO
stands for search engine optimization
there's search engine marketing there's
email marketing affiliate marketing
social content mobile
and then we can get into subsets of each
of these digital marketing channels but
really we'll start with SEO because
that's the king and to me that's
basically increasing the quality and
quantity of relevant organic traffic on
the search engines including Google so
depending on where you're located in the
US market Google tends or has a large
market share so you want your pages on
your website to be found and clicked on
organically and so that means if
somebody types in a keyword you want
that relevant page to show up first on
Google so somebody can click on that
link okay and we know that millions of
people specifically in the US but
worldwide you search on a daily basis so
if you're ranking for those relevant
keywords you can imagine how much
traffic you can get okay so that's SEO
okay and here's an example so you type
in online shopping well you can see the
first listing here is a paid search ad
we're going to get to that in a minute
the second organically is Amazon okay so
online shopping you think maybe Walmart
you think maybe Alibaba or you're
thinking probably Amazon okay so no
surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names Anonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well my
us.com is bidding on that keyword online
shopping so they're actually appearing
above Amazon On's organic listing but
that's what they want to do they want to
be found for that keyword so if they're
not ranking for it organically well
they're bidding on it and if somebody
happen to clicked on that listing then
my us.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to $100 it depends
depends on the keyword depends on who
else is bidding on the keyword depends
on the location
depends on the time of day depends on
quality score there a lot of factors
involved and regarding what you pay
however the benefit of sem is visibility
and getting traffic to your website for
keywords you're not found for so that's
why sem such a popular choice for a lot
of companies okay let's talk about
digital marketing that's a traditional
type of digital marketing channel it's
been around a long time you know we all
send emails on a daily basis and we
probably all receive emails on a daily
basis just an effective way to capture
leads and convert them to customers
because with email you can personalize
your emails and you can send your emails
to a segmented audience okay so if you
have emails from females who are 35
years of age to 44 that live in say the
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out you're
selling a product and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase product and if
you purchase it you're going to get 30%
off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a Salesforce of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you could see earn up to 12%
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay out that commission
okay let's let's turn our attention to
social media marketing so social media
marketing you know I wouldn't say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in
2019 and I remember talking about
Facebook back in 2006 so you're talking
about 13 14 15 years of social media
it's definitely evolved over the years
and but the concept Remains the Same it
involves creating different types of
content depending on the platform okay
so you could be on Pinterest or
Instagram and be dealing with photos or
you could be on Twitter tweeting out
certain characters up to a limit okay so
it really depends on the social media
platform uh that really drives the type
of content you're going to promote but
we know social media can be effective
because people use social media I mean
Facebook is one of the more popular
platforms and if you want to get your
product or service out there you could
certainly pay to have an ad on Facebook
or you could just post your content
organically okay that's the beauty of
social most of your Social platforms
like LinkedIn and Twitter and Facebook
and Pinterest and Instagram they all
have a paid form of advertising that you
can use to promote your product or
service or you can go the organic route
and you know post content organically in
hopes of driving traffic back to your
website so with social you do have two
options here but social is interesting
because there a lot of different social
media platforms out there really depends
on your product or service okay so an
example of social media marketing
especially on Facebook with Facebook you
got mobile and desktop and you obviously
have the opportunity to post something
organically and have that liked or
commented on or shared or you can post
an ad and get that liked commented or
shared or clicked and have people go
back to your website and fulfill the
goal of what you want them to do so
moving on to content marketing so
content marketing is really an effective
way of really Distributing valuable
content online and when we talk about
content marketing you know we're talking
about different types of assets so it
could be simply text in the form of a
blog post or it could be a video or it
could be an an infographic or it could
be an image okay there lots of ways to
create content these days especially in
digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there um um and depending on the
platform putting yourself out there with
various types of content so for example
we look at YouTube you could see this
video here about digital marketing
certified associate well hey you don't
need to always write the content you can
produce the content in the form of a
video and post it on YouTube this is a
form of content marketing so that's
content marketing and then let's talk
about mobile marketing so content
marketing again different types but if
we go now to mobile marketing you can
kind of segue from content to mobile
because the only difference here is with
mobile it's strictly on mobile phone
it's not desktop so mobile marketing is
really a strategy on its own that helps
you the company promoting your product
or service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
could do a bit adjustment just for
mobile and the goal could be app
installs okay so and you can even do a
mobile or app extension so there's lots
of ways to really promote your app or
your product or your service Via mobile
marketing digital marketing plays an
essential role in most businesses today
this has led to an increase in the
demand for digital marketing profession
profs because of this many people are
interested in learning about digital
marketing it is becoming one of the
essential skills that you can have if
you learn how to use it you can make a
difference in your marketing
capabilities hey everyone I'm Tushar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
and this video we will discuss the top
10 reasons to learn digital marketing
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay
tuned so without any further delay okay
let's get
started easy to start a career a career
in digital marketing is an easy one to
start the field is growing rapidly and
there is a demand for professionals who
can care the digital assets of a company
with this in mind it is easy to find a
position even with no specific degree it
is also easy to find further training in
digital marketing as a lot of free and
paid resources are
available a technical and creative field
both Technical and creative skills are
necessary for digital marketing it has a
lot of subfield hence it requires a
unique skill set and knowledge of the
latest technology for example a social
media marketing professional should know
how to run a successful campaign digital
marketing is a perfect career option for
those who are interested in both the
creative and Technical
Fields highly paid digital marketing is
one of the most popular and trending
Industries there is a v demand for
digital marketing professionals as a
result digital marketing roles are also
very well played your expert could help
you gain better roles within your
organization which could improve your
salary according to Goldman Sach report
digital marketing scope in the Indian
internet industry alone is expected to
reach us 160 billion by 2025 which shows
the extent of digital marketing in India
and the job demand for digital marketing
according to Glass do a digital
marketing manager earns around 7 lakh in
India and HEI can earn roughly
$123,000 in the
US become an entrepreneur as a digital
marketer you will be familiar with wide
range of online tools and platforms you
can start a blog or website where you
can list your products or if you have
expertise in some field you can also
create your own digital products and
sell them online also you can start your
own freelancing business where you can
offer various services to the clients
all aspiring entrepreneurs need to
embrace digital marketing and even the
old ones need to adapt in order to grow
career growth there are lot of digital
marketing professionals around but very
few are skilled the demand for digital
marketing skills will increase in the
near future due to digital economies
rapid growth many individuals are
starting their online businesses and
almost every new company starts with an
online presence hence it's a perfect
chance for individuals who are looking
to make a career in digital
marketing the next reason is versatility
dig digital marketing offers a variety
of career options and a lifetime
learning since there are so many aspects
to it for example suppose you worked in
content marketing for 2 years and now
you want to work in SEO in that case
there is relatively little training you
need so it won't be that difficult to
switch over if you want to enter into
some other domain your digital marketing
experience will always be valuable
therefore it is said that digital
marketers can easily change
jobs the next major reason is is more
number of jobs several new jobs were
created in the digital marketing field
after coid as most businesses came
online you will find many digital
marketing job opportunities on Len every
single day Grand View research reports
that the global digital marketing
software Market size was USD 56 billion
in 2021 and is expected to grow at a
compound annual growth rate C AGR of
19.1% from 2022 to 2030
the field of digital marketing is vast
however digital marketing is also used
in other areas such as blockchain
blockchain provides trustworthy metrics
for monitoring marketing campaigns in
real time it's also a good chance for
digital marketers to discover other
fields like blockchain time and cost
effective in the long term digital
marketing will save you a lot of time
effort and money traditional marketing
is expensive and the cost keep Rising
there are cost of printing ads
television ads radio ads and billboards
digital marketing will give you more
profits than traditional marketing if
you know how to use it effectively
furthermore digital marketing requires
less efforts for example you can reach
Global audience using your laptop
sitting at home while traditional
marketing involves a lot of
efforts the next important reason is
Recession Proof job lending your dream
job is a rarity for many in this job
market with the economy still struggling
business are cutting jobs left and right
so how you can make yourself Recession
Proof if you are creative and willing to
learn it can happen there are many ways
to make yourself more desirable to
businesses and get job offers however
one way is to become an expert in
digital marketing digital marketing is
the internet based marketing of product
and services using digital Technologies
mainly on the internet marketing is an
integral part of any business with the
ever growing number of Internet users it
is expected that more companies will use
digital marketing extensively in the
future so now let's discuss the last and
interesting reason specialization the
field of digital marketing has a wide
range of
specializations SEO content marketing
influencer marketing sem and many other
fall under digital marketing an
individual has a lot to explode and once
you explode you can pick a digital
marketing specialization according to
your interest additionally there is a
wide variety of skills that you need to
to master under each of these categories
digital marketing is a strategic method
that utilizes digital channels to
promote products or Services it involves
activities like social media marketing
SEO content marketing and email
marketing to engage with a specific
online audience the objective is to
increase brand visibility attract
customers and generate leads and improve
conversions by leveraging digital
platforms and datadriven insights bu
businesses can optimize their marketing
strategies personalize communication and
measure campaign performance in today's
competitive online landscape digital
marketing provides a coste effective and
trackable approach to connect with
customers and drive business growth
these days digital marketing is one of
the most trending jobs digital marketing
jobs are trending due to Growing online
presence cost Effectiveness targeted
marketing measurable results constant
Innovation and Global Reach This has
increased the demand of digital
marketing Professionals in the industry
it is predicted to have approximately 8
lakh 60,000 job openings in 2023 from
apparel industry to it fintech and
Pharma digital marketers are in huge
demand the salaries of digital marketer
May differ depending upon the skills
location or the company however on an
average the salary of digital marketing
manager in India is 6.4 lakhs perom
rupees whereas in us it is
$122,000 per anom so hey everyone if you
are looking to try your hands on in this
field then here we have a magic course
that will help you to gain excellence in
this domain and grab highest paying jobs
under digital marketing so before we
begin with the digital marketing road
map consider subscribing to our Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so without any
further Ado let's begin with digital
marketing road map for 2023 in the
dynamic world of digital marketing a
marketing road map is a crucial for
businesses to navigate successfully
towards the growth by defining goals
understanding target audience and
implementing effective strategies
companies can establish a strong online
presence and Achieve marketing
objectives so here are the basic steps
if you you are looking to become a
successful digital marketer let's begin
with step number one establish a solid
foundation learn marketing principles
and strategies be good with
communication and writing skills develop
analytical skills analyze data to drive
insights understand consumer behavior
and market trends the next step we have
is to gain expertise in SEO and PPC
campaign SEO or search engine
optimization ation Master keyword
research and onpage optimization
techniques as this is the base of any
digital marketing efforts understand
link building and backlink Analysis with
this it is also necessary to have good
understanding of technical SEO including
website speed optimization and site
structure stay up to date with search
engine algorithm changes next is
paperclick advertising or PPC learn to
create and manage PPC campaigns on the
platforms like Google ads and Bing ads
develop skills in keyword bidding and
targeting and add copyrighting keep an
eye on the campaign performance and
optimize for better results explore
remarketing and display advertising
moving ahead we need to understand how
to Leverage The Power of social media
and marketing gain Proficiency in major
social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram Twitter and Linkedin
understand social media media
advertising and audience targeting
create engaging content and manage
social media communities analyze social
media metrics and utilize management
tools moving ahead content marketing and
email marketing are the powerful
techniques to gain more leads here
talking about content marketing develop
content creation skills like content
writing graphic designing and video
production learn content distribution
strategies like guest blogging and
influencer Outreach use analytics and
measurement tools to evaluate content
marketing Effectiveness moving towards
email marketing learn to build effective
email marketing campaigns understand
email Automation and segmentation
utilize email marketing platforms and
tools comply with email marketing
regulations and best practices with all
the above practices it is necessary to
have knowledge of web development
acquired knowledge of HTML CSS and
JavaScript get detailed understanding of
content Management systems or CMS like
WordPress uiux design and more data can
provide valuable Insight in the business
growth gain expertise in data analysis
learn tools like Google analytics and
Google tag manager analyze website
traffic user behavior and conversion
rate experiment with AB testing which
will help you to understand what works
better for your content utilize data to
inform marketing decisions and enhance
campaign performance last but not the
least stay updated stay updated with
industry news Trends and best practices
attend webinars conferences and
workshops engage with online communities
and participate in discussions get
certified in Google ads Google analytics
HubSpot or Facebook blueprint well to
bring it to your notice the postgraduate
program and digital marketing covers all
the requirements as we discussed in this
video check the complete course details
from the course Link in the description
box greetings everyone this is Rob
Sanders from Simply learn happy New Year
and today we're going to talk about
digital marketing skills so digital
marketing allows business owners
regardless of the business nonprofit
for-profit large or small National local
International to really expand their
business allows them to personalize
their content they could save money and
most importantly they can measure the
results and so that's what we're going
to focus on today when we talk about
digital marketing skills focusing on
measuring those results so suppose
anybody wants to work in marketing or
grow a company or help grow an
individual's company or ensure to keep
up with the appropriate skills this is
what we're going to cover today so we're
gonna cover a few channels and so let's
get right to it today we're going to
start off with search engine
optimization or SEO also known as
organic search so
SEO is an interesting channel uh it's
probably the premier channel for most
companies in fact HubSpot confirms that
57% of B2B marketers stated that SEO
generates more leads than any other
Market marketing initiative so it's
really important for not only just
generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business including
e-commerce and so what does SEO entail
and what skills should you acquire in
order to manage SEO as a marketing
channel well if you think about it SEO
is really divvied up into two pies one
piie is called on page
the other pie is called off-page and so
on page consists of things you can do to
the website to help you be found in
organic search so what are those things
well it could be anything from you know
page load speed to 4 four errors to sit
maps and so the point here is if you're
going to manage SEO and you know that
you got to make sure your websites and
top shape or your client's websites in
good enough shape for Google to
recognize it as a legitimate site you
have to have some technical skills now
I'm not saying you have to be developer
but at the same time you have to know
what a 44 eror is you know have to know
where and how to generate a site map and
upload that site map you need to know
how to edit a robot's text file so those
are you know what I call soft technical
skills but they're all valid for SEO so
you have to to have some technical
background staying in the on page P okay
you need to make sure you have not only
skills to write content but skills to
optimize content so you need to be aware
of all the different elements on a page
in order to optimize that page so again
that entails you know some copywriting
skills but more importantly and probably
more challenging is to take those
copyrighting skills and enhance them for
SEO okay so making sure that you're able
to understand what it is that you need
to do to get a page optimized so it can
rank higher in the search engine results
okay so those are on page
skills then you got the other piece of
the pie which is off-page so
understanding you know what it takes to
make sure your site is relevant so it's
understanding different metrics off page
metrics like page Authority domain
Authority external links internal links
and so generally most SEO managers have
a thirdparty SEO platform that they work
with like sem rush or MZ so it's
understanding how to work with those
platforms to measure off-page results so
we always say that SEO as a digital
marketing channel is an 800 pound
gorilla well it is because you have on
page and off page to worry about so the
two those together you know is is quite
a task in order to rank and so what
brings SEO and all digital marketing
channels is understanding the metrics
and understanding what you're seeing in
order to measure results and improve
upon those results okay so that's really
the theme for all these digital
marketing channels we're going to talk
about today it's really about okay what
metrics and how do I measure the results
and so when you look at SEO in terms of
measuring results on the onpage side
okay you're going to have to do some
keyword analysis you're going to have to
understand okay what volume is you're
going to understand how to get the
competition numbers okay and you're
going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are
performing okay and then again the off
page you got different metrics like
domain Authority or page Authority you
have external links internal links you
have no follow and follows and and you
allot these little metrics related to
off-page SEO you're going to have to
understand what those metrics mean and
if you can understand what those metrics
mean and then more importantly act on
those metrics then that's what's going
to help you improve your results in
terms of SEO so again that's going to be
the common theme here so I'm just going
to highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand in
order to better manage SEO a channel
again on the on page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time what's a bad page load T
from a keyword perspective what's good
volume what's bad volume what's good
competition what's bad competition so if
you can understand the intricacies of
the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up
toate and have a complete knowledge of
the latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking okay
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads payperclick cost per click a lot of
acronyms a lot of ways to describe it at
the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity
to rank at the very top of the Google
search results now it's different than
SEO because you're actually paying for
the placement and so to be found at the
top of the search engine results as a
paid placement or sponsored ad means
that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're going to pay Google X amount okay
so unlike SEO sem is very fast
moving and so when we talk about fast
moving we mean that you're collecting a
lot of data very quickly so sticking
with the theme of what skills should I
have for search engine marketing well if
you're going to collect data then that
means you need to measure the results of
that data and so sticking with our theme
of measureing results you need to
understand first and foremost what all
the different metrics mean related to
Cent engine marketing okay so I'm just
going to Rattle off if you will a few of
the metrics but the commonality here is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
seen your ad what's a lot of impressions
well it's subjective okay so it could be
a th000 Impressions or 10,000
Impressions at the end of the day that's
how many people have seen your ad now
more
importantly you have another metric
called clicks clicks means how many
people actually saw your ad and then
clicked on your ad okay so if you have
100 people that have seen your ad and
one person who clicked on your ad then
you have a click through rate of
1% now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click through itate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay a quality score is simply a number
between one and 10 that's assigned to
each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you
have 200 or 300 or 5 00 or a th000
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click through rate is going
to be low if your click through rate is
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low and in order to pay
less to Google you need to make sure
that your quality score is good so you
need to understand the factors involved
with quality score you need to
understand Impressions clicks click
through rate because if you don't have a
good click through rate then how do you
improve that so it's about measuring the
results and acting upon the result
results those are the skills involved
with search engine marketing and that's
just on the click side you got the
conversion side of the house so you need
to be able to understand how to get
conversions and how to maintain a high
conversion rate so for example if you
have 100 clicks and only one
conversion that is a 1% conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if if that number is
high like say $20 and you're only
selling a product that's say
$10 well then you got a problem and so
there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low clicked rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion or very low Impressions you
need to be able to understand how to
react to what you're seeing and what
data you're collecting that to me is the
primary skill bottom line with search
engine marketing and there are other
skill sets involved don't get me wrong I
mean it's nice to be able to write copy
because with search engine
marketing typically the ads have very
few characters involved so you need to
be able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing Copy being able to
understand your target
audience um those are all things
involved with managing search engine
marketing but really the key component
here is again measuring the results okay
let's switch over to a traditional
marketing channel email marketing you
know one of my favorites you know listen
we're all bombarded with
emails uh and you know what it's it
becomes cumbersome at times I mean it's
easy to just disregard an email and so
to me the key here if you're going to do
email
marketing you need to have a certain set
of skill sets and so what that skill set
is is really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients you need to
hope that that email is relevant to that
audience okay so you need to be able to
really identify who it is we're sending
this email
to and a recent study done by
statista uh stated that 49% of consumers
really like to receive promotional
emails from their favorite Brands so if
you have a very strong brand then email
marketing is probably a good channel for
you if you don't have a strong brand or
nobody really knows about your brand or
your product your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will but
really email marketing is it involves
emails that promote the brands products
and
services and if you could Target the
Right audience or making sure you have
the Right audience then you got a good
chance of having successful email
marketing
campaigns but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copyrighting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighting saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email they're going to be able
to react to it so you know writing copy
with strong call to action or really
relevant copy that really talks to the
audience I mean those are all keys for
email marketing in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's AB
testing and so AB testing is simply
taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs well you could certainly do
AV testing with email marketing that
means taking a subject line that has
traditionally worked for you or is
relevant for that audience and then
creating a variant or different subject
line so if I'm going to send an email to
100 people I'm going to send
50 people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variant
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to okay so if I see the
open rates higher for the variant versus
the traditional or the original subject
line then I know that this subject line
works and therefore I'm going to apply
this subject line moving forward and
then what am I going to do I'm going to
take it and test it against another
variant so you should always do AB
testing on subject lines so the concept
of AB testing should not be lost on any
digital marketer okay whether that be
SEO search engine marketing or email
marketing okay so you should have an
understanding of AB testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have have a different set
of metrics we already mentioned open
rates so if you send out 100 emails how
many people open the email okay you want
that open rate to be as high as possible
and then when they open the email did
people click on that CTA or any of those
links in the email okay so you want a
high click the rate and then more
importantly when they click on a link in
the email they're going to go to a
landing page you want that person to
engage with landing page so what's the
engagement rate of the landing page from
the email okay so it's really important
that you have an understanding of all
the different metrics involved with
email marketing and again how to react
to that data so if you're getting a low
open rate could it be the subject line
isn't that good possibly that's why you
have to do testing if you're getting a
low clicked rate on the emails that
could be because the copy may not be
that great or the design or the call to
action or it's not compelling enough for
the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement rate on the landing
page if you have a low engagement rate a
low conversion rate you got to look at
that and figure out how to improve that
okay so you can apply AB testing the
landing pitch so there are always ways
to react to the data regardless of what
campaign or regardless of what digital
marketing channel you're working in okay
so that's the common here one point on
email marketing is if you're going to
measure the results of the campaign
whether you're using you know vertical
response or MailChimp or you know some
other email marketing platform you want
to make sure you have what we call UTM
tracking and if you're using Google
analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign pign in
Google analytics so that's another skill
set you should have being able to apply
you know tracking to your digital
marketing campaigns including email okay
because if you don't it's going to be
hard to measure the results in Google
analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular in fact you know offshoot
of social media is really influencer
marketing uh you know if somebody an
influencer has millions of likes on say
Tik Tok or Instagram you might want to
engage with that influencer and help you
promote your brand or your product isn't
that really what social media is it's a
platform whether that be you know
Facebook or or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to to get to message your
user base your community perspective
clients people who do don't even know
about your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me see there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage the majority of the
percentage of the world uses a social
media platform okay in fact just like
SEO where you need an SEO platform there
are plenty of social media platforms
there's later there's Sprout social
there's hot sweet there's buffer in fact
buffer confirms that 73% of marketers
believe social media marketing has been
somewhat effective or very effective for
their business and that's promising
because social media in my opin
opinion having been in this industry a
while it can be a very fickle Channel
meaning if you're trying to promote a
product or service on
Facebook and it's very very going to be
very hard to pull that person away who's
engaged with their Facebook feed not
only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and
convert okay based on what you have on
your it so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone converting so that's
why when I say very fickle but you know
somewhat encouraging if buffer is
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying trying to
achieve when we set up a social media
platform or enact a social media
campaign okay and so that's really the
first thing it's really understanding
what platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content because just
like any other marketing channel you're
going to have
metric and social media is not shy on
the metric front Okay so you have
reach you have Impressions you have
engagement rate in fact every social
media channel has its own set of
specific specific metrics whether that
be likes followers
shares uh uh reviews Stars if you will
so it really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day you need to be able to
measure the results if you're posting
let's just say on Facebook and your
whole job or strategy is to entice
engagement meaning get people to share
that particular post or act on on that
post then you need to be able to measure
the engagement how many people saw the
post how many people engag with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data but
more
importantly it's about being able to you
know put a strategy together
first and then I would you know a skill
set I would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just n buffer or hoot sweet or
Sprout social they're all good in their
own right but they're all going to have
different features so to
me understanding what social media
platform works best for you you want to
choose a social media platform that you
know allows you to control what post you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on at the same time you want a
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the engagement that
you're getting from that platform
and you probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will um what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform okay so you want a
listening tool if you will uh as part of
that social media platform so it's
understanding what platform you want to
use when it comes to social media
marketing it's understanding what
strategy that that platform is going to
help help you enact okay and then it's
also that social media platform that's
going to help you understand the data so
you can react to the
data so those are all to me the skill
sets you need as a social media manager
and then an offshoot of social media is
paid social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
you're ad on LinkedIn and somebody
clicks on it you're going to pay for
that click you're going to pay LinkedIn
or you're going to pay Twitter you're
going to pay Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid social is
understanding what assets you can have
when advertising on these platforms you
know can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook um you know can you use what
type of images and you know how big do
those images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your
ads so having a full understanding of
the types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise
again a whole another set of metrics you
know how many people saw your ad how
many people clicked on your ad how many
people engag with the landing page how
many people converted what was the cost
per conversion so all of those are
metrics that we covered in search engine
marketing they apply with paid
social so you have the opportunity on
paid social you have the opportunity on
social media to to really get your
message out there it's really
understanding what kind of data you're
you're collecting what are the results
of the ad or the post and how do you
react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or
spreadsheets if looking at a mountain of
data scares you well then you might want
to think otherwise when going into
digital marketing but if you want to
embrace the data then digital marketing
is really a great career because if you
can get the data and you know how to
react to the data then you can be
successful in any campaign you run so if
you are looking to grab a career in
digital marketing simply learn has got
you covered with wide range of top-notch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skill in SEO content marketing
PPC social media marketing and much more
with hands-on experience in the tools
like Google analytics keyword planners s
rush and there is huge list on board
however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course find
the course Link in the description box
Rachel is a baker who runs her own
Bakery to expand her business she
decided to create an online presence by
first setting up a Blog she began
posting on her blog regularly however
even after regularly posting on the blog
there were barely any visitors showing
up deciding not to give up Rachel began
searching in for a solution on the
internet that's when she came across SEO
or search engine optimization a term
she's never heard before so let's take a
journey together and help her learn
about SEO search engine optimization is
a method that could improve the quality
and quantity of the audience coming to
Rachel's website from search engines it
could increase brand awareness attract
local customers and build credibility
and trust and all of this is possible
without having the spend a single penny
to bring visitors to our website Rachel
would have to take advantage of the two
types of SEO on page and off-page SEO
Rachel first decides to tackle onpage
SEO and get that sorted onpage SEO
involved Rachel optimizing her website
both in terms of content and the
technical aspects including the HTML
source code schema metatags and more she
started off by using tools like Google
AdWords rref and semrush to identify
popular Search terms associated with the
recipes she planned to publish on her
blog she began to look for Search terms
related to the broader area of baking
cooking and related topics once she
found these Search terms she began to
incorporate them into her recipes she
started off by providing an introduction
to the recipe with this she could
provide an engaging beginning to her
story like how the dish reminded her of
her childhood and enabled her to
naturally include the Search terms into
the blog she also included these
keywords in the actual recipe as well
additionally she added pictures videos
time-lapses and more to increase
credibility and engagement for her
content and subsequently persuading
search engines to show her content to
more people after this she moved to the
website meta content that search engines
display when her blog appears in search
results she optimized the metat tags alt
tags header Tags and More this completed
the onpage aspect of SEO thanks to this
she saw a significant increase in the
number of visitors coming to her page
having done all she could on her web
page she now decides to explore what
could be done off- page to improve her
Page's visibility on search engines
off-page SEO involved Rachel doing
things outside her site page to help
increase its search engine rankings
making optimizations outside the site
would improve the site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
this is possible with the help of
reputable websites vouching for your
content with backlinks social media
marketing guest blogging linked UNL
brand mentions influencer marketing and
much more Rachel also understood that
for her content to reach people she
would have to promote it on social media
platforms like Facebook Twitter and
Instagram as well as Niche platforms
like H Reddit and medium these could
help her achieve greater reach for her
website by sending stronger social
signals to search engines leading to the
page being shown as highly relevant for
related searches and audiences and even
after understanding an implementing all
of this Rachel had just scratched the
surface of what was possible with SEO
before we find out what she did next
let's have a look at a quiz which of the
following is the most effective way to
improve off-page SEO one creating plenty
of web pages of a Content two getting
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative sites three acquiring
backlinks through link buying four none
of the above let us know your answer in
the comment section below for a chance
to win an Amazon voucher now let's go
back to Rachel Rachel decided to take up
simply learn's digital marketing
certification with classes covering just
about everything she needed to know
about SEO it was only a matter of time
before Rachel began to implement her
learnings on her website and see a
massive uptick in the number of viewers
coming to her website in time she could
even earn money off the site by setting
up an online shop and with that we've
covered an introduction to the concepts
of SEO and the possibilities it can open
for you either as a marketer or a
business owner in the ever evolving
landscape of the digital realm where
visibility is Paramount and competition
is fce Mastering the Art and Science of
search engine optimization SEO has never
been more crucial as we set our sides on
2024 the world of SEO is posed for
remarkable Transformations offering a
spectrum of opportunities to those who
Dare To Tread its Dynamic path imagine
having the power to harness the
algorithms that decide which website
rise to the top of search engine results
Envision the ability to craft compelling
content that not only captures the
hearts and minds of your audience but
also climbs the digital ranks
effortlessly picture yourself as the
guiding force behind businesses striving
for online prominence in this SEO Road
app for 2024 we will navigate through
the twist and turns of the SEO landscape
unveiling the strategies and insights
that will make you a true Su expert in
the year ahead from understanding the
latest trends and staying ahead of
algorithm updates to perfecting the
intricate dance of technical SEO and
content strategy this road map will be
your companion on the journey to se
Mastery so fasten your seat belts as you
embark on a tring Expedition into the
world of SEO in 2024 it's time to unlock
the secrets of search engines and Propel
yourself into the realm of digital
success so the number one is user
experience user experience is a top
priority in SEO search engines now
consider factors like page speed mobile
friendliness and user friendly layouts
as crucial for ranking well positive
user experience keeps visitors on your
site and reduces bounce rates and the
next is mobile optimization mobile
optimization remains a key challenge
with the increasing use of smartphones
ensuring that your website is mobile
friendly is vital for SEO success this
includes responsive design fast loading
times and mobile first indexing and now
moving to the next Trend that is eat
expertise authoritativeness and
trustworthiness EAD is critical for SEO
in 2023 search engines aims to provide
users with high quality and trustworthy
content demonstrating expertise
authoritativeness and Trust
trustworthiness in your content and
across your site is essential and the
next trend is voice search voice search
continues to grow optimizing for voice
search involves using natural language
answering specific questions and
providing concise informative content
understanding how users speak their
queries is key and now moving on to the
next Trend that is content quality and
relevance high quality relevant content
is essential creating content that
addresses user intent is up to date and
adds value to your audience is crucial
for SE success and the next trend is
data analytics and AI data analytics and
AI tools are increasingly used for SEO
leveraging data driven insights Nai
technology helps in making informed
decisions personalizing content and
improvising user experiences these
Trends and challenges highlight the
importance of adapting to the
challenging landscape of SEO to maintain
and improve your website search engine
rankings and visibility now we'll start
with the SEO expert road map for
2024 so the first step is mastering the
basics that is on page and off page SEO
so we'll start with on page SEO and the
first keyword or the first features of
on page SEO is that is keyword research
understand how to perform keyword
research to identify relevant Search
terms for your content and then comes
the content optimization learn how to
optimize your web pages with high
quality relevant content and
strategically placed keywords within it
and then comes the meta tags familiarize
yourself with optimizing meta TXS
including title tags meta descriptions
and head Texs and then comes the URL
structure understand the importance of a
clean and SEO friendly URL structure and
then there is internal linking know how
to create an effective internal linking
structure to enhance user experience and
SEO and now coming to oage S we'll see
the features of it number one is
backlink building that is learn how to
to build high quality backlinks from
authoritative websites in your Niche
understand the importance of natural
earn backlinks for off page SEO then
comes the social signals comprehend the
role of social media in off page SEO and
how social signals can impact search
engine rankings and then comes the local
SEO for businesses targeting a local
audience Master local SEO strategies
including claiming your Google my
business listing and managing online
reviews and then comes the citation
building and understand the significance
of nap name address phone number
consistency for local SEO and citation
building and the next is brand manions
know how unlink brand manions can
contribute to off page SE and reputation
management by mastering these on page
and off page SEO Basics you will build a
solid foundation for the journey to
become an SE expert and now moving on to
the next step that is stay informed on
SEO Trends so continuously follow
industry block blogs webinars and
conferences to keep up with SEO Trends
and algorithm updates so now you'll see
the steps how you can achieve this step
so the number one is subscribe to SEO
blogs that is follow reputable SEO blogs
and websites like Moos search engine
land and search engine journal to get
the latest updates and insights in the
field the second is join SEO communities
participate in online SEO communities
and forums like reddits SEO or SEO Rel
ated groups on LinkedIn to discuss
Trends and learn from others in the
industry and now moving on to the next
that is webinars and conferences attend
SE webinars and conferences where
industry experts discuss new trends best
practices and algorithm updates keep an
ey out for both local and international
events now coming to the next that is
SEO newsletters subscribe to SEO
newsletters that provide regular updates
on industry news and Trends these
newsletters often curate valuable
information
now coming to the next that is podcast
listen to S podcast where experts share
their knowledge and insights podcast are
a convenient way to stay informed on the
go so this was all about the Second Step
that is stay informed on SEO Trends now
moving on to the next step that is
technical SEO proficiency so now we'll
see the steps how we can master in this
technical SEO proficiency and the number
one is site speed optimization ensure
your website loads quickly to improve
user experience and search engine
rankings compress images Minify CSS and
JavaScript and leverage browser caching
and the next is mobile friendliness
optimize your site for mobile users as
Google prioritizes mobile first indexing
use responsive design Test Mobile
usability and create mobile friendly
content and the next is schema markup
Implement schema markup to provide
search engines with structured data
about your content this can enhance rich
which Snippets in search results and
improve click- through rates and the
next is scalability and indexability
ensure that search engines can easily CW
and index your websites use a sitap
robots. txe and canonical tags to guide
search engines effectively and the next
is structure data Implement structure
data to help search engines understand
the content on your site better now
moving to the next step that is step
four that is content strategy and now
we'll see the features or the steps to
learn content strategy number one is
keyword research and targeting start
with Comprehensive keyword research to
identify relevant keywords and phrases
that your audience is searching for the
next is quality and relevance andure
your content is of high quality
informative and relevant to your target
audience then comes the content variety
diversify your content types including
blog post videos infographics and
podcast then comes the topic clusters
and Piller content Implement a topic
cluster strategy where you create Piller
content that is comprehensive guides or
Cornerstone articles and support it with
related in-depth articles and then comes
the content promotion develop a plan to
promote your content through social
media email marketing and Outreach so
this was about the fourth step now
coming to the fifth step that is eat and
user experience so eat that is expertise
authoritativeness and trustworthiness so
the first step to learn all these is
focus on demonstrating expertise in your
content by showcasing your
qualifications and expertise in the
subject matter establish
authoritativeness by earning backlinks
from reputable sources and ensure your
content is trustworthy and well
referenced and the next is user
centering content craft content that
genuinely serves the users need offering
valuable information and solutions and
then is transparent attribution clearly
attrib authors and their credentials for
the content reinforcing trust and
authority and then is the mobile
friendly user experience ensure your
website is mobile responsive as Google
values a positive mobile user experience
and then comes the user engagement
metrix monitor user engagement metrics
like click through rates bounce rates
and time on site now moving on to the
next step that is data analysis and
tools so now we'll see the steps to
learn data analysis and tools that is
the first step is Google analytics
Mastery learn how to set up and
effectively use Google analytics to
track website performance user behavior
and conversion metrics then comes the
Google search console proficiency that
is understand the insights and tools
available in Google search console to
monitor website visibility in search
results identify issues and optimize
content and then comes the keyword
research tools familiarize yourself with
keyword research tools such as seam Rush
sem Rush RFS and most to identify
valuable keywords and assess keyword
competition and then comes the SEO
auditing software utilize SEO auditing
tools like screaming frog or side bulb
to conduct comprehensive website audits
identify technical SEO issues and
optimize site structure and then comes
the data visualization skills develop
the ability to create visual reports and
dashboards to communicate SEO
performance data effectively to
stakeholders or clients and now moving
on to the seventh step that is link
building strategies and now we'll see
the steps for this step that is quality
or quality that is focus on acquiring
high quality authoritative back from
reputable websites rather than pursuing
a large volume of lowquality links the
next is natural link acquisition and
then comes the Outreach and relationship
building that is actively reach out to
relevant websites bloggers and
influencers to request backlinks and
then is the guest posting that is
contribute guest post to authoritative
websites in your Niche and show that the
content is valuable and relevant and
then comes the Monitor and ISO regularly
monitor your backlink profile to
identify and ISO any toxic or spammy
links that could harm your Su efforts so
this was all about the seventh step now
moving on to the next step that is
eighth algorithm changes so now we'll
see the steps what the algorithm changes
include so the number one is stay
informed that is regularly monitor SE
new sources and official search engine
announcements to stay up to date of any
upcoming algorithm changes the next is
adapt quickly when algorithm updates
occur be prepared to adjust your SEO
strategies promptly to align with the
new ranking criteria and requirements
the next is analyze impact and then
comes the audit and optimize that is
conduct regular site audits to identify
and address any issues that might affect
your website's ranking then comes the
diversify strategies a avoid over
Reliance on specific SEO tactics now
coming to the ninth step that is
structured SEO strategy now moving to
the steps that include the structured
SEO strategy the number one is keyword
research and targeting and then comes
the content planning that is create a
Content calendar that outlines when and
what type of content you will produce
and then comes the on page optimization
that is Implement on page SEO techniques
including optimizing meta tags and then
comes the link building strategy that is
developer strategy for acquiring high
quality backlinks and then comes the
performance monitoring that is regularly
track the performance of your Su efforts
using tools like Google analytics and
then comes the next step that is the
10th step that is certifications and
courses now we'll see the steps the
number one is choose reputable Su
certification programs op for well
recognized and reputable certification
program
such as Google analytics or Google ad
certification these certifications
demonstrate your expertise in specific
SEO areas and then comes the advanced
SEO courses consider enrolling in
advanced SEO courses offered by trusted
educational institutions such as
universities or online learning
platforms such as simply learn that have
postgraduate program for digital
marketing now moving on to the third
step that is specialized SEO
certification look for specialized SEO
certification from organization like Mo
or Hub Sport and then comes stay updated
the SEO field evolves rapidly so you
have to stay updated as this is crucial
for long-term success and then comes the
practical application seek out courses
that include Hands-On projects and
practical exercises by investing in
certifications and courses that align
with your career goals and staying
committed to continuous learning you
will be well on your way to becoming a
proficient Su expert now moving to the
next step that is 11th step that is
practice and experiment element and now
we'll see the steps in this step that is
AB testing that is conduct AB test to
compare different elements of your
website such as headlines images or
calls to action to determine what
resonate best with your audience and
improves SE results then comes the
keyword experimentation and that is
continuously test and refine your
keyword strategies explore new keywords
and then comes the content iteration
that is regularly update and improve
existing content based on user feedback
and analytics data and then comes the
link building strategies experiment with
various link building techniques
Outreach methods and content promotion
strategies to identify what works best
for Niche and audience and then comes
local SEO tactics experiment with
different local SEO techniques such as
optimizing Google my business profiles
soliciting reviews and running localized
ad campaigns to enhance your local
search visibility experimentation is a
critical aspect of su expert as it
allows you to fine-tune your strategies
Based on data and feedback ultimately
driving better results and now these are
the steps be owner SEO expert and for
the SEO road map 2024 now moving to the
job roles within the field of SEO so
there are various job roles within the
field of SEO each with its own set of
responsibilities and expertise here are
some common SEO job roles and we'll
start with SEO specialist SEO
Specialists are experts in optimizing
webs sites for search engines they focus
on on page and off-page SE optimization
keyword research and implementing Su
best practices and the average base
salary for sto specialist in United
States is
$150,000 per year and in India it is 11
lakhs perom and now coming to the next
job roll that is content strategies
content strategist are responsible for
planning and creating content that
aligns with SEO goals they develop
content strategies conduct even research
and ensure content is optimized for
search engines and their average salary
in United States is
$145,000 perom and in India it is 13
lakhs perom and then comes the technical
Su manager that is focus on the
technical aspects of a website such as
site structure page speed and mobile
optimization they work to improve the
website's technical performance for
better search rankings and the average
salary for technical SEO manager in
United States is
$120,000 and in India it is 10 lakhs
perom and now moving to link building
specialist link building specialist
concentrate on acquiring high quality
backlinks from authoritative websites
they play a crucial role in improving a
website's domain Authority and search
engine rankings and the average salary
for link building specialist in United
States is
$156,000 perom and then in India it is
88 lakhs perom and then moving to the
local SEO specialist that is local SEO
specialist focus on optimizing a website
for local search results they help
businesses appear in local searches
particularly important for Brick and
morar businesses and the average salary
in United States for local SEO
specialist is $15,000 perom and in India
that is 7 lakhs perom so these roles SC
to various aspects of SEO from content
creation and Technical optimizations to
local search and data analysis depending
on your interest and expertise you can
choose the role that best aligns with
your career goals in the field of SEO so
there you have it the SEO road map for
2024 SEO is a dynamic field and staying
ahead of the curve is key to your online
success make sure to stay tuned for more
in-depth videos on each of these topics
in the upcoming weeks greetings everyone
this is Rob Sanders from Simply learn
and today we're going to talk about
keyword research so what are we going to
talk about when we talk about keyword
research we're going to talk about why
we would do keyword research for SEO
we're going to talk about the types of
keywords that we need to research we're
going to talk about some methodologies
best practices on how to do keyword
research some alternate suggestions
we're going to talk about keyword
clustering and then we're going to talk
about some tools that you can use to do
your keyword research so let's start
with the why we would do keyword
research so Jesse is planning to publish
a Blog of pizza recipes so she was doing
Pizza recipes step by step pizza recipes
with sausage homemade pizza toppings
pizza dough recipes thin crust pizzas
she's doing a lot of different topics on
pizza recipes well what Jesse needs to
do is understand what's going to drive
traffic to these blog posts if she's
writing about you know different topics
around pizza recipes so she's Unsure how
these blogs are going to drive traffic
so she really needs to understand that
hey you need to choose the right
keywords to drive traffic so the
question is if you're writing a blog
post about recipes with sausages is
pizza recipes with sausages or recipes
for free the best keyword to use maybe
maybe not so you need to take uh care in
choosing the key words to align with
your content so that's really the idea
why we would do keyword research because
some of the issues with keyword words
that are poorly chosen are they could
have low search volume for example you
may choose a keyword that just a lot of
people aren't using to search for or
they can be highly competitive so if you
choose a keyword that's very broad or
popular it can be very competitive and
take you long time to be found for that
keyword or you could just make the
mistake of choosing a keyword that isn't
align with your content or you can
choose keywords but use them incorrectly
with your content so these are some of
the issues that you can counter if you
just go about choosing keywords randomly
without due diligence without the proper
research so low search volume will lead
to less traffic High competition you may
not even rank at all okay if somebody
finds you for a keyword that's not
relevant to the topic they're just going
to leave the page and if you're not
using the right keywords and or if you
are using the right keywords and not
using them correctly in the content then
your pages may not even be found in
organic search so you really have to
take care and choosing the keywords to
me that's the most important step with
SEO is keyword research so we're going
to talk about the types of keyword
research then so we have short tail
keywords and we have long tail keywords
so if you write a blog post about pizza
recipes well what are you going to
choose a short tail or long tail so
let's talk about short tail keywords
first so short tail keywords are
keywords that are usually three keywords
in a phrase or shorter in some cases it
may be two keywords in a phrase or
shorter so short tail keywords usually
have high search volume which means
likely means higher competition but what
it also means it could be lower
conversions because short tail keyword
like for example pizza recipes could be
considered a short tail key word but
maybe somebody's looking for homemade
pizza recipes or pizza recipes from
their favorite Italian restaurant so
short key words may not be as relevant
so if we compare it with longtail
keywords chances are you're going to
have lower competition that's one of the
benefits but you're also going to have
lower search volume but with longer tail
keywords the keyword is probably going
to be more relevant with the content
you're writing about so therefore the
conversion rates likely going to be
higher so that's really the difference
between short tail keywords and longtail
keywords if you want to look at
simplistically short tail keywords are
Broad in nature it's going to capture a
lot of eyeballs but those eyeballs May
look at your content is not relevant
versus longtail keywords that may be
very relevant but not as many eyeballs
on them so short tail keywords the
characteristics they're not as specific
usually they're less than three words
they have high search volume and high
competition so if you just choose pizza
recipes could take you a while to rank
for that keyword but when you rank
you're going to get the traffic but
again it may not convert because the key
word is Broad in nature so pizza recipes
is a short tail keyw that may not be
exactly what you're writing about in
your blog post so it may draw a lot of
traffic but the traffic may not do
anything so the longer tail keywords are
very specific they consist of more than
three words in the search query they
have relatively low search volume
competition so the chance of you ranking
higher faster for that long TI word is
probably going to be greater because not
many other websites are trying to rank
for that same key word and so the
benefit of that is is if you have let's
just say homemade pizza recipes with
mushrooms that's a long tiky word but if
somebody's looking for that type of
pizza recipe then you know you're going
to track the right traffic and chances
are that traffic is going to engage or
convert based on the type of conversion
you have in place so example would be
homemade pizza dough recipes that'd be
another example more than th key words
in the phrase very specific we're
talking about homemade pizza no recipes
so we're not talking about just pizza
recipes so it's a little bit more uh
specific in nature longer tail so these
keywords are used for targeted Pages
including blog posts if you're writing a
blog post specifically about pizza
recipes with homemade dough then this is
the keyword you likely would want to use
versus just pizza recipes so let's look
at an example between a short tail
keyword and a longtail keyword and to
accentuate the differences we're going
to use use Google's Keyword Planner tool
so Google's Keyword Planner tool is
located in Google ads the Google ads
platform and when you're in the Google
ads platform you can simply click on
tools and then Keyword Planner and so
what Keyword Planner allows us to do is
get a sense of the type of volume that a
particular keyword has so what Google's
Keyword Planner does is they show you
the average monthly searches this is the
average monthly search volume of a
keyword over the past 12 months and so
in this example we're going to choose
pizza recipes and homemade pizza dough
recipes so one short tail and one long
tail so we enter those keywords in we're
going to click get results and what
Google's going to do is it's going to
show us the volume of those keywords so
for pizza recipe we could see the
average monthly search volume is
33,100 for pizza recipe so note that
pizza recipe and pizza recipes are
closely related keywords and so what
Google does is they consider that a
close variance so meaning if somebody
ties in pie of recipe then they're also
in Google's eyes looking for pizza
recipes so it's a close variance and so
for the keyword pizza recipe which is
short tail we could see on average over
the past 12 months this keyword received
33,100 queries and so if we hover over
the graph we could see basically
the volume the average volume per month
so here I could see for this particular
keyword here the volume per month is
331,000 and then I can see the actual
volume over the past 12 months and then
for the longtail keyword I can see
homemade pizza dough recipe again close
variance homemade pizza dough recipes I
can see over the past 12 months with the
search volume is for this on average
it's 2400 but I could see here in
December the volume went up to 3600 but
for example in May it was 1,900 so it's
going to fluctuate a bit over the past
12 months but on average it's about 2400
so shorter tail a lot more volume longer
tail not as much volume but nonetheless
there is volume here and so these are
the differences between a short tail and
a longer tail and so what Google's
Keyword Planner also does is allow us to
get a sense of what the competition is
and so here I can see the competition is
low for both of these keywords fair
enough so we now know that if we want to
optimize or choose the keyword homemade
pizza dough recipe for our blog post we
know for ranked on page one of Google
even in the top spot we can expect about
2400 search queries for that keyword now
whether you get all 2400 clicks for that
keyword remains to be seen chances are
you're not going to get all 2400 you're
going to get Lion Share of those clicks
but you're going to at least get some
volume on it so even the longer T
keywords have a lot of Promise because
there is some search volume here for
this keyword how to do a proper keyword
research so we looked at Google's
Keyword Planner tool in Google ads and
we typed in two keywords and we were
able to get a sense of what the average
volume is so we definitely want to
choose key words based on the following
factors we want to choose it based on
search volume search volume is a good
indicator of the potential traffic we
can obtain so again for the key word
homemade pizza dough recipe we know that
it averages 2400 a month in search
volume again we may not get all 2400 but
we're going to get a line share that we
also need to look at competition and so
Google's Keyword Planner gives us a high
medium or low in terms of the
competition but if you're somebody who
wants to get a better sense of what the
competition is and you should because
competition is a key component in
choosing keywords and so what I want to
do is get a sense of how many people are
actually optimizing for that keyword so
Google's Keyword Planner tool is going
to give me a low medium high really what
I want to do is get a better sense of
that numerically so what I can do is go
into Google's search and I can type in
pizza recipes and I could see there's
about 1 billion results that's a lot of
results however
that means that every potential web page
out there on the internet that mentions
pizza recipes is going to be included in
this number here and so I want to get a
better sense of who's optimizing for
pizza recipes so I'm going to put in the
all and tile syntax and so what that is
going to ask Google to do is tell me all
the web sites that have pizza recipes
the keyword pizza recipes in the title
tag so if I do all in title colon space
than pizza recipes my result drops down
to 336,000 so what that tells me is that
there are 336,000 results with the
keyword pizza recipes in the title tag
now if I want to focus in on my other
keyword if I choose uh my other keyword
was a longer tail keyword homemade pizza
dough recipe so if I type that keyword
in so homemade pizza dough recipe or
recipes remember close variants and I
just click enter or type the keyword in
hit my Enter key I'm going to get 35
Million results but again is that really
an indicator of the type of competition
I have no because every listing that
mentions homemade pizza dough recipes is
going to be included in the search
results so I'm going to type in my all
en title colon space and then I'm going
to get a better sense of how many
websites have the keyword homemade pizza
dough recipes in the title tag and I get
2,160 different results so here I can
see the first result in the title tag
homemade pizza do recipe second one
homemade pizza dough recipe so these are
sites or web pages that have that
keyword in the title tag so now I have a
numerical number to work with and so the
thing you have to understand about SEO
specifically about keyword research is
you need to do research on a few
different keywords not just one or two
so what we want to do is have a
spreadsheet the spreadsheet is going to
contain keywords that we can potentially
want to optimize for choose as keywords
to optimize for SEO and so my
recommendation is you come up with a
theme first so the theme for us in this
exercise is pizza recipes and so that's
our theme so we chose the keyword pizza
recipes so the close variance here is
pizza recipe what was the volume well we
know the volume was 33,100 for pizza
recipe so what are we going to do we're
going to put that number in in our
volume column what was the competition
well if we go back and type in pizza
recipes it was 683 th000 so I'm going to
type in
683 th000 what was our next keyword well
it was pizza or homemade pizza dough
recipes so if I go back for this
particular keyword is $400 so I'm going
to put 2400 in under my volume column
and then what was my competition well my
competition was I type that keyword back
in 2,160 so I'm going to put
2,160 so now I have an idea of what kind
of volume and what kind of competition I
have now you want to do this for number
different keywords and when you do for
number keywords what you do want to do
is obviously choose a relevant keyword
that has high volume and low competition
so another way of saying it is the
volume or ratio of volume to competition
and so basically what we could do is
take volume divided by competition and
if I make that a percentage I could see
it's. 35% is the ratio between volume
and competition if I do the same for my
longer tail keyword 2400 divided by 2160
I can see that 111% so this just kind of
proves the point that yeah I'm still
going to get some volume but I have a
better chance of ranking for this longer
TL ke word homemade pizza rest recipes
so you want to be able to do that for
number keywords and examine the volume
the competition and the ratio between
volume and competition for your themed
keywords in this case pizza recipes so
relevancy you want to choose keywords
that are very relevant to the content
that you're writing and then again
commercial intent what keywords are
going to drive more conversions and
revenue for the business so when we talk
about commercial intent we're talking
about you know are you choosing keywords
that are going to get somebody to do
what you want them to do so we could say
You Know download pizza dough recipes so
somebody's typing in the keyword
download pizza dough recipes then
chances are they're going to find you
come to your side and take action by
downloading that pizza dough recipe so
you want to be able to also think about
the intent of the keyword is it going to
help you drive conversions and revenue
if you're an e-commerce site so search
volume is the average monthly search
volume made for a particular keyword and
phrase so we can get that number using
Google's Keyword Planner tool in the
Google ads platform we want to Target
keywords with high search volume that
will help bring traffic to the website
we want volume but we want to take into
account seasonality as well so that's
where the Google's Keyword Planner tool
comes in place because if we go back
again we can just hover over we can get
a sense of any particular Trend going on
or seasonality so for example if I saw
large growth in the winter months and
not much volume growth in the summer
months then that might indicate to me
that this keyword is more popular during
the winter time so pay attention to the
graphs that you know the Keyword Planner
tool gives you use them to your
advantage to take into account
seasonality so a good example would be
funny Halloween costumes well we know
that for Halloween you're going to have
a spike probably towards the end of
September all the way through October
and then it's going to drop after
October 31st which is Halloween so
that's an example but in the case of
pizza recipes you know you may find that
more people are choosing to search for
pizza recipes during maybe the summer
months versus the winter months so pay
attention to seasonality it will affect
search volume so competition based on
our example it's one of the most
important key metrics you don't want to
choose a key word that's highly
competitive because if it's competitive
then it's going to be harder to rank
number one or even on page one of Google
depending on competitive it is so high
search volume low competition in other
words the ratio between the two is the
ideal combination so going back to the
spreadsheet recommend you have that
spreadsheet handy put your theme in
place okay theme pizza recipes we use
Google's Keyword Planner tool to find
the volume we use the all entitle syntax
to find the competition so we entered
both of those numbers in and we get our
ratio and so when you have these numbers
for a number of different keywords you
want to be able to choose that ratio of
high volume low competition but always
relevancy always trumps ratio so always
go with a keyword that is going to be
relevant to your content don't choose a
keyword that's not relevant if you
choose a keyword that's not relevant
it's not going to bode well for user
engagement so the difficulty of a
keyword ranges from zero to 100 in
Google's keyword tool so it's going to
be easy it's going to be medium it's
going to be hard but my recommendation
is also to get the numerical factor and
that's the all and title syntax and
again relevancy is what drives the
traffic to your website and keep the
traffic there on your website and also
not only will it keep the traffic on
your website but hopefully get that
traffic to engage and convert so that's
the key about Rel
you always want to choose keywords that
are relevant to your content even if
it's sacrificing volume relevancy again
trumps volume and competition so always
choose relevant keywords first so when
you do that you're always almost
guaranteeing that at some point
somebody's going to find your content
because somebody out there might be
looking for it and if they do you're
going to get found and then the
engagement is going to be better so
understand your business find keywords
that are relevant to to your business
and then focus on those key words
that'll help you with getting the right
traffic to your site always keep in mind
the commercial intent so these keywords
are more specific and result in
conversion rate for example buying is a
good commercial intent keyword so if you
really want somebody to come to your
website and buy then focus on those
types of keywords in the case of the
pizza recipes maybe it's download could
be our commercial intent keyword again
there may be low search volume but those
are the type of keywords you want to
focus on because that's the type of
traffic you want to drive to your site
so some other examples of commercial
intent keywords or discount deal your
coupon shipping you don't don't be
afraid to use some of these keywords as
part of your longer tail keyword phrase
again the volume may not be high but the
traffic quality is probably going to be
better so keyword research is the
foundation for SEO so if you have chosen
your keywords properly then if you do
get ranked for the those keywords then
it's going to lead to better engagement
with some conversions and so when we
talk about keywords we also want to talk
about our primary and secondary keyword
so every page should have at least a
primary keyword and then a secondary
keyword to work with so primary keywords
are really defining the nature of your
content the secondary keywords are
relevant to the primary keyword so why
do we choose a primary and secondary
keyword because you may choose use a
keyword as a primary keyword that is
relevant to the content but may not
necessarily rank very high or have a lot
of volume that secondary keyword is also
relevant to the primary keyword but also
relevant to content and you may rank for
that secondary keyword so you always
want to go with two keywords versus just
one keyword you want to give your
yourself a chance to rank for least two
different types of keywords of relevant
nature so for web page there can be
several secondary keywords but only one
primary keyword so your primary keyword
is always going to be relevant to your
content secondary keywords can be
relevant to the keyword but and you may
have multiple secondary keywords but
it's also going to be related to the
content and it gives you a better
opportunity to be found between both the
primary and secondary in search Okay so
let's take a look at another example of
how to use primary keywords and
secondary keywords when choosing
keywords so if a primary key key word is
healthy diet plan remember healthy diet
plan is directly related to the content
so that's what we're talking about but
these secondary keywords are also
related to content and play off the
primary keyword and so what we want to
do is go to co Google's Keyword Planner
tool and get an idea of the volume for
healthy diet plan and then also the
volume and competition for some of these
secondary keywords like healthy diet for
weight loss healthy diet food low carb
diet healthy mail plans and diet plan
weight loss so if I go in to Google's
Keyword Planner and type those keywords
in I'm going to choose get results and
now here I could see healthy diet plan
keyword I'm focusing on as my primary
keyword has an average monthly search
volume of
99,900 and then some of my secondary
keywords healthy diet foods diet plan
weight loss low carb diet you know
Google will give me a number of
different keywords to work with so I'm
going to look at to search volume of
those as well and so ideally what I want
to do is be able to then look at the
volume and then look at the competition
so healthy diet plan I go into my
keyword analysis here that's my theme so
that's my keyword what's my volume for
healthy diet plan
99,900 what's my competition so my
competition is
74,700 and that's going to give me a
ratio of volume to competition of 133%
so that's what my content about that's a
considered a short tail keyword because
it has a lot of competition and so my
ratio is 13% and what I want to do is I
want to be able to put these other
secondary keywords in here as well maybe
even go to a little longer tail because
I want to be able to find two key at
least two keywords I want to be able to
find my primary keyword that's relevant
to my content and then I want to be able
to find my secondary keyword which is
again related to the primary keyword
which is also related to the content and
so I want to be able to choose two
keywords basically and I want to choose
two keywords that are relevant that have
good ratio between volume and
competition so that's the whole idea
again of how to do keyword research you
want to be able to find your keywords
use the tools available to you and get a
sense of what the volume is what the
competition is look at the ratio between
the volume and competition and then
based on the content choose that primary
keyword and then again based on the
keyword you chose choose some secondary
keywords as well because you want to be
found for not just one keyword but
multiple keywords okay let's look at
some alternative suggestions to keyword
research so for doing keyword research
we want to take into account LSI
keywords we could take into account
other platforms that host a lot of
content like Kora or Reddit we can use
Google suggestions in the keyword search
bar we can use use popular platforms
like Wikipedia and we can use social
media bookmarking like Reddit so there
are lots of suggestions that we can
obtain from various sources so let's
start with LSI keywords and LSI stands
for latent semantic insect indexing and
so basically what it is it's just
keywords that are linked to your primary
keyword and so when you're choosing
keywords you always want to choose that
primary keyword and then secondary
keywords that are similar to the primary
keyword and usually those are LSI or
latent semantic indexing type keywords
so they're used to drive relevant
traffic to your page so if you're
focusing on one keyword we want to have
other keywords that are similar to
increase our visibility on the search
engine result pages so we could find
latent semantic indexing right in search
so if we use the term healthy diet if we
go to Google search for example if I
type in healthy diet in Google search
all I need to do is scroll to the bottom
of the page and I can see searches
related to healthy diet so healthy diet
menu healthy diet essay what does a
healthy diet look like notice at the top
Google's also given me some other
suggestions here so they're saying
lowfat diet veganism gluten-free diet so
there's lots of different suggestions
right in Google search bar so all of
these are LSI related keywords so if
you're optimizing a page for healthy
diet then you could choose lowfat diet
as a secondary keyword you can use
gluten-free diet as a secondary keyword
it really depends on what the content is
but you always want to support your
content with as much LSI keywords as
possible so you can be found for as many
different keywords as possible in Google
search so it's important because if you
have a Blog that you know talks about
python so how do the search engines know
if the website python is about the
programming language or snake so Google
for example uses LSI keywords to
understand what the page is specifically
focusing on so if you're just focusing
on Python and your content you want to
support that with LSI keywords and so
that will allow your web page to better
communicate with Google also to have the
visibility to show up on search so they
can certainly improve your search
positioning and featured Snippets as
well so if you have a keyword that
answers a question you could certainly
found for Featured snippet for example
maybe you know healthy diet recipes if I
type that in you can see here there's a
featured snippet so if I'm talking about
recipes that's a keyw I may want to use
and if I use that then Google has an
opportunity to see what my content's
about and place my information at the
top in this featured snippet you can
also again see what some of questions
are being asked what meals are good for
weight loss what is a good healthy diet
plan all of these could be keyword
phrases that you can use so the answers
are right here in Google so Kora is a
great platform because Kora is a
platform that people go and ask
questions and a community responds with
answers or responses to that particular
question or topic and so the great thing
about cor is it's a good it's a good
place for you to go to get some ideas
about a specific topic so if we're
talking about healthy dieting so we can
find key words with high search volume
writing Kora so the whole idea is you
can look at you know the top five
questions for specific topic like
healthy dieting and find relevant key
wordss to healthy dieting so if you just
type in that particular key word in Kora
you're going to probably get some
responses to questions or responses to
somebody else's question and so if we
take a look at core for example so if I
just type in healthy dieting what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get some
responses to the the top healthy dieting
so what's the best diet for Healthy
Living what are the top five tips for a
healthy diet habit so all of these could
be keyword phrases that you could take
away with for your own content and so
the benefit here is you're getting kind
of an idea of what's trending what
people are talking about and if you use
tips for a healthy diet habit for
example and you optimize for that well
again that could turn around and bode
well for you because you could be
featured in Google as a featured snippet
at the top here you can also turn around
and use LSI related keywords for healthy
diet habits and you can simply just look
for those LSI keywords right in Google
remember at the bottom or at the Top If
I scroll down I can see some related LSI
keywords at the bottom so writing Google
as well you could see in the Google
search bar that Google provides some LSI
related keywords to your query so if I
go back here and type in healthy diet
recipes I can see here Google suggesting
some other related keywords healthy diet
menu healthy diet for men healthy diet
foods healthy diet for women so these
are all LSI related keywords that you
can use to support your primary keyword
and the content you're writing about so
we've talked about LSI keywords where to
find them so they're found right here
they could be found at the top of Google
and they could be found at the bottom
you can also then go to core as well and
get some ideas for the types of
questions they're being asked so if you
ask a question and use that as your
keyword phrase then again you have an
opportunity of showing up for a featured
snippet in Google just by doing some
additional research within Google itself
or on Coral so according to Google the
autocomplete predictions are
automatically generated by Google's
algorithm without any human intervention
it's based on a number of factors but
the primary factor is how often past
users have searched for terms so Google
collects all the keyword quer that
somebody types in and they're suggesting
some of the most popular terms that
people have typed in so if I go back to
Google again if I start type in recipes
I could see some of the other queries
that somebody else has typed in or some
of the most popular queries related to
that topic so if you enter the keyword
healthy diet Google's going to suggest
multiple keyword suggestions that users
have asked in the past and you could
certainly get the search volume of those
keywords just by looking in Google
itself S I could see for healthy diet
recipes billions of pages related to
healthy diet recipes I can also get the
search volume by going into Google's
Keyword Planner so if I type in healthy
diet I'm going to be able to see what my
search volume is for that keyword and in
addition I can see the seasonality of
that particular keyword and in addition
to that Google's going to provide some
other related keywords to my search
query so if I'm looking for healthy diet
Google's going to suggest hey maybe you
should choose healthy food or healthy
eating or how to lose weight so those
are LSI related keywords that Google
provides in the keyword plan which is
built into the Google ads platform
another option for you is Wikipedia so
Wikipedia is a vast platform of content
so we could turn Wikipedia into our own
asset and use it to our own Advantage by
finding relevant keywords in an easy
fashion so with Wikipedia IIA we can
identify a list of keywords in The Meta
description itself we could choose
keywords from the P paragraph of
Wikipedia it has many relevant keywords
or we can take a look at keywords from
the Wikipedia content section so we can
also see additional Pages like the C
also section that gives relevant
keywords that you're looking for we can
also look at the references section as
they contain relevant keywords so if we
go to Wikipedia as an example and I type
in healthy diet into Wikipedia here I
can get just in the first paragraph
alone I can see some additional keywords
that I might choose to use like
micronutrients I never knew that
micronutrients was related to healthy
diet but Wikipedia is providing some
information about what micronutrients is
and maybe I can use that as a keyword an
LSI related keyword to my content so if
I scroll down I can the see also section
so it might give me some information
food information consumers for example
dietary guidelines I can look at
categories like dietetics and diets I
can also look at the references section
so I can also see what information was
provided like health effects of
overweight and obesity I can look at
diet and physical activity so all of
these are related to my main keyword
healthy diet so the answers are right in
here on the platform they're just all
over the page so Wikipedia has an
abundance of you just need to know where
to look so again with Wikipedia you can
look no further than the first paragraph
you can look no further than the c alsoo
section the referencing section category
section there's lots of information
right on the page itself to help you get
ideas for keywords so if you Google your
keyword with Wikipedia term in the
search query and get relevant keywords
from the title tags and the Ser you can
also do that as well so if I type in
healthy diet Wikipedia and search I can
also get some information here here as
well so people also search for healthy
food advantages or healthy food habits
essay or information about healthy food
all of these are related to my keyword
healthy diet so again another bit of
information for you to choose or look to
choose some additional keywords for it's
a Reddit it's a popular Community where
people post content discuss a variety of
topics so that's what Reddit is so with
the help of subreddits and individual
can find relevant keywords with with
high search volume so in Reddit there's
an easy way to find out keywords they
have a keyword tool called keyword it so
keyword it gives the average monthly
searches for a particular keyword so if
we type a Word and key rdit and choose
keywords from the autogenerator list
this tool will extract the keywords and
give us those relevant terms with search
volume so if we go to the keyword it and
Show an example of that for example
healthy food if I get key keywords I can
see what keywords are relevant and the
search volume of that keyword so if I
just type in healthy food keyworded tool
is going to tell me some relevant
keywords and what the volume is so if
you don't have the Keyword Planner tool
in Google ads available to you this is a
good alternative solution to finding
keywords so it's free you just need to
go to keyword it.com type in your
keyword click get keywords and what it's
going to do is give you some relevant
keywords related to your primary keyword
with the search volume let's talk about
keyword clustering now so the whole idea
about keyword clustering is to really
take advantage of the keywords that
we're optimizing for to gain higher
ranking so if we can cluster keywords
together in a theme and that theme of
keywords is relevant to a specific page
of a website then we have a better
opportunity to rank so in other words
why do we have to Target just one
keyword
when we can Target many so keep in mind
you know LSI keywords we want to group a
bunch of keywords together that are
similar core content so for example
after some keyword research you can
thematically group keywords into a core
topic so for example we can cluster
these group of keywords together like
for example what is SEO how does SEO
work intro to SEO what are the basics of
SEO all of those are related to the
court theme what is SEO another cluster
of keywords for example could be SEO
techniques SEO best practices tips and
tricks website optimization on pageo
techniques Etc so those are clusters of
keywords okay that we can group together
in themes and if we group keywords
together in themes we can apply that to
a particular content on our website so
the whole idea behind clustering
keywords it's going to provide more
diversity more of an opportunity for us
to be found
so that's the whole idea behind
clustering so some additional steps
remember stay up to date on industry
news so brainstorm your ideas first and
identify a list of keywords IE a theme
of keywords that you can cluster
together and then you could determine
the keywords that your competitors are
already ranking for so for example if we
want to rank for the keyword SEO best
practices for example we can use a tool
called keyword MZ if I go to keyword the
keyword Explorer tool in MZ and just
type in SEO best practices what it's
going to do is it's going to give me
some volume related to that particular
keyword but more importantly what it's
also going to do is going to show me
what pages are already ranked for that
particular keyword so therefore I can
get a sense of who is already ranking
for that keyword so here I can see mzz
medium.com alexa.com so I can get a
sense of of what web pages are ranked
for a particular keyword or group of
keywords I want to rank for myself SEO
is an important part of the marketing
strategy in case your website doesn't
show up on the first page of the search
engine then you need to work on it to
solve all your SEO related problems
we've come up with a solution welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel and today
we will be discussing the top 10 tips
that every marketer needs to know so
let's get started and see the first step
the first step is voice search now voice
search will impact search queries in
2021 according to dialog tech.com
in the United States of America 55% of
the households will have their own smart
speaker by
2022 well that's a lot so if you're
planning to optimize your voice search
consider choosing wise
keywords find out longer phrases that
Searchers use in Daily life
conversation voice search is a more
suitable way for searching long and more
natural sounding phrases creating
detailed and relevant answers are
essential when optimizing for voice
search so always remember to create
Persona based content next create web
pages that can answer FAQ use because
when Searchers ask a question they begin
their question with words like who when
what however there are many reasons for
using voice search such as dictating
text messages looking for a video on
YouTube calling a person from your
contact list asking for directions Etc
according to Forbes voice search
drastically improves your user
experience due to its extensive use
search engines such as Google are
focusing on voice search optimization
Google's voice search shows websites on
top that load quickly in that case you
must always ensure that your website has
a responsive design its images are
optimized the files are compressed
implementation of website caching is
done properly to improve page speed and
finally the last important Point your
server's response time is
reduced now the second step in the
process is the mobile
optimization now you must already know
how important it is to make your site
mobile friendly for a better user
experience but did you also know that
having a mobile friendly application
impacts your search engine
optimization sem Rush confirms that by
the year 2025 approximately 70% of
Internet users will access the internet
through mobile devices Google's mobile
friendly update has resulted in a big
change in search rankings with the help
of Google's free mobile friendly test
have a look at how effective your mobile
website is is also take a peek at the
mobile usability report in Google's
search console now let's talk about tip
number three that is Google's eight
principles Google has confirmed that
content quality is an essential factor
for ranking on search engine result
pages but what does quality mean to
Google well content that fulfills the
Google eat principle will rank higher
eat stands for expertise authoritative
and
trustworthiness these elements will
determine if a web page has a useful
quality content Google uses the
combination of algorithms to deliver the
best results for users Google Panda is
one of the famous algorithms of Google
which emphasizes delivering highquality
content it removes web pages from the
index that have lowquality and duplicate
content not just that there is one more
algorithm called
rankbrain rank brain is is a processing
algorithm that uses machine learning to
interpret search queries that users
search on Google whereas the searched
query may not have the right keywords
that were searched
for for example when you're searching
for chocolate cake recipes you will also
get results for chocolate truffle cake
recipes on the search engine results
page Google Panda and rank brain send
Bots to crawl each and every website and
as a result shows highquality content on
the top of the search engine results
page next is our tip number four
featured
snippet these results are featured on
the top part of the page Google
programmatically chooses the best answer
from the thirdparty website and displays
it on the featured snippet here's what a
featured snippet looks like according to
ahrs for a specific search query almost
99% of web pages shown in the featured
snippet already rank on sep's first page
some of the ways to optimize featured
Snippets are organize your content in a
structured way make sure one article
answers many similar questions use
eye-catching images and the last point
is to create answers with tables to
drive clicks and write dedicated
headings to answer featured Snippets
like is red meat healthy suppose you
want to create Snippets plan on creating
question-based questions along with the
relevant keywords for ideas you can also
look at the Google search function that
is usually written in the blue color and
it reads out as people also ask so now
let's move to the fifth tip image
optimization according to sem Rush image
optimization will play a prominent role
in search in case the images on your
website aren't optimized make sure to
take care of them right now remember to
use highquality images relevant images
and use a suitable label for your image
file include images in your site map as
it becomes easier for the Bots to crawl
and finally use alt tags as crawlers use
it to classify the images alt text is
displayed on the web page when an image
fails to load on a user screen it is
also utilized by Google to drive meaning
from images
a well optimized image can improve your
page ranking and increase the engagement
on it image optimization can help your
web page show up in the image carousels
on search
engines next we have semantically
related
keywords semantic search will have
become an important factor for ranking
in the future semantic keywords are
linked to the primary keywords they
drive relevant traffic on search engine
result Pages a simple simple way to look
for LSI keywords is on Google
sep semantic search can be performed
wisely by writing content that targets
the question that your target audience
is looking for remember to optimize
content for topic clusters instead of
focusing solely on keywords and finally
use structured data and pick your
semantic keywords this can also be done
with the help of a comprehensive keyword
tool it finds out semantically related
keywords next comes tip number seven
building quality
links building quality links to your
website is important if you are aiming
to manage a successful and long-term SEO
strategy building quality links cannot
be ignored in 2016 Google declared that
building quality links are one of their
top three ranking signals always opt for
quality over quantity as building
quality links to your content can give
your product and category Pages a boost
in
scps let me share a few effective
strategies that will increase the number
of links pointing to your website
dramatically the first one earn
backlinks from relevant and
authoritative web pages next promote
your content regularly on social media
opt for guest blogging and influencer
marketing next take advantage of social
media platforms like Facebook Twitter
Instagram and start your own page then
participate in forums to engage with
your target audience start your blog and
attract your target audience with your
valuable content finally get listed in
the highquality link directories this
will help you build links from
authoritative
websites next number eight is local
search
listings local SEO is is the practice of
optimizing a website in order to obtain
traffic from location-based searching it
is the best way to Market your products
and services to local
customers according to Google local
results are based on relevance distance
and prominence these factors help Google
to find the best match for your search
for this reason it becomes important to
have your nap details accurate and
consistent across the internet
sem Rush confirms that local search
listings will play a larger role in the
SEO
strategies suppose you want to know how
to get your business in the local pack
go to Google my business page and create
your own for this it is also important
to have a strong backlink
profile next we have number nine that is
improve the user experience for the past
few years ux has become an important
ranking factor for Google however more
and more SEO Specialists have gained an
interest in
ux uux optimization is nothing more than
focusing on the visitor consider the
partnership of search engine
optimization and user
experience this way the search engine
optimization focuses on search engines
and user experience targets website
visitors so both share a common goal of
giving users the best result this is
what the content King app says about the
user
experience let me show you a few
practices on how to effectively leverage
ux designs to provide your site's SEO
performance simplify your site's
navigation a good site architecture
helps to gain traffic utilize ux design
to SEO friendly layouts which means make
content easy to digest in infused images
and videos whenever possible use ctas
very
wisely and finally optimize for site
load speed optimize for mobile
responsive design as more than 50% of
all the traffic is now driven by mobile
search in case your site isn't mobile
responsive you will notice poor
engagement and finally we come to our
10th and last
tip that is using schema
markup according to search metrics 36%
of Search keywords bring up at least one
feature snippet that is derived from
schemo markup schemo markup is Micro
Data that every individual can add to
his website in order to give an enhanced
description to users on a search engine
results page in simple words schema
markup is used to define website
content
adding structured data will give your
website a significant SEO boost and
increase your
rankings some of the schema markup
examples are ratings and reviews image
thumbnails product availability and
finally site links adding schema markup
to your HTML is one of the ranking
factors hello everyone welcome to this
new video by simply learn search engine
optimization has been playing an
essential role in the success of various
businesses for those who are still
looking for growth in the industry and
have search engine optimization
otherwise known as SEO as their primary
weapon then yes you are in the right
place this video on how to rank number
one on Google will give you the best
tips to get a higher ranking without
spending a penny but before we begin
subscribe to our Channel simply learn
and hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from Simply learn so before
before we begin I have a question for
you the process of getting the quality
and quantity of traffic to your website
organically is known as search engine
marketing search engine optimization
search engine advertising or none of the
above let me know your answers in the
comments section Below in this video
first we will understand why it's
essential to rank high in search engines
next we will have a look at the top five
mantras on how to get ranked number one
on Google search result pages
and while understanding this we will put
a light on why these success tips are
important for getting a good ranking and
how we can actually implement it we will
share some necessary tools to help you
carry out the needed process and stick
to the end of this video to find out the
one thing that can impact your business
tenfold so definitely we're going to
take a look at the best tips for ranking
high on Google but before that it is
necessary to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google well we
we are all aware that most of the
businesses are shifting online nowadays
ranking on search engines has become one
of the most important aspects that
Define the success of a business the
data states that around 1.17 billion
people across the globe use Google
search which is estimated to increase
exponentially in the coming years
moreover Google has gained the trust of
their users with their services over the
years this definitely makes the point of
interest to understand why it's
important to rank high on Google search
ranking at the top of search engine
result pages also known as Surs allows
the business to generate more traffic to
their website and possibly get more
leads by which then they can get a
chance to convert leads into customers
thereby boosting sales it also helps in
generating authenticity for your
business well not one or two there are
numerous reasons which makes SEO
important to know more about SEO check
the complete play playlist on SEO you
can find the link to the playlist in the
description box below to gain expertise
in search engine optimization get
certified as a skilled SEO professional
with simply learns search engine
optimization training course you can
check the course details from the link
in the description box below as we know
how important it is to rank high on
Google so in the next 10 minutes let's
get to know the top five success mantras
that will help you rank high in Google
so the fifth tip on our list is promote
your content whether you are a business
owner or a blogger you definitely need
to promote your content to get a good
audience reach by content here we mean
data on your website that can be
products services or even a simple blog
to do this find the relevant groups on
the social media platforms like Facebook
or Instagram and post your content with
an excellent call to action context some
blogging or article submission sites
like Kora Tumblr and hub pages may also
prove helpful online forums and
communities can be a good option to
spread a word about your content with
people having similar interests let's
focus on our number four tip internal
linking a good site architecture is
always a happy bite for webcrawlers a
website with good site architecture and
internal linking helps web crawlers
understand the website structure and
helps them to crawl the site more
effectively the more the pages of your
website are crawled greater are the
chances of getting indexed if pages are
successfully indexed they get eligible
for appearing in the search results
let's move to our tip number three yes
it is backlink building any website
linking to your website is a backlink
for your website websites with more
backlinks suggest to the search engine
crawlers that that website has good
content and is trustworthy and should be
ranked higher on the search result pages
to get a backlink the most important
thing is to understand that the da or
the domain authority of the website for
which you are looking for the backlink
is greater than yours getting back links
is somewhat entirely a gesture of
Goodwill you can find a page relevant to
your business and ask the website owner
to add the link to your website to the
page in a humble manner you can create a
better or updated version of some other
web content let the site owner know
about it and then ask for a backlink in
a humble way yes you can find some more
relevant backlink Bild building
techniques in the video how to build
backlinks check out the link in the
description box below at number two we
have a tip which is of utmost importance
to win a good position in the search
results onpage optimization onpage
optimization or also known as onpage SEO
is a process in which we take essential
measures to improve the website or web
pages position in search engine rankings
onpage optimization is a vast concept
that includes technical optimization of
websites like server speed page loading
speed removing page errors submitting
Pages for indexing and more maintaining
a good website structure and improving
it adding internal and external links on
the site adding SEO optimized images and
video on the page efficient use of
keywords on the page and links and much
more get the detail guide to learning on
page optimization by simply learn check
the link in the description box below
and finally the best tip we have is the
most effective one and the one that
rules them all which is keyword research
keyword research is a process of
identifying and implementing the
relevant keywords for the content you
tend to create proper keyword research
may prove a boom to your business but it
also has the power to ruin your business
so be wise When selecting your keywords
try choosing longtail keywords if you
are new to the business as these are
easier to rank for you can look at
Google's Autos suggest feature to
understand what people are looking for
in your industry be updated with what
your competitors are doing if something
is working for your competitor there are
high chances that it may work for you as
well you can also take the help of
various keyword research tools like
Google's own Keyword Planner answer the
public tool Google Trends and Etc these
fantastic and 100% practical tips can
drive your business to Heights make sure
you implement all these tips with more
detailed attention as SEO can make and
break you so what according to you is
the most effective way to grow your
business online let us know in the
comments below so if you are looking to
grab a career in digital marketing
simply learn has got you covered with
wide range of top-notch digital
marketing courses these courses make you
skill in SEO content marketing PPC
social media marketing and much more
with hands-on experience in the tools
like Google analytics Keyword Planner
Sim rush and there is huge list on board
however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course find
the course Link in the description box
hey guys welcome to today's session my
name is achin seel and I'm here to talk
about a very important tool Google ads
and out of all the ads we can create
under Google ads today we would be
talking about a very important one
Google search ad so this is going to be
very exciting this is going to be very
deep from my experience I can say I will
going to take you through a lot of
technical aspects and a lot of
optimization strategies where you can
really bring down the cost down if
you're really paying high for your
clicks and conversion so please be with
me and I would try to give you the best
from my site great so let's just start
guys Google ads is something which we
have discussed in the last class if you
have seen my last session if you you
have not we will leave the link in the
description where we talked about the
basics of Google ads and we also talked
about how to create this beautiful ad
account or a tool with a free Gmail ID
okay we did talked about few more things
that how many types of ads you can
create just to give you the quick
Glimpse we are on Google and when we
type something like if I want to do a
data analytics
course so I type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called text ad or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create create
under the Google ads there are few more
just like if you would go and search for
any of the e-commerce product probably
by
winter
jacket
online so then there would be results
but in a different shape and color and
different structure there is an ad which
is a text ad but on the top we are able
to see some more ads but they are not
just text they have a pricing they have
a title they have a brand name they have
a image of the product so they are
called shopping ads or product listing
ads in addition to that sometimes you
know when you go to a product uh a
website like speed test and you see the
product ads
there but again in the different shape
and color so they are called display ads
because they've been displayed on
different websites and different apps so
why I'm going so fast in explaining you
different type of ads because as I told
you we have another video created uh
with the name of uh Google ads for
beginners 2023 you can just check the
link in the description and you will
able to get all this type of ads and
whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just as
to show you if you can see that adds
back Google so this is the display ad or
a banner just quickly I have shown you
three types of the ads but our Focus as
I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which is the most important
ad from the Google ads family okay so
let's just begin
guys when I come to Google ads this is
how the Google ad structure looks
like we have a Google ads account
created again I repeat if you don't know
how to create it please find the link in
the description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you you would have a
dashboard like this okay in this
dashboard you can see there are
campaigns there are ad groups there are
ads there are videos there are landing
pages so a lot of things can be
confusing if you are just coming to this
account or to this beautiful tool for
the very first time so to just keep it
very simple or to explain in uh in a
very simpler way what I did is I just
drawn this structure for you okay so the
structure says that you have a Google
ads account imagine that I am a simply
learn Google ads manager so I am running
the ads for all simply learn keywords
like data analytics course digital
marketing course or any machine learning
course python course so whenever
somebody types this so there is a ad
which shows like from Simply learn
probably we have to just assume because
currently I'm not able to see any simply
learn ad here so data analytics course
India and then probably we can see if
there are any you can always change the
keywords but just to test I'm uh
randomly changing the words or I could
have just written simply Lear
specifically because I want to go with
simply learn only I have researched a
lot and I feel like this is one of the
best okay so probably there is no ad
though still I will
check probably have to just change the
codes
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can expect any of the ads
running because this is not a very peak
time so we are probably you know saving
some of the cost not running the ads at
this odd hour anyhow so we can assume
that this is the ad you know I am
running for so how we can create this ad
how we can get the best of clicks as I
said it is not the very best time to run
the ad so this is also Al kind of a
change you know we can bring into our
ads by doing some research so how all
these things are done we're going to be
learning it okay so when we come here to
the dashboard and then we see our
dashboard looks like this a bit
complicated so we can be confused we can
be disheartened that I have created the
account by seeing uh the first video but
now I am all stuck okay so probably I
have to again wait so the wait is over
now we are here to understand the whole
structure okay so let me just take a
very simple example suppose
I uh am someone who selling a shoes okay
because I have just said simply Lear
probably let's just convert it to any of
the Google ads account of a shoe seller
probably I'm Nike okay and I am making
the ad for Nike shoes and I am selling
uh two types of the Nike shoes today
probably formal or Canvas OR probably
I'm selling the casual or any sports
shoes and what I did I created the
campaign named it search ad uh any month
you know whatever the month you have
started with suppose November so
November 2022 that is the name which I'm
giving name can be changed name is
something which is being puted up for my
reference so that after creating lot of
campaigns I'm not confused in which
campaign I have to check the results
okay so I'm running the search chart for
shoes for the month of February or
November or December 22 23 whatever and
then I open two ad groups into it why
I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I'm
selling formal also under the shoes only
I'm selling casual also so what happen
suppose I would have just you know
created one at group and would have
inserted or uh submitted all the
keywords of formal and Casual inside one
ad group then if somebody would have
searched a term called formal black
shoes then this ad group would have got
confused that should I show formal ad
shoes or should I show casual art shoes
because what I did I have just got all
my keywords like formal casual Cricket
shopping jogging party office you know
all the mixed of the keywords from
formal and Casual family into the same
ad group the moment any of these six
keywords been typed or being searched on
Google then this ad group would have got
triggered and then again randomly it
would have shown the ad of a formal or
ad of a casual because both of the ads
would have been under this okay but
after doing uh this bif foration or
after doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here this ad
group would trigger if any of this
keyword would searched and accordingly
this ad which has everything related to
only formal shoes will be shown and of
course with that add the landing page
which is connected
which would be open you know when
somebody clicks the ad okay and wi of
Versa if somebody would have searched
for a casual term like a casual shoes
sports shoes jogging shoes running shoes
then this ad group would have triggered
and then the casual shoes ad with all
the headline related to that casual
keywords would have been shown and
accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shows uh you know would have opened okay
so if this is clear actually you are
very much ready to uh dive into the
Google ads because many people takes a
lot of time to understand the structure
because uh you know maybe they are very
much confused at the ad group level but
I have just tried my level best by
bringing this example why I am creating
two different ad groups why I'm not just
going with the same ad group you know
mixing all the
keywords second scenario could have been
or a second permutation could have been
I would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns Al
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign Al together and I would have
named it campaign search ad casual shoes
November then this second campaign or a
second campaign can be assumed here with
you know with a green color would have
been drawn okay so this is how on the
structure it works like we can always
now create inside so let's just see a
few things uh before we create the ad
okay very important uh requirement or
rather I would say uh if being the
campaign manager of any any any any any
company you name any startup you name or
any client you work with or probably for
yourself as well you have to be very
much sure how these terms works like
Okay so this terms when I talk about is
going to be bit inclined towards the
search ad today only and when I talk
about the display ad in the next video
then I would you know take you through
about the terminologies and all the kis
of display Banner or a video ads okay so
now if I talk about a search ad a very
important um term which we should be
aware of is the maximum bid price okay
because we all know when we talking
about this ad which is called a text ad
then we are paying on every click okay
that's why this is also called PPC ad
this is also called PPC marketing or you
can understand in a very simple words uh
Advertiser which uh is emiritus this in
this particular ad only has to pay when
somebody like such In This Moment
clicking this ad I click this ad I reach
to the landing page of this particular
University or this college and and a
certain amount is deducted from this
particular ad account and that certain
amount actually decides or decided on
the basis of the keyword helped to show
this ad okay so as an Advertiser must
have paid something to Google ads for
showing this ad for this keyword okay so
when I say a maximum bit price it means
it's a maximum bid price of a keyword
that's why now this would be easier to
understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course
2022 what I did I have open the Google
Keyword Planner you know I did talked
about this in the previous session but I
will take you through again how you use
a Keyword Planner smartly so I have got
this data from the keywords planner that
the average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ADD is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I I have bided something over
the minimum bid price okay this is the
minimum bid price this is the maximum
bid price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take um chance maybe 30 40%
over the minimum bid range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bit price but
coming back to the terminologies what we
talking here is once I have seted up my
maximum bid price of 7 rupees then my ad
would start showing suppose my ad shows
for thousand times today and every time
when my ad been clicked you know certain
amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertis
iers also you know who are running the
ad and after showing my ad for the whole
day Google in the dashboard just shown
that you have paid average CPC of 5
rupees only so I bid it for seven but by
seeing different uh you know factors
like the competition the demand and how
many times the ads got clicked what was
the position where my ad was shown I
ended up in paying 5 rupees for every
Click by the end of a day so the average
SE CPC sometimes you know people get
confused they have a CPC and the maximum
bid price the same no so maximum bid
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my ad to show on
certain keyword for every click and have
a CPC is something which actually you
know I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks uh for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword uh submitted and
suppose I got 100 clicks then you know
it's a simple math that my budget which
I have spent today is 5 rupees for one
click 500 rupees for 100 click so daily
budget would be 500 rupees and tomorrow
if company says I need 300 clicks then
of course my uh average CPC which I have
from the historical date of yesterday
you know I would just do my maths and I
will going to submit the daily budget of
not 100 rather 300 today so that in,
1500 I can expect 300 clicks at the cost
of 5 rupees per click okay so this is a
very simple of the example to just make
you explain how things works you know
you submit something then on the basis
of a lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds uh this screenshots
over so your Keyword Planner opens and
then you discover the keyword suppose I
am selling data analytics course so I
would just put my search term data
analytics course and then I'll click the
get result and then accordingly it will
show me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and high price so I would
take the 30 40% over the low bit price
or the average price between these both
and that would be my maximum bit price
and after checking all the permutations
Google would show my ad or either it
would not show my ad also there can be a
chance so I have to just wait for my
impression and clicks and the results by
the end of a day and I would you know I
would know uh how much the average CPC
actually I'm paying for each keyword
okay so I'll show you all those reports
in a while uh that's it right now let's
just go and see few things so the
Keyword Planner will start with suppose
I start um you know in researching all
these things my campaign is about data
analytics course I'm making it for
simply probably and I would go and I
would just try to you know search into
the planning my Keyword Planner and then
I will write a term quickly here you
know whatever I want to show my ad for
suppose data uh analytics course as I
said okay probably let's say distal
marketing because we would have
more uh results so
it's easy to understand with a lot of
results because I would able to tell you
how to sort and filter them down uh
disal marketing course and you can just
test it with any of the keywords I'm
just doing a random check so once we are
here we have lot of keywords in addition
to what we have submitted so the keyword
which I have provided is this and the
result shows that it had over 100k uh
you know um monthly searches and uh of
course in the range of 1 million in the
in the you know in the month of 2021 to
September 2022 so this is actually the
average monthly searches happened in
between this period and uh the advertis
is actually paid as low as 44 Rupees to
as high uh 200 24 rupees okay that can
easily be uh you know converted to
dollars uh half a dollar or maybe more
than half a dollar uh 6070 cents
probably and uh this is like going to be
a $3 cost okay so what we can do is we
can see now there are a lot of keywords
been given and we can easily sort them
down here on certain you know uh basis
like you know suppose the monthly
searches are high or the bid is low and
all that stuff but this is quite you
know difficult when we have to to sort
down here in the Keyword Planner so what
I do is I'm just going to talk about the
same you know like hi how I actually go
when I working for my clients okay I
have clients here a lot of clients I
don't want to show you but yeah I have
and um suppose I just go and download
this data from here and then this would
be you know uh downloaded in the Excel
format and we can just save it anywhere
suppose I just bring it here and then
now I would open the keyword
sheet and I would have a data in my
Excel okay so I need this this one so
this is the most important column
because I have to highlight uh which
column is important and what is not
required right now so whatever is
required I'm just I'll be keeping with
me and what I feel like is not very
important as of now I'm just not going
to be taking them so now there are five
column which I have kept with myself
like these four where we talk about
about the
results and the keyword okay uh this is
not required this is not required I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about our
competition index value so this actually
tells us that a particular keyword is
how much um you know from the
competition point of view is difficult
to rank suppose I talk about two key
right now let me just take um one with a
lower SC SC suppose this one and I would
take the higher or the highest one
probably is this one okay so now when I
talk about a comparison you know
probably uh or or probably let's say
this this one because this has monthly
searches which are equivalent uh you
know from the uh competition point of
view they are way different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sort that if I have
to finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that that's something
which we are talking here you if we have
a kind of a combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both of the
keywords mean very important if I would
just check from my naked eye a quick
Scan they look very promising they look
very great to me suppose and they have a
equivalent number of searches in the
last uh you know one year on the average
monthly basis but there is a difference
between the competition okay now people
can be confused what is this competition
so I would just make you expl in a very
simple way Suppose there are 100
companies or there are 100 you know at
Tech institutes or probably physical
institutes who teaches uh digital
marketing because we are doing online
marketing or you know digital marketing
course online so so let's keep it uh
online uh institutes like simply learn
and all okay so what they have done is
in the last one year they all have use
these keywords to run their ads you know
to show their uh advertisement or their
digital ad on a Google space okay when
this data has been given so this is
telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100
competitors 66 or a
66% advertisers have used this ad okay
or have used this keyword to show their
ad okay and out of 100 33% or if it is
100 uh then 33 advertisers have used
this keyword to show their ad okay so it
brings you know kind of a uh comparison
to US that probably these two keywords
are very much in demand you know like
equally from the searches point of you
because both have been searched equally
but whenever this has been searched then
there has been a competition where 66
people or 66 advertisers or 66%
advertisers are fighting to show their
add okay and when this keyword being
searched as equally then only 33% or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then that seems to be
okay where my ad would look like you
know where my ad would show because if I
just go on a Google space you know that
only seven ads are shown when you know
when we go on a Google search engine 1 2
3 and four and then the rest three would
would be at the bottom if they are shown
at this moment or not I'm not very sure
so three would be here somewhere so
total seven ads placement on the first
page nobody goes beyond first we know
that 97 of the worldwide audience don't
don't go beyond the first page in nation
okay so we have to be on our first page
so if I talk about from the first page
seven positions point of view it would
make more sense so let's imagine there
are only 10 advertisers of digital
marketing course so out of 10 if I take
out 60
66% then it means almost like 6 to seven
advertisers are fighting or have bided
or probably are trying to outrank each
other to show their ad on the top or on
the first four positions of Google but
when I talk about this then only three
to four advertisers are fighting or have
bided for this keyword to show the ad on
the first page so this actually is a
very important data sometimes we just
you know Miss it because
uh it has not been uh I think explained
anywhere else that what exactly this
value is we only go by the low medium
high which is the very first column I
delete nowadays you know I don't you
know go by this because they both come
under the medium but there's a big
difference you know seven out of 10
would have been bided for and only three
to four would have been bided for this
keyword so never go by the high medium
or low just go by the index value
because that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bid
value or a bit uh price which is also on
a very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that that much uh you know we go for
the high search keyword and then we try
to get the low medium competition
keywords which of course less than 60
index value and then I put a price you
know kind of a price of my price you
know which is like if the low bid price
is 10 Rupees then I just make it 13 by
adding 30% to it so if the pricing is 10
so I would add 30% to it that makes my
price 13 and then I check you know uh if
the first day if the Impressions has
come it means my pricee actually been
accepted but if any of the keyword my
pricee is not accepted then I would
again revise the price by 230% and then
would wait for the second day report and
that's how you know I keep changing for
the first 2 3 days and keep seeing the
results and once the you know every
keyword gets pick up and I get the you
know starts getting the stable results
then I uh just as allow the campaign to
work uh you know on the algorithm and uh
you know I I see uh results actually
moves in the positive direction when you
give some time to campaigns to read and
to learn uh you know from the audience
Behavior okay so this is about the
keyword planning which we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus focus is more
on this uh presentation parall I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads uh the demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the um ad algorithm point of view so
what happens or what used to happen uh
when when the quality score you know
which I'm just trying to speak now was
not there uh what used to happen the one
who used to pay the highest bid price
used to get the first position and the
second one used to get the second
position and the third bidder used to
get the third position so I have just
brought into this table suppose a
advertizer has bided 8 rupe B 10 C 15
and D 20 and when the quality score
concept was not there so they actually
been given the very direct position this
one first this one second this one third
and this one fourth but they have
realized or Google has realized that the
one who is paying the most is not having
a very good quality of the ad uh his uh
landing page or the website it's is not
working or probably the pages which is
which are connected are not very
relevant and the keywords on which the
ads been shown is nowhere near uh you
know when the landing page is opened so
it it was like a very negative impact on
Google when the reviews been checked and
people or the users who were clicking on
those ads were not happy so what Google
did Google brought us you know kind of
um uh test score or a check uh which is
called quality score for every keyword
we bid okay and this is only for the
search ads that's why I said all the
keywords we B okay I'll just show you
the result on a client site so when we
submit our ad on the basis of you know
different keyword we buid and the and
the strategy we use and the landing page
we connected the back end so what the
system does is system starts analyzing
and starts checking everything from top
till you know bottom from the start till
the end
and I would just talk about the factors
and what impact it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every uh Advertiser here
is bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let let's um assume that they all
are running the ad for the digital
marketing course so what would happen
they would check and on the basis of the
you know factors they would give a score
out of 10 suppose the a Advertiser who
bid it for the least had the best of the
quality score because of the reasons
we're just going to talk about B got 8
out of 10 4 out of 10 and 2 out of 10 so
the one who have bided the most got the
very least quality score probably the
reasons you know would be more clear
once we talk so how this now will going
to impact the whole position system is
that their Google rank not Google
position okay there is a Google rank
kind of a kPa can be understood or a
metrix which is um a product or a multip
lication of what you bid and how much
quality score you were able to get so 8
into 9 brings 72 10 into 8 brings 80 15
into 4 brings 60 and 20 into 2 is 40
okay so the combination of a good
pricing and a good quality score got B
bidder as a first position okay and the
one who got the best quality score but
still paying very less from the average
pricing probably is you know brought the
Google position or ad position to Second
and then the one who was spraying very
high but the quality score was below
average which is of course 56 is average
price average score they've got into
third position and the one who was
paying so high probably would not get a
position because this is the maths from
the math point of view have got these
numbers if the quality score would have
been below five then the ad would not
have got any position rather because
Google always tries to you know show the
ads which are the best uh for the users
you know because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users um uh you know expectations so and
when I said that I think you would able
to understand more now how the factors
you know which which actually results in
these quality score is um like relevant
score like by relevant score means when
you type A quiry or a person would come
here would type A quiry so he doesn't
know that this is called a keyword we as
a digital marketers know this is called
a keyword for them it is a normal query
because they are about to start a course
where they would be taught about all
these things but right now to they are
not very aware you know very much aware
of these things so they are putting a
query when they put a query they want to
see the add or add extensions or add
description relevant to what they have
searched and when they see all these
three things here with the search uh you
know what they made they would
definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody's clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to the SC and to whatever being shown
outside they cannot just show anything
here uh which is not relevant to the ad
which has actually been shown outside so
all these uh you know uh factors uh in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is
CTR which you must have understood when
you know we uh I I did you know explain
the last session the basic one but if
you do not aware of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and a click
through rate it is a ratio of clicks to
impression okay it is a ratio of clicks
to
impression just a spell check okay so
suppose
today uh when we are saying ABCD so
let's see this this is a or this is B
and this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their uh ad their
description everything is very much
common so Google in the starting of the
day you know when the ad actually
started to show for everyone uh you know
given them a very good quality score
probably of five okay and when this
quality score of five been given to them
then the other factor which actually
adds on you know to that algorithm is
the CTR so CTR is I just told you is the
ratio between click to impression so now
they all have a same quality score but
this got 100 clicks out of the Thousand
Impressions being given given today this
got 5050 clicks out of the th000
Impressions given today this got by any
mean probably 200 clicks out of the
Thousand Impressions given today okay
every time this this search is happening
here digital marketing course so these
three ads are very much visible equally
so all got th000 Impressions thousand
Impressions th Impressions but this got
100 clicks this got 50 clicks and this
got 200 Clicks in the very first hour or
maybe in the next two hours okay so this
CTR you know when we are talking about
100 out of th000 to 10% This Is 50 out
of th000 it means this is going to be 5%
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of th000 means
20% of the CTR so Google was actually
benefited or made the most of the
revenue when know clicks have come from
here because it is almost like a double
or a four times of this so because of
the high CTR the quality score of of
course you know every every Advertiser
would improve but this one would be
improved from probably from 5 to 7 and
this would you know probably from 5 to
5.5 and this probably from 5 to 6 so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CT this has got so this position
will be changed and this would know
probably would get the first position
the second position and at the end of a
day this ad has to pay or Advertiser has
to pay lesser because it's quality score
increase we have just seen it is you
know almost like the uh you know
inversely proportional the ones who are
actually paying or the ones who are
having the best of the quality score are
paying the least or has to pay the least
okay so this is all basically you know
can be checked once your ad starts
running so I would just open the
client's account uh where you can just
see this
with you know
B understanding you would be able to get
out of
this hopefully I able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple advertisers you know but I Cann
just show for all so let me just check
if I can show you from any of the older
one just wait it is actually asking me
some
modification it's taking too much
time yeah it's it's done now
okay so once this is
done so I just take you to one of the
accounts where my main focus will be to
just show you how the quality score
report look like and then you know you
will get a fair idea about all the
factors you have to be focusing to bring
your quality score high or to take your
quality score high
okay so I'm just going to open the
search ads because we're talking about a
search ad here only and suppose if I
just go into this uh Campaign which is
of course you know not running right now
but I just want to show you how to check
the report and all suppose this is the
campaign you have run for and you got 75
clicks at a you know um average CPC
price of 40 PESA and you have just given
this much pricing and I have bid it for
many keywords but I want to see which
keyword had got the best of the quality
score and how the quality score been
given and all okay so once you reach to
the keyword report here you know at this
level then you see um uh you know uh the
kpis or metrics here which gives the
quality score out of 10 okay you can see
here very well and every keyword being
given you know if if there are 10
keywords I don't know how many keywords
we bided for we bided 50 keywords okay
and um you know you can see all the
keywords here and every keyword been
given the quality score out of 10 okay
because their CTR which was the last
part which I've explained you the ratio
between the impression two clicks got
the above average so they give uh below
average average and above average so
above average is best actually for any
of the factors so the CT R is above
average the landing page is above
average and their ad is above average
means all are perfect then they got the
10 the moment anything goes below
average or probably to the average
suppose you can see this is above
average for them this is above average
for them but their landing page
experience from this keyword point of
view is only average their quality score
has come to eight okay if you go further
down uh let's see anything where two of
them uh yeah so here the kidss ride on
is a keyword where CTR is also not as
high or as great you know to as compared
to the other keywords which we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there uh two
factors like CTR and landing page has
come to average as compared to the Andro
evance which is above average so their
whole quality score got impacted which
actually came down from 10 to 8 and then
7 for this particular keyword and last
not TC just take you to somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average one is okay they
are getting clicks but probably the ad
is still not very much relevant to the
keyword okay so they are below average
above average average has brought the
quality score to 6 out of 10 which
certainly would have you know impacted
on the cost and also to the position
okay so this is something which you
would see when you come here also you
can check one more thing here suppose
you have bided for your keyword and your
bid price where you are paying for is
maximum bid price let me just see where
that column is so otherwise I would just
add that column so that you can learn
that part as
well
[Music]
okay just wait okay so this is
basically CPC priz is being given in the
average cost 2.50 is the cost for every
click and we got 249 clicks so got 623
you can just check the maths it's always
good to cross check so 249 clicks
multiplied by the CPC price which is
2.50 rupe will give you 6 22.5 which is
the cost you know for the keywords um
you know we B it for and the total
clicks we have paid okay and the
maximum bid price suppose you know you
have got the maximum bid price of 1 rupe
and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and all and
then what happens you want to secure
your position suppose the very first
page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting a first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
or particular one keyword uh I suppose
so this is something which I'm know
trying to show on a one rupee cost but
to show on the first page it is saying
that you have to pay 1.5 okay to show on
the uh first four positions here 1 2 3 4
it is saying that probably you have to
pay 2.5 and to get the absolute first
position which is going to be the
topmost it would tell you that you have
to probably pay 5 rupee you know you're
paying one it is asking 1.5 the first
four it can be paid for 2.53 or this has
to be five so you can always go and
change your you know bid price for the
particular keyword okay so there are
ways to do it suppose if I just go here
and I just go to the edit I can change
my maximum CPC bid price for this
particular bid or a keyword like to 5
rup okay because I'm not changing for
all the keywords so I have selected that
particular keyword and I have made the
change to this particular keyword to 5
rupe so if you know the average price
was one and I was not getting the
keyword uh from this keyword the
position secured on the first page or
first absolute position and I want
because this is the most important
keyword for me then I would just come
here and would check the pricing okay
this says 5 rupees you have to pay for
the top position so I will just go here
edit and would change the bid price or a
maximum CPC bid price of this particular
key you can do for all you know you have
to just of course you know select all of
course but if you would do for all then
it it can really impact your whole
budget okay so try to go for the
keywords where you really feel like it
is required and always go by the quality
score it has you know it has a very good
quality score so I should be paying or I
should be ready in paying uh the maximum
price which actually Google is asking me
to pay to secure my first absolute
position and uh certainly that would
increase the chances of clicks and
certainly if clicks are there so
conversions can be expected too okay so
this is all from what I've just T you as
of now now I would just move to the
campaign making though we have done as I
told you last time but I will try to
make it again so that we can quickly see
how the Google ad search ads or the
search Google ad created okay so if I
just go to the campaign uh My Demo
account so I just go to the Google ads
account that dashb and then I would come
to the
campaigns I would just click
plus new
campaign and whatever the you know um
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
C campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate uh session all
together so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we're
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with uh adding the extensions to the ad
as well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is um just open
simply
learns uh landing
page so that I can make the ad for
simply marketing as a demo ad of course
not a main ad so copying and just
putting in here I have to just put a uh
you know website domain that's it I
don't have to bring the whole landing
page here and then I can just name it
probably
November search
add
and then I would just go and
continue start
new and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks and
of course from my Excel I would learn
that okay my bid price which I'm going
to be paying uh you know uh is certainly
in the range of something like probably
5060 and I have just told you that I
bring my price kind of a thing into this
like I always bring like this and then
let me just delete all the other column
which are not
required so this is the sheet which I
did explained you earlier with the index
value and all so my price what is my
price like so I always pay 30% 40% extra
to the low bid price so I can you know
just get the formula here like
this
plus this
30%
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 + 13 going
to bring 57 and I can just drag it and
now I've got the average suppose these
are the you know keywords which I have
finalized just assuming so these are the
keywords which I have finalized probably
because of XYZ factors search as and
index value and all that and I see that
my pricing is varing from 35 to 89 so
maximum paying 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head
I would going to give the limmit to my
bid price that I don't want to pay
anything extra or more than 90 okay so
this is something which you can do on
this particular level and then you move
ahead and you remove this because you
just want to keep your ad on the Google
search and then you go down you select
your countries you select your location
if you want to show the ad in all the
locations then you certainly can just go
uh and keep the very first option open
which is uh all countries and
territories if you want to just show
your ad um uh in a particular country
like you know right now if I just go
India so the whole India would see your
ad and if you want to go for a manual
locations like suppose I want to select
any of the states or cities then what I
would do I would just probably take
Delhi so Delhi would be targeted like
this okay or probably I just want to
Target the state of Texas here so I just
would go and Target the whole state or
if I want to Target any of the provinces
of Canada so I would just go and take
the uh provinces of Ontario Canada and I
would just Target the whole Province and
now if I also want to go for any of the
uh PIN codes suppose I want to Target to
a certain pin code then I can just go
and Target the PIN codes like this so it
is up to us that we want to go worldwide
or if you want to go for a country
specific if you want to go for a state
specific or if you want to gr as a
province or a pin code specific okay
otherwise uh if you suppose um a
restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search and then you can go into radius
and you can just bring this
whatever you understand better in India
we understand kilometers better maybe
the person in us would understand miles
better so we just go and take that 2 km
radius and probably I am the cake shop
in Delhi so I was just going to search
my location this is my location and I
was just going to Target people around 2
km because I don't deliver outside 2 km
so it's all up to us how we want to go
uh this is called radius targeting or
Geo fening when we go to the locations
we can also learn one thing suppose I
want to show the art to the um whole
country India I've targeted but the same
time I am not delivering in um uh in in
in Mumbai okay or probably in uh kataa
you know bangaluru where the city is
okay probably I'm not delivering in any
of the uh northern states like harana
Himachal Punjab so what I would do I
would just take Punjab suppose for
example and I'm just going to exclude
that okay so what would happen now my ad
would show in all the states and all the
cities of India but just not in Punjab
okay so I can save it that's how you go
about the location language is you know
in which language the users probably
uses the search engine and all so you
can keep it all languages that's the
best and audience we don't cater here
much because we are doing the search ad
which actually shows the ad on the basis
of keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the Moree settings comes where you talk
about the ad rotation so ad rotation is
uh already default being selected as the
perform best ad uh if uh because the
nowadays the ad actually been created uh
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you uh
the headline changes for every user the
description sometime changes for the
user what I mean is if such is selecting
or you know writing this keyword so
probably this headline is shown to me
and after 1 hour if I'll come again and
put search the same term so the headline
from the same Advertiser could be
different or the description could be
different so that's how the dynamic ADS
works like okay so once you are done
with this okay the start and dat is
important you know the basics from the
previous chapter so I'm just going a bit
faster in here so you would select the
date and then if you want to schedule
this campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run on the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8:00 a.m. to uh you
know the late nights like 2345 and you
don't want to run the weekends if you
want um Saturday Sunday to be you know
24 hours then you don't have to put any
timing so that goes like 24 hours for
Saturday Sundays and then you click next
and you reach to the the next
level where it will just going to ask
you for certain things like keywords you
want to submit and the ad you want to
run for and the ad copy you know you
have to create okay so once you come
here it uh is the you know work you have
done so you can just copy paste them and
you know bring in there uh and otherwise
these all keywords are the ones which
Google has suggested you from you know
the page which you have submitted okay
so the landing page is this so I'll try
to change the landing page first so that
I can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would going to search again or
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show us certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of the keyword is how much
the monthly search has been so we go by
our own maths we we calculate we do all
this pre homework on the Keyword Planner
sheet just like we did today and then we
bring them here by deleting all what
they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then be ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
being used how the copy is created I'll
just show you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
you know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the add or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling
online digital marketing so I would just
going to write whatever I want to
show probably I'll just keep it
here
marketing okay so that's works okay so
now it has come digital marketing and
then the part comes where you know you
have to
be I'll just going to tell you the call
extension once the art is created so
headlines and all so the headline is
something which
shows you know you know the basics so
I'll be fast again under the landing
page list L this blue which actually uh
you know brings the most of the
engagement or which actually appeals the
user to click it is something in blue
which is you know going to be the
headline so we have to be focusing very
much on bringing the best of the
headlines here so that we can get the
best of the clicks because you know once
the click increases the CTR increases
CTR increases the quality score would
increase quality score would increase
your costing would come down and your
position would rise so you have to
ensure that your headlines your clicks
everything is in you know in a line
whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and I'm just
going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and um we
can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords
here this is okay this is nice this can
be
changed
digital marketing
course online is not taking so this
Marketing Online probably I'll just take
because course are already submitted and
then I can take few more like social
media marketing I just
seen or whatever the length it would
accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the
rest this is the one and I should ensure
that I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know being given
like a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so
enroll
register
today for free
demo then we'll talk
about you can see the moment I've added
the headline this the strength has
changed 100 uh
plus tools for
free
job
assistance
program okay so I'm just adding few
random things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
atank companies ads uh include some
popular keywords popular keywords could
be your brand name as well so
simply
learn
courses
online
hopefully the spelling is fine and
um
weekend batch
for
professionals uh
[Music]
oh just a batch for
professionals and that's it you know
because I already added a lot of
keywords lot of headlines probably Le so
I would just not work on the headlines
anymore uh and I'll see you know if
description doesn't takes it high then
I'll I'll just add one more but right
now the description is also not giving
me the full uh tick like in the headline
unique and the headlines been given so
I'll just try to bring the description
so simpl online online that's great
that's great I just try to get something
from Google itself let's see what they
have given so I'll just going to bring
this one okay so that it is been taken
from the landing page itself so that
would make a difference
to uh the quality score simp digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to
put our courses focus on
skills
see focus on else like seu PPC
analytics to make this one here so that
has been picked up so now you can see
this is also been picked up and the last
thing I would do is now going to bring
some headline again you know I'll just
check probably uh digital marketing
certification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
training so now it has you know come
down to good and uh that's the best you
know right now we can do of course uh
you can take it further but yeah that
doesn't um uh matter if you are just
stuffing it to get this one completed
you have to just ensure that all the key
keywords or all the headlines are
relevant just do not overdo 10 to 12 are
okay okay once this is done your ad is
created you can just click done and you
can click
next and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet when I
was explaining you so the the the bid
price which you have submitted for
you know when I told you is like
something which is in this range uh 80
90 whatever it is so you know that bit
price would come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
100 going to be your 9,000 daily budget
so because you know that you know you
would end up in paying maximum 90 rupees
per click because that's the maximum bid
price you have submitted if that comes
down to 70 80 60 then of course your
clicks would increase but right now to
being very uh you know hypothe
hypothetically thinking that okay I
would pay 90 rupees per click at Max
because that is what I submitted so to
get 100 clicks I have to pay 90 into 100
it would be 9,000 your you know daily
budget has to be so you would come here
and you would just going to change it
set a custom budget and you were going
to bring down 9,000 rupees here okay so
on that CPC whatever it would be you
would get the number of clicks if your
have CPC goes down from 90 to 45 then of
course you are not going to get only 100
You' rather get double amount which is
going to be 200 okay when that is done
then you just click next and your budget
goes you know your campaign goes for a
review and then you can add the
extensions from outside okay so they're
just giving you some of the uh you know
kind of uh suggestions so let's see uh
there is one issue in the
ad let me just check that
first let me just see
you can always fix
it but that would again you're not going
to give you the option of um publishing
you know till you fix it but it is not
clickable I not
know uh what is the
problem I just go if from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is I isue
one
and okay so we just to do that
the character limit part I have not
given the space so that is something
which is not acceptable by them just
going to put like skills like this
and now so these all small things you
know they
do take uh care of so here only because
we have come down so why not uh just to
see the extension here itself because
that would uh going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created only till
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headlines the description but
in this ad by emerus you can see more
links like apply to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub page
is also been shown in this same ad how
they are done so they are done through
the extension called site link okay so
you can see here if you go down after
the headline there's an option to have
the site links here okay so you can just
click plus here itself I'm not
submitting the ad because I wanted just
to show you from here itself and then
you can go down because in your case
these would not be given because mine
are already created yours are not so you
would go down and you would create the
new new site link from here and you can
just give a name suppose
download
brocher and then you can give a URL of
that download brocher page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page like this like
this has to be the landing page which is
workable for the downloading brocher of
course so this would be added and then I
can just go and probably add um uh
testy
monals and
reviews okay so somebody wants to read
the uh you know um testim and reviews of
when when they see the ad so you can see
that on the desktop how that would look
like so they would have an ad and then
they would have these four links and all
which you have just seen in the Google
when I shown you so final URL of reviews
can be given which would directly take
them to the page where the reviews been
given and uh site two could be anything
you know which can just see um industry
ready modules or the fee structure you
know the fee structure is something
which people always wants to just
know from the uh very first glimpse of
the art itself so I can just
maybe take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe
tools
provided number to tools
and
certificates you would get so that can
also be one of the links which people
would very much interested in you know
clicking and checking okay so you would
see the the add in certain shape you
would have a normal headline uh the
description which you have put it up and
then four links where people can
directly reach okay and then you know
this had to be saved here and you can
always see the preview which I want
already shown you but yeah this is how
that would look like so your add your
add and your four uh extra links which
actually been added okay so this is one
which you can apply
now and now your ad has the extensions
in addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your add as uh
the number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here I right now it
is not showing any of the ads with the
number but they you know uh generally
have advertisers have nowadays the
numbers in addition to the headline and
everything okay so you can add that as
well by just going up and you can see
there is an option of calls okay okay
let me you can add from here uh
certainly I can show you but you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your country and you know
giving your number here it it'll just be
cross checked by some verification and
all so that is is done you can save it
so you can see what actually I was
showing you you know I would just show
you um from outside also that if by any
of the uh you know um that is done that
we have corrected so you don't have to
be you know uh worried about so if I
just click done so that should not be
there if it is still there I have to
check now which spacing it is actually
talking about um actually I have un
acceptable spacing contains comma and I
think I have just corrected it but it is
not taking maybe I have to just U um
delete the whole description probably
that would something which I would save
our
time okay so we not adding that
description though C done so this is
actually you know kind of a bug because
that is something which has been deleted
rather in front of you so this is not
um taking but I would just click next
and probably this would now be not the
error in which we would see so you go
for a review so what I was saying I did
shown you from outside the you know the
the campaign was created from the ad
itself how the S site link is connected
and how the uh call being added for now
the publish campaign you can see because
that add error actually been rectified
so if by mistake you know you just
forgotten that you have to add the call
number or extension you know which we
just added so what you don't have to be
worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well you know
which you had just created then you can
just go inside the um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets let
just click
that so there's an ad which you just
created and there's an assets you know
where you could see
uh
the extensions and all like you know you
just have added today and we just added
this site link and this number so if I
want to add again or if I would have
forgotten then what I can do I can just
go and take from here suppose if uh that
call extension was not added there you
know when I just added you would come
here in the assets you would click that
plus button and then you would just go
to the call and you would see the same
kind of a preview which you have seen
inside the ad when we were creating okay
nothing different it's just like the you
know way you do it you know either you
do when the ad was created or otherwise
you can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add in assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these uh extensions we will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough
uh learning on the Google search chart
with the extensions and also the main uh
agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can save the
cost and of course to understand how the
quality score works like you can have a
lot of videos on a YouTube where you can
find the quality score of Google ads
working though I tried to you know bring
everything under this session but still
if you want to go for our deep learning
you can always search more and research
more so let's have a look at what social
media marketing actually means what is
it yeah and we got to put this in the
context of the definition of
marketing yeah I studied Marketing in
the very early days in the 80s and um my
main sort of uh Guru in marketing was
Philip Cotler and over the years
marketing has sort of developed from
traditional marketing to online
marketing but the basic concept has not
changed if you look at the definition of
marketing it's the activity of creating
communicating delivering and exchanging
offerings that have value for
customers yeah so you supply you deliver
you exchange products or services
that have a value for your
customers so two very important aspects
here there is value and there is
customer and that is what we capture in
the marketing concept you put the
customer at the core of what you do yeah
because when you do that you
automatically will look at what value
are we giving to the customer
yep so take social media marketing in
that context then the second part of the
social media
marketing sort of term is the word
social media what is social media when I
explain social media I'm using the three
C's the three C's of social media
marketing and they are content they
community and
campaigns content is the fuel
of your social media content is the um
the currency of social media if you have
really good content that you can share
on the internet yeah using various
multip multiple social media channels
like Facebook like YouTube or like video
or like Instagram or blogging you name
it yeah people people will engage with
your
content and then when people start
engaging with your content they may come
back for more content that you supply
and they will then become part of your
community so Community is a very
important aspect of your social media
definition with really good content you
can create
communities and then you can push that
process
by running
campaigns yeah and a campaign makes it
relevant for
businesses because when you run a
campaign you have a goal for your
campaign you have an objective you have
a St date you have an end
date yep and that is what social media
marketing is it's all about running
campaigns to develop your communities
with really exciting content and then
you put it into the marketing context
you do that with a customer at in the
core of what you
do yes so if I then take that to a
definition of social media
marketing is very basic it says the use
of social media to develop a company's
brand increase website traffic and boost
sales that is what we call social media
marketing yeah the most important aspect
here is that you need to have an outcome
you need to have a result which is
customer
related and that is where the sales
element comes in you do this to get the
customer to do something and in the end
that is buying your product or your
service
yeah so social media marketing is not
the
Tactical combination of your social
media networks yeah to um to reach as
many people there needs to be a goal to
it and when we talk about marketing it
comes down to selling your product or
service with a
value yeah so that is the um kind of the
call to action as it were that comes out
of your social media marketing so keep
that in mind everything you do with your
social media marketing in the end comes
down to reaching your goals or achieving
your objectives of developing your
company's brand increasing website
traffic or growing your
sales now a big benefit that you're
getting these days in digital marketing
and social media
marketing is
data is
intelligence is
knowledge in the early days of marketing
the biggest problem has always been how
to measure the success of your marketing
campaigns if I ran adverts in a magazine
how do I measure the effectiveness if I
do a PR campaign and they write about me
in the newspaper how do do I measure the
effectiveness of that how can I track
that when somebody buys a product it
actually is as a result of the pr
campaign that I Ran So in the early pre-
interet days yeah we the only way to
measure customer engagement as it were
were through Loyalty cards or credit
cards yeah with a loyalty card you had
some basic customer data through credit
cards you could track
transactions but it's very difficult to
relate that to your marketing then the
internet emerged and all of a sudden I
could track traffic to my
website yeah I could see how many people
visit my website are these people that
visit my website for the first time are
they returning visitors what are the
most popular pages that they see how
long do they stay on my website and are
they actually buying my
products yeah so that was a major
advancement of marketing in the early
2000s and then when social media emerged
it all of a sudden became possible to
measure
engagement how many people are having
conversations with us I could even
measure sentiments are people positive
about my brand are they negative about
my Brands I could track the
effectiveness of my marketing
campaigns I could measure the
effectiveness of my advertising
campaigns that I ran online so today's
reality is that we can measure
everything we can measure clicks we can
measure transactions we can measure
engagements we can measure return on
investments yeah and we can now even
take that a step further through
artificial intelligence that we can
actually start making predictions how
people may respond to campaigns that
we're going to be running so it's a very
important aspect of your digital uh your
social media
marketing now let's go into the social
media marketing tips and
tricks number one set up your
goals now what good will your actions do
if you don't have a goal in mind the
goal of your marketing strategy may be
the driving force behind every decision
that you make
and this is exactly why setting up goals
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the
organization here are some things that
you need to keep in mind while setting
up your goals first of all your goals
need to be quantitative for example you
need to have a th000 conversions by the
end of the quarter or 5,000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on number two you need to stick to to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your options and number
three make sure your goals are smart now
smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and
time-based now let's go to number four
like I mentioned earlier your goals need
to be aligned with the marketing
strategy and alongside these goals there
also needs to be the Northstar metric
now what is the Northstar metric well
this represents a main goal or a fixed
reference point to ensure that your team
is on the right course this Northstar
metric will also give your team Clarity
and
focus now let's have a look at some
popular northstars there's increased
engagement greater conversion rates more
leads generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two understanding
your
audience social media allows you to
interact engage and build relationships
with your Audience by understanding what
they need want and desire you can
deliver content in a way that makes your
product or service the answer that
they're looking
for there are also other ways that you
can understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of
Their audience by conversing with them
in forums responding to their comments
and blogs and social media taking up
their feedbacks of suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here well we've taken a personal
example here is simply learn now simply
learn's audience is predominantly
working professionals and graduates
unacademy has high school graduates and
BYU app has high school students as
users
now let's go to number three determining
the right social media
platform now when performing social
media marketing choosing the right
platform is really
important When selecting them you need
to ask questions like why you're using
that particular platform who you will
reach with this platform what content
could work best on the platform and is
there any content that was unique to
that platform like for example YouTube
and then there's the
video answering these questions will
help you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some of the major ones
there's LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest now let's talk about the
purpose of each of these platforms
LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences for
Facebook well just about everyone has an
account on it content that is related to
news or entertainment usually finds
success on Facebook then we have
Instagram visual content works best on
Instagram now although it works well for
static images and short form video It
Doesn't Really drive a lot of traffic to
your website and then finally we have
Pinterest Pinterest is also limited to
static images however it's highly
effective at driving traffic to your
blog now let's go to number four setting
up a social media
calendar a social media calendar demands
the message you want to convey to your
audience it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform let's have a look at some of
the most popular types of posts on
social media first off we have
competitions now I'm sure all of you
have seen posts like tag a friend who
does this or comment or like to win
something and stuff like that
competitions like these provide great
opportunities for engagement with the
audience and they can be used to
increase your followers to share your
content it could also be for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag and competitions help
grow your presence on social media then
we have Paul polls and surveys polls can
help you if you need a collection that
also encourages followers to take action
and interact polls and surveys also
provide opportunities through which you
can learn from customers to understand
what they like about the product or
service or what they don't and to
receive their feedback and then we have
videos and live streams although we'll
be covering this in a little more detail
further on visual storytelling along
with videos and live streams goes a long
way to drive engagement among your
audience these will help get your
followers attention increase trust and
credibility and have a higher response
rate and has so much more to offer live
stream with its live nature and having a
human face alongside your business
humanizes your brand and by extension
helps increase customer loyalty and
trust and then there is infographics
articles and images so social media
calendars are successful because of
their ability to increase colle
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective
manner next up we have number five using
social media marketing
tools social media marketing tools align
to the goals of your organization with
it you can create highquality content
attract new potential customers and
drive engagement and it also helps you
with the plan planning process you can
plan create and schedule posts on your
social
calendar now some of the more popular
social media tools include buffer hoot
site Buzz Sumo if T and much more now
these tools also help with generating
leads creating email lists finding a
relevant audience to show your content
creating buyer personas providing you
insights on what works and what doesn't
and giving you templates for different
kinds of
posts now for number six visual
storytelling visual storytelling
involves passing out a lot of
information in the simplest of forms
visually using pictures and videos your
followers are able to grasp the message
quickly and remember it for a long time
afterwards visual storytelling is also
not limited by language barriers and
this helps it become interesting and
entertaining to anyone watching it can
also help your audience stay interested
and engaged grab the attention of
potential clients and so much
more but it also has some other
advantages it helps you build a bond
with your audience visual storytelling
connects with your audience methods like
live streaming help humanize your brand
and help grow customer loyalty and trust
it has the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential
customers so have a look at some of our
videos so here's what is machine
learning data science in 5 minutes and
AI in 5 minutes now these are some of
our our most viewed videos on our
Channel and now you know why visual
storytelling if you guys are interested
in watching these videos you can check
them out on our Channel homepage and we
also have similar videos on blockchain
devops and Six Sigma but now back to the
list let's go to number seven paying for
advertising this is a method that helps
you find a Target and reach your
audience with ease it can greatly help
with achieving your organization's
marketing
goal and this can help you improve your
reach and improve your Brand's
visibility it's payperclick model and
shows cost Effectiveness by providing
great results and return on investment
it also helps improve targeting by
letting you control who sees your ad you
get to choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types alongside the basic
user demographics like age location
gender and so on now since most social
media platforms have native analytics
you also get to assess and Define the
performance of your ad
campaigns now as great as it sounds
there are certain pitfalls that come
along with peer advertising first of all
your audience could get exposed to your
post too many times and tune out your
content disregarding it in the
process second it could get really
expensive for small businesses or
startups to manage a campaign to its
maximum Effectiveness third people could
pass off your content as irrelevant or
unimportant and you also have to deal
with a lot of
competition smaller companies with
lesser budgets have more of an uphill
battle to deal with than better funded
organizations next we have number eight
newsjacking newsjacking is a method that
involves using current events to promote
your own Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness newsjacking uses
the popularity of current events and
drives it to your brand it helps shine a
spotlight on your products and it also
helps you show off that you are up to-
dat with current events in the industry
and that your product is relevant by
extension it also improves engagement
and website
traffic now for number nine AB
testing AB testing is a popular method
for comparing copies creatives and ctas
or call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media now since audiences
would react differently depending on the
content AB testing helps determine which
of the variants your audience engaged
with the
most AB testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on and next up number 10 community and
influences joining communities helps
your brand link up with like-minded
people and other companies belonging to
your Niche it'll also help you establish
your brand as an Authority within the
industry actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up
with and on the other hand partnering up
with influencers helps promote your
products or services to a brand new
audience it helps provide an additional
layer of authenticity in YouTube which
is also a social media platform if you
didn't know here are some very very
popular influencers
we have Marcus brownley unbox therapy Mr
who's the boss and lonus Tech tips each
of them with more than 4 million
subscribers and finally we're at number
11 measuring and analyzing
results accurately tracking and
measuring your marketing efforts are an
important part of the process it ensures
that you're making the most out of your
campaigns now it's really important that
you find key metrics that are crucial
for your brand and these metrics can be
tracked weekly monthly or on a quarterly
basis and based on these results
appropriate actions can be
taken so on Facebook you could look out
for reach and engagement on Twitter you
could look out for Impressions clicks
and Impressions and interactions on
LinkedIn and likes comments and mentions
on Instagram and engagements and
Impressions on Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
hoot Suite Google analytics and so on so
if you are looking to grab a career in
digital marketing simply learn has got
you covered with wide range of top-notch
digital marketing courses these courses
make you skill in SEO content marketing
PPC social media marketing and much more
with hands-on experience in the tools
like Google analytics keyword planner
Sim rush and there is huge list on board
however one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course find
the cost Link in the description box I'm
Greg jarbo and what is that I mean what
we're going to talk about in this first
module of a Content marketing Foundation
course is literally content marketing um
okay what is it so content marketing Is
Not A New Concept it's been around for
over a hundred years in fact one of the
classic Foundation stories of you know
the birth of content marketing goes all
the way back to the Michelin Brothers in
France and the Michelin Brothers you
know in case you haven't done your
history that's okay you know we'll
refresh her right now were two brothers
who made pneumatic tires and they were
trying to sell them along with an
Innovative product at its time called
the
automobile in an era where the roads
were horrible
in a place France where frankly people
didn't like to get outside of Paris and
into the provinces because my God what
was worth going out there for you know
for Paris it's all happening here and
what the Michelin Brothers realized is
if they wanted to sell more
tires they had to get people to drive
farther and farther and use them so what
did they come up with the concept that
really is the the birth of content
Marketing in my
book was the Michelin
guide and the Michelin guide was unique
in that it reviewed restaurants not just
restaurants nearby in Paris but
restaurants out there in the
provinces and the Michelin brothers are
the ones who came up with the one two
and three star rating system to say this
restaurant I know it's way out there
it's you know bad roads uh but guess
what to dive for the Ratatouille H you
you got to have it this is a three star
restaurant you you it's worth making the
trip and oh by the way and since we're
going to give you a guide and you have
to get out of Paris in order to get
there we're going to tell you where you
can find gasoline along the way uh which
hotels uh you might want to stay at
overnight and oh by the way just in case
you have
to how to repair a flat tire
particularly it's a Michelin tire
because it's a Pneumatic and you know
what it's quite easy to
repair and guess what that put Michelin
on the map why they weren't trying to
sell you more tires they weren't telling
you about the features and benefits of
round or a tire repair I mean that was
in there but it was only a how-to
article not necessarily a feature in
benefit what they were doing was they
were speaking to Their audience about
what Their audience was truly pass
passate about which in Paris in
1900 was
food and by creating
content but got the audience to get into
their new Innovative
automobile and drive all the way out
there into the provinces for that
absolutely remarkable three- Star
Restaurant people got more Flats people
had to replace their tires but it was
worth it and oh by by the way Michelin
solds more tires so that that's a great
story every time you sort of you know
hit a pause and like well we're doing
content marketing we need to come up
with a concept think back to the
Michelin guide it's it's a great
foundation so let's go to a modern
definition where are we now in the 21st
century when it comes to content
marketing well you can read the slide
here and read the definition and some
people like reading definitions I'm not
going to read it to you but I am going
to highlight a couple of words in the
definition that I think are
absolutely critical to any definition of
content
marketing the content that you create
needs to be
relevant and it also has to be
valuable now if it's not relevant then
you're not actually meeting my needs or
interests you know and why why would I
be interested in it and we've gotten way
too tired of screening out the
commercial that comes on um you know
trying to sell us snow tires and pardon
me we live in Florida I don't use snow
tires what the what the heck is this
commercial doing you know interrupting
what I'm
watching so relevance is important
relevance means that this content isn't
going to get screened out and the
valuable the valuable can can work in a
lot of different ways it can be
interesting it can be useful you know
value is an interesting proposition all
by
itself but that's the key to content
marketing uh it's not just creating more
spam it's not just throwing more trash
over the fence and hoping something
happens this is something where if
you've created valuable and relevant
content you know what your customers
will find you
it's a whole different kind of
proposition I know there's some Skeptics
who saying oh come on come on come on
content marketing is just a fancy new
name for social media marketing right
and the answer is well there is some
overlap and we're going to deal with
that in module
three but let me just be clear
here social media content is part of
what content marketing needs to create
but it can also create content for your
we website and that's not the social
media it can also create content that U
your PR people can share with uh uh
reporters or bloggers and that's not
normally considered uh social media
content and by the way all of that
content can be optimized so maybe it
actually is part of SEO not social media
marketing in fact that's the other place
that content marketing really
overlaps and it's not
coincidental it so happens that around
February
2011 when Google rolled out the first of
its multiple versions of the panda
update all of a sudden even seos started
to pay attention to content marketing
why because Google changed the rules and
what Google basically said is if your
content isn't valuable or relevant you
know what it's not going to rank very
well in our search
algorithm and all of a sudden people
who' been used to like putting keywords
in the right places realized content
matters you mean I've got to actually
tell stories that are interesting I've
got to create information that's
valuable yeah yeah you can make it
relevant that's the optimization part
but you know if you're trying to
optimize a piece of boring irrelevant
trash God bless you good luck so yeah
cont content marketing has grown it's
like tripled in terms of web search
interest since the panda update and
we're talking about Panda 1 of course
there was Panda 2 Panda three Panda 4 I
mean come on Google is driving us in
this direction and so content marketing
is pretty relevant
today now one of the other things that
uh people in content marketing struggle
with is oh but you don't understand I do
B2B content marketing or I'm a small
business or pardon me I'm an Enterprise
and so content marketing has to come in
flavors right well possibly maybe on
occasion so let's just question that
assumption for a
second you know content marketing has
been around now long enough and enough
people have done it but some research
has been conducted and it's been
conducted against B Toc marketers and
B2B marketers and small business
marketers and Enterprise level
marketers and when they start asking key
questions like okay we're going to try
to determine what is the difference
between an effective content marketer
and an ineffective content
marketer let's see the results well
first of all the most important thing to
Be an Effective B Toc content
marketer is you need a documented
content
strategy oh okay all right mean people
who are winging it aren't as uh
effective as people who actually have
thought about this and written it down
got it okay no great Insight but you
know interesting to note secondly they
got to have somebody in charge who
oversees content marketing oh Lord does
that mean we have to have a reorg or
maybe we just have to designate somebody
who reports to somebody else what
whatever but guess what it really helps
if somebody is driving this
process third they've got to be using
more content marketing tactics than
their less effective
peers and this is not an argument more
is better this is just pardon me that's
the way the data falls out the people
who are actually more effective are
doing more different kinds of
things a broader range of tax
ICS and who knows maybe it's that
broader range that's part of the success
form same thing is true with social
media
platforms the effective content
marketers are using more than the
ineffective ones and last but not least
and this may be a sort of a result of
the first four by gosh effective content
markets generally have greater
percentage of the overall marketing
budget in their
organization wow okay that's the BC
marketing form but you don't understand
I'm not a b2c marketer yeah okay so
let's take a look at the B2B content
marketing
formula guess what you need to have a
documented content marketing strategy to
Be an Effective B2B content marketer you
need to have someone who oversees
content marketing strategy it helps if
you are using more tactics and more
social media platforms and guess what
you spend a higher percentage of your
overall marketing Budget on content
marketing well that's similar to the b2c
content marketers but do you understand
B2B is different yeah there's a couple
small differences but guess what overall
the top five criteria are similar and
when you get to small business here's
what you're going to see same five
criteria and you're in an Enterprise I
know the world is different for
Enterprises actually not so much so four
different data points let's net it out
there's a pattern and the pattern is is
I don't care what flavor of content
marketer you are you can be B Toc B2B
you can be small business you can be
large Enterprise at the end of the day
there are five things that you've got to
focus on if you want to be a
active we've already covered these and
are there differences between small
businesses and large Enterprises between
B2B and BC well
sure but they're all at the
margin what's the downside if we don't
do this you know is anyone going to come
in and like whack us and the answer is
um maybe not inside your boardroom but
it may happen on the next sales call
that one of your salespeople makes they
may encounter someone I like to call the
man in the chair and the Man in the
chair actually refers back to a classic
McGraw Hill ad campaign from I think the
1960s but basically the guy in the chair
asks theoretically some questions from
quote maybe your salesperson okay I
don't know anything about you I don't
know about your company I don't know
about your company's product I don't
know about your company's you know
reputation
or anything about you and so what was it
you were going to try to sell me and
that's the downside of not having a
Content marketing
program we've actually found and work
that we've done with companies that
content marketing can shorten the sales
cycle why you're providing people with
information at key points that they need
in order to take the next
step so yeah is there a downside sure
stick with the status quo struggle
swimming against the tide you know what
it's probably smarter to have a Content
marketing
program so this introductory module in
the content marketing Foundation try to
ask and answer these questions what is
content
marketing and oh by the way just how
different are B Toc B2B
small business and Enterprise content
marketing and I think you've got the
answer content marketing u means that
your
content needs to be
relevant and it needs to be
valuable and by the way that content can
come in a whole lot of different forms
it's not just words on paper it can be
videos it can be infographics it can be
webinars it can be speeches that you're
executives are giving in public you know
content can take a lot of different
forms but at the end of the
day you want to Be an Effective content
marketer and for that we're going to go
through five more modules and let me
give you a sort of a highlight of what
we're going to
cover guess what we're going to cover
all the things that makes you effective
we're going to cover content marketing
strategy you need a documented one so
we'll we'll go through that and by the
way we're going to have a little extra
bonus because it's a problem that we've
seen people encounter again and again
which is all right before we've ever
done this in my organization I need to
get a budget for like a pilot project
how do I do that what do I do when I
don't have a budget and I'm trying to
start up content Marketing in my
organization so that's going to be
covered in module two module three we're
going to talk about someone who oversees
content marketing yeah right the org
chart and what we're really going to
focus in and this happens more in larger
Enterprise than other organizations but
even smaller businesses someday aspire
to be medium-sized businesses and
medium-sized businesses want to grow up
to be large Enterprises so you know what
it's probably useful for all of us to
understand where this is headed and
we'll talk about the lack of integration
across the marketing mix both within the
organization but also outside when it
comes to uh communicating to customers
and why guess what maybe it's time to
organize a little differently third
we'll talk about all those content
marketing tactics and instead of just
listing them all because you know what
lists are interesting but they're not
persuasive what we're going to look at
are the content marketing tactics that
content marketers consider most
effective so that windows down the list
and you're going to want to take some
time and learn not just
the broad range of things you could be
doing but the ones that seem to move the
needle and then then we'll tackle the
sort of subsidiary question of how do I
produce a variety of
content you know that seems to be a
problem for some folks well trust me
once you get your handle uh your arms
around um the whole what is effective
the variety of content pretty much takes
care of itself in the fifth module we're
going to take a look at social media
platforms and again content marketers
are experimenting with a wide variety of
them um the list seems to change daily
as new ones AR introduced or suddenly
the the list is revised because uh some
social media platform just got acquired
but now the company that acquired it is
you know pretty big and pretty
interesting so maybe we need to pay
attention to that too well guess what
once again we going to do a little
triage here we're only going to look at
the ones that seem to to be most
effective today and you too may want to
experiment with other ones beyond that
what it helps to have as a core part of
your content marketing programs the ones
that are the most effective and then
guess what the challenge is not having
one the challenge is actually producing
engaging content for those social media
platforms so we'll look at that in
module 5 and in module six we're going
to talk about budgets why because it all
comes down to the budget you you got to
have one and by the way you need to be
spending a larger uh percentage of your
marketing Budget on content Marketing in
order to be effective and in order to do
that we're going to have to skin this
cat we're going to have to look at
measurement we're going to have to get
you over the hurdle of how come it is so
hard to measure the
effectiveness of my content you know how
do I know that when when can I turn
around and show that to the top
management so they can say wow that
moved the needle fine you need a bigger
budget next year you got it so that's
what's coming um stay tuned uh strap in
this is uh going to be a bumpy ride at
times but guess what it is a journey wor
in the world of digital marketing you
must have heard the term
copyrighting but very few people talk
about copyrighting it's one of the
essential skills for any digital
marketer it has been estimated that
there are 1 lak 31,200 copywriters in
the United States today it is projected
that the copyrighting job market will
grow by 7.6% from
2016 to
2026 freelance market for copyrighting
is on a role companies like upwork and
Fior are filled with copywriters there
are many advantages of freelance
copyrighting jobs like being Your Own
Boss a flexible schedule and doing what
you love in this video we will try to
understand the art of copyrighting in
very simple manner if you stick to this
video till the end I assure you that you
will have a good understanding of
copyrighting hey everyone I'm tar Bal
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching Tech related content consider
subscribing to our YouTube channel and
hitting that Bell icon to stay tuned so
without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session we will start off the session
with an overview of what copyrighting is
what does a copywriter do then its
various types next we will understand
the difference between copyright writing
and content writing moving forward we
will discuss the best tools for
copywriters can use and finally we will
end the session by discussing the job
scenario and salary of a
copywriter so let's begin with our first
topic what is copyrighting in simple
words copyrighting is a type of writing
or a set of words that will convince the
reader to take some kind of action and
that action can be anything like
registering for an event signing up for
something or buying a product businesses
usually hire copyright writers to write
landing pages Facebook and Google ads
copy social media post Etc in order to
convince the readers to take some action
copyrighting should be part of any
marketing plan and is one of the most
powerful ways to capture the attention
of your target audience and motivate
them to convert or purchase copyrighting
is everywhere when you go online or even
offline remember the Google ad that you
see when you search for something in
Google that is a copy or if you check
your email box you will find different
promotional mails by different companies
that are a copy basically those
companies are trying to convince you to
take some action it can be anything for
example an e-commerce company will
convince you to purchase some of their
store products now let's talk about the
copyrighting formula a good copy usually
follows Aida formula a stands for
attention I for interest D for desire
and a for Action almost every good
copywriter uses this formula to write
better copies and it's important for you
in case you decided to become a
copywriter or want to use copyrighting
in some of your work so I hope now we
understand what actually copyrighting is
now let's try to understand what does a
copywriter actually do the copywriter
job is to write words that convince an
audience to take some action for the
benefit of the company in which the
writer Works let's have a look at sample
copyrighted job description that will
help you understand the role and
responsibilities and the skills needed
for this role so firstly let's have a
look at responsibilities writing editing
and Publishing engaging content for
various social media Network including
Facebook Twitter Instagram LinkedIn and
Google my business optimizing social
media post language tone message based
on your target audience Behavior
selecting appealing images and videos to
complement text for designers to design
the
post let's have a look at some more
responsibilities coordinate with
internal teams to create advertising
post for client respond to questions and
comments on social media Pages promptly
and accurately there can be more
responsibilities to a copywriter
depending on what the company needs so
it varies from company to company now
let's see what skills a company looks
for in a
copywriter hands-on experience using
various social media platform to
advertise solid knowledge of SEO keyword
research and analytics tools example
Google analytics familiarity with online
paid advertising let's have a look of
some others requirement and
skills ability to deliver creative web
content text image and video excellent
communication
skills so now we know what copywriter
does let's explore its various types SEO
copyrighting it means optimizing the
copy using keywords to make it rank at
the top of the search results for
example if you optimize a company's
product page correctly through SEO
copyrighting then there is a high
chances that your sales page would rank
at the top of the search result which
would result in more sales next we have
social media copyrighting this type of
copyrighting is used on social media
platform for example a catchy title is
used to grab the attention of the user
and Emoji is used to make the copy
interesting or frame the right message
in order to convince the audience to
take some kind of action next we have
technical copyrighting the motive for
writing technical copy is to explain the
latest Technologies or the technical
product that a company wants to sell for
example if you have a tech product you
need a copywriter who can explain the
technical aspect use case of the product
and how that product help the customer
direct response copyrighting it is a
type of communication that is compelling
enough to be able to influence the
customers to act in other words any copy
that encourages the recipient to act
immediately and the response from the
reader are measurable another type of
copyrighting is Public Relation
copyrighting in Public Relation
copyrighting you write newsworthy things
to catch your audience attention and
gain their trust it helps you quickly
earn an audience with credible sources
and as a result your business can
promote its product and services more
effectively whenever you search on
Google you see some ads at the top of
the search results that are also made up
using copyrighting following that next
we have add copyrighting this type of
copyrighting is used to create effective
ads generally it's used in Facebook and
Google ads now we reached the second
last type of copyrighting in the list
which is email copyrighting as you
understood by the name all the copy that
we use in emails are email copyrighting
in it includes a good subject line nice
preview text an intro sentence for the
body of your email and a strong call to
action now let's discuss our last type
which is brand copyrighting brand
recognition and connecting with customer
begin with communicating what your brand
represents your brand image can be
conveyed through writing it can be in
the form of logo a song or a phrase to
create brand copy you have to think
about your customers first with this we
have come to the end of this
copyrighting types list before jump
jumping into the next topic I have a
task for you just pause this video and
in the comment box type your favorite
type of copyrighting I hope you are done
with the comment let's move forward to
our next topic which is difference
between copyrighting and content writing
firstly let's discuss the difference
based on the overall goal copyrighting
is a type of writing aimed at selling a
brand on the other hand content writing
is all about building a perception in
consumer's mind the next difference is
based on the length of the content a
copywriter typically writes short form
of copy and a Content writer writes long
form of Copy Text written by copywriter
is brief and engaging content writer
often have to write more in-depth
content explaining a process or topic
now what's the difference when it comes
to a role in a company a copywriter is
someone whose primary role is to create
copy and a Content writer often does
more than just write it may be a writer
blogger executive or anyone else lastly
let's discuss the difference based on
SEO a good copywriter understand SEO but
when it comes to a good content writer
they should know about the advanced SEO
now let's explore some of the helpful
tools for a copywriter copy AI it's an
AI tool and the greatest thing about
this tool is it's very simple to use you
can generate Instagram caption product
description and even product value
proposition by just providing a few
words it's a paid tool but it has a 7
days free trial the next tool that we
have is grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that finds mistakes in your
writing and suggest improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistake you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plagarism checker
and a punctuation checker however for
additional features you need to go with
grammarly premium word tune with the
help of grammarly you can fix your
writing mistakes but when it comes to
rephrase and rewording your content
without sacrificing flow tone or meaning
word tune came into the picture hence
the combination of grammarly and word
tune is the best for the copywriter and
it's a paid tool but have a free plan
for beginners the last tool in our
bucket is Wordsmith if you rely on data
in your day-to-day decisions Wordsmith
is a perfect for you it can be used for
everything from journalism to financial
reporting because it produces natural
sounding content simply create one
template and set up a few variables and
Wordsmith will generate multiple
alternative Scripts for example you can
write chatbot scripts for responding to
various complex customer requests now
comes the most interesting and the last
topic of a session the average salary of
a copywriter several factors determine
the income a person can expect including
experience the size of your company your
location and your industry copywriters
are the brain behind advertisements
explaining what the product does and why
people should buy it they are also
responsible for shaping the Brand's
identity and tone of voice copy riters
are a valuable resources for businesses
as they are responsible for writing the
first impression customers get of a
company a copywriters earns
approximately 3 lakh 64,000 perom in
India and in the US HEI can earn roughly
$53,000 and when it comes to a senior
copywriter the average salary in India
is 5 lak 86,000 per anom and in the US
HEI can roughly earn
$78,000 per year in most organizations
the people who are doing search engine
optimization have been doing it for a
while and I can tell you cuz I've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days it was mostly technical with a
little bit of content sprinkled in so
for argument sake let's say 8020 80% of
what an SEO needed to learn how to do
had to deal with you you know your metat
tags your metadata you know uh CMS
system and blah blah blah blah blah and
oh by the way yeah you needed some
content on the
page well here we are a long time past
that and if this you you you look
through this slide here for example uh
this is the latest guidance from
Google on the kind of content they
want and if you look through the list
here most of the items on it aren't
Technical and frankly most of it is
content and if you think about it what
this means is is that the job
description for SEO has changed
dramatically particularly beginning with
the panda update but then including the
uh penguin update and then hummingbird
and pardon me more and more and more
seos had better be interacting with the
people who are
creating quality content engaging
content credible qu content um um useful
content it's not enough just to put
keywords in the right places anymore on
pretty thin content that won't get you
where you want to go so
again different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in SEO frankly
need each other and they may or may not
recognize it in your organization but
you know it's a starting point this is a
conversation you you probably need to
have content marketing is comp Le
Lex it often overlaps with other
elements of uh marketing uh the the most
typical overlaps are with social media
marketing and
SEO and uh they're probably already
are in your organization those kind of
groups the seos may be
on one floor and uh the social media
marketing people may be in a different
building you know
whatever but the new success formula
says we got to get all those folks to
the same table now we may have to do it
virtually we may have to use you know
webinars in order to hold those kind of
meetings who
knows but the point is is that uh you
know the world is Shifting and
organizational structures need to shift
with it and again you know that's not
something you can change tomorrow but
that is something that will evolve over
time and for what it's worth it turns
out that let's just say uh the people
who were in
SEO uh they may or may not admit it at
first but they absolutely need to work
with the people in content
marketing why because basically after
Panda and Penguin the rules
shifted and it's less about your time
tile
tag and it's most mostly focused now on
the quality of your content and whether
that content is link worthy which means
it's really compelling content it's
remarkable content that's content that's
going to get people to link to it
because wow that's you know and that's
not necessarily part of the skill set
that was required to be a successful SEO
5 years ago or 10 years
ago so again you got to get these folks
to the table they've got to work
together you know and um and again that
means the organizational structure
probably needs to
shift and the same is true with the
social media marketing folks you know
they went out and their initial goals
and objectives were you know get lots of
likes you know get lots of fans uh get
lots of views gets lots of Twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave
us and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out none of those measures
actually measure real success because
they're focused on being successful on
the
platform boy I have lots of fans as
opposed to being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales so there is a real real
discrepancy between let's just say the
center of
gravity okay it's not Facebook you're
not going to make uh a lot of money on
Facebook you know it's just not set up
to do
business you got to get those folks that
you've engaged in Facebook to your
website where they can buy
something and that's a you know radical
shift for all the folks who uh are in
social media marketing to say wait wait
time
out but that's not what I was told a
couple years ago and the answer is
that's correct what we've learned over
time is that being engaging is
useful if it's harnessed to a benefit
and I'll tell you in most organizations
the social media marketing people are
under Cloud because they aren't
delivering business
benefit
and they too need to learn to work with
the content marketing people in order to
do that and in some cases they may not
be creating the right kind of
content that actually generates leads
and sales as opposed to you know is
inexpensive to create to get my next fan
or my next Twitter
follower so the key metrics here are no
longer how many likes or comments or
shares did you get that's
nice
but how many sales leads did you
generate what percentage of those
converted into
sales that's a radical change but again
it helps when the social media marketing
people are at the table with the content
marketing people there is a difference
between content strategy and content
marketing where content strategy focus
on the actual content content marketing
focuses on the outcome content strategy
is about a management and creation of
the media the tools you are using the
resources you have available what are
the types of content you will be
creating where content marketing is all
about the customer who are you targeting
with the content how well do you know
this person and most important of all
what is the expected business
outcome are you creating and sharing
content to build brand awareness or are
you aiming to increase
Revenue more generic content marketing
questions are how it fits within your
overall digital marketing strategy what
does your content calendar look like and
also by sharing your content are you
exposed to risk in any way does your
content work for every
Market content creation
framework a good way to start putting
together your content marketing strategy
is by creating your content marketing
framework it enables you to map out the
required content along the customer
buying Journey while considering the
impact it has on your online presence
your social media your website and your
sales between these two areas the
customer journey and your overall
digital marketing approach you have the
three types of content you need to focus
on on link content conversion content
and Authority content link content is
content that drives traffic from the
internet and from your social media to
your website this is content that is
created with the goal of attracting
quality backlinks for SEO purposes
conversion content is content that
drives web visitors to the next stage in
the buying cycle through call to actions
or ctas this is the content is created
with the goal to convince prospects that
they should buy from you Authority
content drives web visitors to sales
through call to actions and drives
repeat traffic to your website this is
content that is created to build a
community of people that trust you and
see you as the expert in your field this
is a useful structure to organize your
content and it keeps your focus on the
customer needs and the impact on your
overall digital Market marketing
objectives each type of content has
different requirements link content
needs to be high quality and often based
on Research so other websites can refer
to it it's all geared towards generating
high quality backlinks to your website
which Google Sees as very important for
your search ranking make this content
fail prooof repurpose it and promote it
like crazy conversion content is based
on helping the customer to go through
the buying cycle this will only work if
you understand what they need and that
your content clearly articulates that
you can help them solve their problem
but on top of that it is vital in this
stage that your content gives them the
option to move to the next stage through
very clear and compelling call to
actions and Authority content is a
logical followup from your link content
it is content that confirms you are an
expert in your field it helps you to
build trust as long as you are truthful
transparent and show integrity and done
continuously and consistently it helps
you to deepen the relationship with your
prospects and your clients content
marketing strategy there are various
steps in developing your content
marketing strategy the obvious thing of
course is to start with setting your
objectives but Additionally you need to
do a number of things create customer
personas create listening outposts write
your Brand Story develop your channel
strategy create your content marketing
Playbook measure your content marketing
and establish your content marketing Roi
let's look at these elements of your
content marketing strategy in a bit more
detail customer
personas a vital step in your content
marketing strategy is creating customer
personas this is a concept that comes
from the user interface and design world
in a customer Persona you look at things
like demographic characteristics like
age and gender but it is important to
add to this what their pain points are
what is their Affinity with technology
where do they hang out online and what
are their interests and their Hobbies
once you completed your customer
personas print them out and put them on
the wall in your office and make sure
you add them to your briefing document
when you ask your agency to create a new
campaign
HubSpot has a great free tool to create
customer personas by asking a set of
questions it will put it in a format for
you that you can share and print and you
can tailor it to your own requirements
and add your own sections it includes
things like education social networks
they use preferred method of
communication tools they need to do
their job goals and objectives
challenges and how they gain knowledge
establish listening post an important
part of your content marketing strategy
is to listen to what people are talking
about online you can find out what they
think about your brand the topics they
talk about and if there are any issues
it is also great to listen online to
find good content you could share you
don't have to share just your own
content there's nothing wrong with
sharing relevant content from others
obviously when I say listening or line I
mean this in the widest sense watching
videos reading articles or blogs looking
at photos or infographics or literally
listening to podcasts here are a few
tools you can use to listen Feedly is a
reader app on which you can listen to
Live RSS feeds Google Alerts and talk
Walker are tools that will send you a
notification for certain terms that you
have set you can use Google Trends to
find out search trans for keywords your
Brand's
Story the next thing you need to work
out for your content marketing strategy
is your Brand Story what is your mission
your vision your values what is the
story of your company your CEO remember
people want to listen and share
stories when I search for Ika on Google
you get an understanding of what I mean
stories about the history of the company
the found of the company the way they
work the employees what makes them
unique and the more twists turns and
uncertainties in these stories the more
people will love
them and it gets even better if you can
show them how you overcame obstacles and
bumps in the road this will increase
your credibility a good example of this
is Elon Musk from Tesla he came from a
very simple background but kept on
following his beliefs even when was
nearly bankrupt he kept on going and
look where he is now an important
element of defining your content
marketing strategy is understanding of
what kind of brand you are the type of
brand you are determines the type of
social media you will get with your
content if you are a basic brand you
won't get many people to talk about you
let alone comment on your social media
posts you're just fulfilling a basic
need the only way these Brands can get
engagement on social media is to turn
themselves into a funny brand like
blende Tech blenders who launched the
will it blend campaign if you are a
functional brand you will have customers
who ask questions about how to use your
product you need to respond to that by
offering content in which you answer
their
questions exciting Brands don't have a
problem to get social media engagement
with their content they they have
thousands of fans who love to talk about
a brand Harley-Davidson is a classic
example these Brands need to keep on
posting amazing content that become
almost like collector items for their
fans finally vital brands are for the
greater benefit of mankind Greenpeace
World Wildlife Fund UNICEF they have no
problem in getting engagement and
discussions but they should be very
alert on what people are talking about
about and try to find influences that
can help them spread their
CA so think about this when you start
putting your content marketing strategy
together it will guide you on the type
of content and campaigns you should
create and the types of calls to action
you should
set social channel strategy before
you're going to decide on the type of
content you're going to create it makes
sense to agree on the social media
channels you are going to use in the
listening stage you have learned on
which channels your clients hang out so
now you're going to make sure you are
there as well you're going to
synchronize The Branding the key
messages and the campaigns to grow your
followers on these channels you need to
make sure you understand the latest
features and Trends on these social
channels it is also good to do a Content
Gap analysis what type of content do you
already have for each Channel and where
are the gaps so you know what type of
content you need to create here is a
useful template you can use for this it
shows you the channels the structure the
tone of voice for each Channel and the
desired action the gaps will give you an
indication of the work you need to do to
make sure you have a coherent content
marketing
strategy content marketing Playbook so
now you are in a position to decide on
the type of content you're going to
create here is a list structured by the
three types of of content we saw earlier
link conversion and Authority content
link content and Authority content can
be fairly similar it's more on the
promotion side where they differ but the
conversion content needs to be organized
along the customer Journey from
awareness to evaluation to purchase we
call this the marketing Playbook you
need to create your own by selecting the
right content for the right stage
measuring content marketing efforts you
can measure the traffic you get through
your content you can measure the
engagement you get and you can measure
the sentiments whether you are targeting
consumers or businesses the metrics are
the same but the priorities May differ
today lead generation is seen as the
number one kpi when it comes to
measuring the success of your content
marketing closely followed by traffic
generation to your website these metrics
show how your content marketing efforts
are succeeding but you need to go a
level deeper to discover what specific
content campaigns channels and efforts
are most effective in driving value and
in the end whether you are in b2c or B2B
it comes down to measuring the ROI of
your content marketing how much money
did you earn from your content Marketing
in relation to the cost you incurred in
creating and distributing it the things
that can improve your Roi are quality of
your leads sales web traffic engagement
SEO success and brand exposure and
remember improved Roi is not just based
on more sales it can also be based on
Lower in cost planning your content
marketing strategy planning your content
marketing strategy is very important
there are so many things you need to
take into consideration if you don't put
some structure into this you may lose
lose control it is best to create your
content marketing process guide in this
guide you specify how you create and
manage your content how you optimize and
curate how you listen and engage in
conversations and how you measure your
content marketing besides this there is
the technical stuff like roles and
responsibilities what are the style and
writing guidelines and similar what are
the guidelines for posting and
Publishing and make sure you communicate
a process guide to the relevant people
in your organization you may want to put
a training together to the people who
will work with this on a daily basis a
vital part of your process guide is the
content marketing calendar it's the
calendar that contains your content
production and publication schedule
there are many templates and tools for
this on the internet my favorite ones
are trello.com and Google Calendar the
most important part of it is that it is
a collaborative tool so you can schedule
the calendar with your colleagues or
with your client you can give people
viewing or editing access you can use
color codes for the different types of
content or for the different channels
becoming a Content marketing company to
give you a framework on how to organize
your content marketing strategy in your
company you can look at the content
marketing Institute four business models
for Content
marketing they can be mapped in a
quadrant with strategic importance on
one AIS and internal external focus on
the other you're a player when your
content marketing strategy is focused on
supporting teams within the organization
like your product marketing or marketing
communication teams most companies start
their content marketing like this it's
seen as a contributor you're a performer
when your content marketing is seen as a
center of excellence in your
organization it has an external Focus
where audience segmentation is key it
can be seen as a support function to
other parts in the organization you're a
processor when you centralize certain
content functions but not the actual
creation of it your corporate team may
create a Content campaigns with the
corporate guidelines where your local
teams are responsible for local content
creation to execute a campaign and
you're a platform when you approach your
content marketing as a strategic
business within your business often this
is done on a corporate level and this is
separate from local content marketing
initiatives so you need to understand
where you are today and have a vision of
where you want to go today in an era of
mobile devices robots and social media
content creation is the most effective
inbound marketing
strategy nearly 40% of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and and 81% say their
company views content as a business
strategy original and high quality
content can help your company stand out
and attract new customers and help your
business grow on that note welcome to
Simply learns YouTube channel today we
are here with a fantastic video on chat
GPD for Content creation which will help
you create some compelling content on
your desired topics but before we begin
are you aiming to get certified as a
digital marketer and want to build your
career in digital marketing well in that
case you can check the professional
digital marketing course by simply learn
which will open the doors for the best
career opportunities to find the details
of the professional digital marketing
course check the link in the description
box below it could be an ideal solution
to help you build career in the right
direction and if you haven't subscribed
already please subscribe to our Channel
simply learn and hit that Bell icon to
never miss an update from us but before
we get started guys I have a question
for you is CH GPT an application and is
it available on Android well let us know
the answer in the comments below so let
us understand what is chat GPT here now
content creation can be of any type such
as blogs podcast videos graphics and so
on but how do you create high quality
content with a few minutes it not be
worried when we have chat GPT now even
though there are numerous AI writing
tools for Content creation chat GPT
stands out from the crowd due to its
faster response rate ease of use
increased productivity support for
multiple languages and other benefits
now let's try to understand what exactly
chat GP is and how to create content
from it now generally chat GPT is an
open AI trained and developed model that
works
conversationally chat GPT is capable of
systematically resolving all bugs while
providing detailed explanation for each
step it takes so in simple words chat
GPT is a tool that creates content for
any query chat GPT stands out among all
the other achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chat GPT uses
deep learning techniques to generate
humanik text which is based on a machine
learning model derived from the large
language model class now it is trained
on a massive Text data sets from the
internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chat GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers share their views on an
individual subject now there are variety
of categories for writing a Blog so
let's pick one for chat GPD here so as
you can see we have navigated into chat
GPD and let us now ask ask a simple
question about food blogging now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to chat GPT and it will answer so I'm
just uh writing a question here saying
how to start a foot blogging
carrier so as you can see it is
generating the answer for us uh wait for
it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a food block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love of food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose a nishe
choose a name and domain choose a
blogging platform create your blog
create high quality content and so on so
in this way chat GPT will automatically
generate the response for you based on
the questions that you are giving input
to it next we will see another question
on lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular uh entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in chat GPT as well
and see what it will show the answer so
let's uh give the question as how to
start Life
Style blogging in
India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interest so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points for us in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your nishe choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on for beginners let me
give give you a few facts and figures
about blogs before we dive into the
topic did you know that there are more
than 600 million blogs on the internet
and every day over two million blog
posts are published on all those blog
posts that are out there
77% of Internet users they read blog and
they leave about 77 million comments per
month on all these blog posts so it is a
massive um place where you can get
engagement and where you can get people
talking about the things that you're
writing about now people that include
visuals to their blogs they will see
that they get about
94% more views than those people that do
not add visuals to their blog
surprisingly Tumblr is the most used
blogging platform with over half a
billion blogs out there but there are 60
million blogs that are powered by
WordPress also did you know that blogs
are the second most form of media used
in content marketing so lots about
blogging lots of facts they're out there
they're key they're relevant and this
blog is going to introduce you to how to
get started with a Blog now blogs have
been around for a very long time yeah do
you know what the name of the first blog
was and who created it was it A B C or D
well let me give you the answer Justin
Hall started link.net in
1994 as a student at a um at a college
becoming one of the first widely read
bloggers out there in the late 1990s the
first blocks were created primarily
serving as personal journ journals for
small groups of friends or for family
now in the early 2000s blogging tools
and services became more widely
available and it is also when I got my
first experience in blogging when my son
went on a um on a gap year traveling in
in Southeast Asia and he shared his
photos through the internet on a uh on a
Blog so he found internet cafes during
his journey and in each Cafe he's he
started up his blog and added a photo so
that's how I could follow his uh his
trip so it makes it became easier and
easier for people to start to create and
maintain their own blogs in 2002 the
term blog was coined and became widely
used to describe a website that serves
as an online journal or a diary so in
2014 the political world started to get
an idea about the power of blogs they
emerged and played role in shaping
public opinion influencing selections
2005 to 2010 was the big growth of blogs
and they started to gain popularity and
they came into sort of the um into the
more widely
uh discussible areas like photography
blogs and recipe blogs and then in the
2010s businesses got to see the power of
blogs and they started to use blogs as a
main mainstream form of communication
and for other people as self-expression
with millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving a diverse
range of audiences so today blogging
continues to play a significant role in
the rise of social media and it has a
very big impact on the way people
communicate and consume information
online a fantastic tool to learn to find
out about what's happening in the world
what's find to find out what's happening
in particular niches that you're
interested in and a great way to start
sharing your your own opinion so what
will we be talking about we're going to
be talking about what is a Blog what
skills do you need for blogging why
actually should you create a blog what
are the types of blog posts that you can
create and I'm going to show you some
examples of those different types of
blog posts how do you create a blog and
and I'm going to give you some blog
writing tips to close off with the uh on
the video today so let's get into it
what is a Blog now there are many
different definitions of a Blog yeah
there a Blog can be a personal blog it
can be a corporate blog it can be a news
blog yeah so a personal blog is where
it's a type of blog where individuals
share their thoughts their opinions
their experiences their um their stories
on a particular topic or a particular
range yeah these type of blogs are very
easy to set up and they don't cost a lot
of money but it's very much with a
personal Focus businesses they usually
have corporate blogs it's a typle Blog
by created is by a company and um it can
be used for marketing it can be used for
Branding it can be used for
communication purposes for lead
generation usually they share company
news they share product updates or
industry Insight yep so it's also really
good to engage with customers and to get
in a dialogue with customers to build
relationships and to create um thought
expertise in a particular Niche the
third type of blog that you can see and
this definition of a blog is a news blog
is a type of blog that focuses on
reporting and analyzing current events
current news stories what's happening in
the world from a particular angle it
could be one journalist it could be a
group of journalists it could be a media
organization yeah and it can cover a
wide range of topics or it can focus on
a particular Niche like entertainment or
like technology so it can be used to
create different perspectives on new
stories or to supplement the traditional
news stories but if we're looking at the
plain def defition of a Blog if you look
at all the blogs they work from the same
concept yeah a blog is a type of website
serving as an online journal or diary
and it consists of posts on a particular
topic or a particular theme yeah now a
Blog can be created by an individual or
by businesses and as say as I said
earlier they can serve different
purposes for personal or for business or
for news they're very easy to create
blogs and that makes them so powerful
then you can use Simple blogging
software there's lots of free tools
available and you can get started within
five minutes they have lots of features
like commenting yes so um and by using
the commenting functions you can allow
engagement with your readers and you can
really build up a community
now you can find blogs on specific
Standalone websites like a Blog website
or you can find them on um embedded
within a corporate uh corporate website
you could even blog on social media
networks like LinkedIn or um or Facebook
and they often use a Content management
system yep to um to create a blog to
manage the blog and to add add new
content new pages on your
blog blogging for me is the easiest way
to get started with social media yeah so
they played a significant role in the
growth of social media and it had
fundamentally changed the way businesses
communicated with um with their
customers yes so and and how people sort
of consume
information yes so they have a number of
things in common yeah so if you go to a
Blog each blog you will see a number of
recurring things the first thing of
course that you see are the blog posts
they are the Articles or the entries
written or published on the blogs and
they can be in different presentation
formats yeah you can see it in little
thumbnails you can see it in the
headlines yeah um or you can see just a
scroll down of all the blog posts but
the blog posts are obviously the core of
each blog post blogs have comments you
can switch off the comments if you want
but most blogs they have commenting and
they are an important part of a Blog
because they allow you to engage with
the author yeah or that the author can
engage with their readers so that gives
a platform for discussion for feedback
and for interaction around the
blog yeah when you start blogging you
may have a you may build up a big
library of blogs of blog posts yeah so a
common feature on every blog is that
they have categories and tags yep and
you see them on the column on the right
on blog posts and that means that you
can easily access previous content so
you're not stuck to the main article but
you give people access to other content
through categories through tags or the
most popular post or the last five posts
blogs also have an about page what is
this blog all about it provides reader
with information about the author of The
Blog yeah the purpose of the blog the
mission of the blog so some background
information good blogs also have a
search box yeah it's another way where
you can easily search for Content yeah
that has already been published on the
blog
now a Blog without sharing buttons yeah
is like you're keeping it a secret so
one of the powerful features of a Blog
is that you as the author can share it
on social media but you can also ask
your readers to share it on social media
by using the sharing buttons then there
is the archive section where it
organizes the post by month by year or
by category again making it easy to to
access previous content and then many
blogs have a call to action yeah so that
is a button that encourages readers to
take a specific action like subscribing
to the blog or downloading an ebook or
signing up for a newsletter yes so is
very good tool to start creating and
building your
audience and on top of that you need to
think about the design and the
navigation of your blog is very
important and we talk talked about that
in our other blogging video um that we
posted a few weeks ago yes so those are
the common elements of a Blog so let's
dig a bit deeper we talked about yeah
how a Blog can be personal it can be for
business it can be news as long as it is
in a specific topic yes
so around that topic or theme you can
start sharing your thoughts sharing your
ideas your knowledge and you can express
yourself so most some of the most
important and in demand topics for blogs
are lifestyle yeah like topics like
Fashion Beauty Health Wellness travel
and food are very popular they have a
very wide appeal and that's very
personal relevance to readers as well
technology is a very hot topic yeah so
the Fast Change of Technology uh
Innovation technological developments
there's always something to write about
there's always news around um technology
yeah so that is a very hot topic another
topic is personal finance people love to
know more about how to manage their P
finances and blogs can be a really good
way to help the readers and giving them
tips in how to manage their Finance um
in a range of topics from savings
investing debt management um and
budgeting yeah there's blogs about
Business and Entrepreneurship they are
very popular from starting a new
business yeah to growing an existing one
how to relate to your customers there's
a huge demand for top for blogs around
the theme of business and business
support now there's news websites
there's news blogs around current events
that cover the latest news yeah they are
popular they can focus on a particular
area like what's it like politics or
technology or they can cover a more
broad range as well there's creative
blogs creative writing creative
literature writing yes so blogs that are
about creative writing and about
literature they can be a great source of
inspiration and then finally personal
development is a very big category in
blogs a very popular category yeah
personal development and
self-improvement like personal growth
selfcare self-improvement they're really
popular and they are relevant to
people's day today life yeah so these
are some of the most popular blog posts
and the blog topics that people um that
people are interested in so for you
start looking into the topics if you
want to start blogging
yeah and see if you can pick a sort of a
a a topic that is within these uh Within
These
categories so is blogging difficult do I
need a wide range of skills for blogging
well it's not too difficult but of
course people have lots of different
questions about blogging before they
start how do I start a blog how do I
come up with ideas for my blog content
how do I get traffic to my blog how
often should I publish on my blog post
how do I monetize my blog what should I
write about what should I include in my
blog post how do I write an exciting
headline how do I promote my blog on
social media how do I engage with my
readers how do I track the success of my
blog lots and lots of questions yeah and
of course to answer all these questions
you do need to have certain skills
before you start blogging so let's have
a look at those
skills so to be successful with a Blog
and to successfully start a blog there
are some skills that you need of course
you can work on those skills you can
start building up those skills but these
are the five topics that are playing an
important part of your blogging work
your blogging activity there's
writing there's search engine
optimization there's marketing there's
web design and there's social
media yeah so first you need to be able
to write you need to research you need
to write in a clear concise and engaging
manner yep and that is a skill in itself
and of course when you start blogging
you you may not have that much
experience but when you have been
blogging for 6 months to a year you will
see that it gets easier and
easier the next thing you need to do is
to be able to optimize your blog posts
for search for Google for Bing yeah so
that they those search engines will find
your blog posts when you publish them
yeah and a very important part of your
search engine optimization is to
identify the keywords that are relevant
for your business and relevant for your
blog and then you need to understand how
to use those keywords
effectively then of course you need to
Market your blog you need to grow an
audience you need to get people to
subscribe to your blog maybe to start
building an email uh list yeah so you
need to understand email marketing you
need to know all online marketing to
promote your blog you need to know how
to do that you need to know where to do
that you may want to look at affiliate
marketing which means you can promote
other people's product on your blog and
you would get a um a small commission
for that yes so lots of marketing
activities that you need to look into to
actually to publish your blog and make
it become visible and make it become
popular now of course there is the web
design element for your blog as well and
those are skills that you need to have
there are very simple tools as you will
see later yeah that you can use to set
up your uh your blog there's free tools
that you can use there's more advanced
tools as well and as with many things
with the more advanced tools and the
premium tools that you use you get more
quality you get more options you get
often a better design yeah so that is
the balance that you need to strike
between hey how much do I want to do for
free and want to do simple uh compared
to do you want to invest some money and
do you want to have a more advanced um
website yes so that is the balance that
you need to do but you do need to have
some basic web design skills and then
finally you need to have your social
media skills yeah social media is a key
part of promoting your blog on the
Social Web and you need to know how to
do that you need to know how to set that
up you need to know how to create those
social media posts and how to track them
when they um when you have published
them yes so lots of skills that you need
but it doesn't mean that you need to be
an expert immediately when you start
with that yeah but it is it is important
that you recognize those topics and that
you start building experience for that
okay so if you feel that you have those
skills yeah then is that enough for you
to start creating a Blog yeah there's
some other questions that you need to
ask yourself first of all one of the
biggest questions you need to ask
yourself is what am I going to write
about yeah do I have a passion for
writing and sharing my knowledge about a
certain topic do I have a passion about
a theme about a topic and am I do I have
a passion about technology do I have a
passion about health yeah so you need to
have that passion because when you start
developing your blog and writing your
blog post it takes an it takes time it
takes effort and the more passionate you
are about the topic that you write about
then that time and that effort doesn't
matter you don't feel like it's taking
all that time because you're doing
something that you really really
like you also need to have very clear
goals yeah what are you going to do with
your blog why are you having this blog
you also need to have the time and the
resources to regularly create new blog
posts yeah because there's nothing more
frustrating and nothing more damaging on
your website if you start a blog but
then after five posts you stop with it
yeah there's so many websites where you
go to and then you go to the blog and
the last blog post was 24 months ago
yeah then it almost works against you
yeah it shows hey there's a Blog but
they haven't taken the efforts to um to
start a blog yes so you need to have
that passion you need to have clear
goals now businesses they often have
very clear goals for a Blog yeah they
want to use a Blog to increase traffic
to the website to drive conversions yeah
to get people to the website to get them
to convert into a prospect it helps them
in contributing to their social media
efforts it's great way to build client
trust to be seen as an expert in their
field yep it gets a great way for
developing the brand and reinforce the
key messages around the brand it's great
to differentiate yourself from your
competitors and it is a good way to
encourage engagement with your customers
yeah so for businesses there's almost
like a no-brainer they want to they they
use blogs because they can see that they
get a lot of benefits but for you let's
take it very simple yeah there are five
reasons if you want to start your blog
there's five reasons why you can why why
you should create a blog yes first of
all if you want to express yourself
creatively then blogging is the best
place to do
this yeah so if you haven't if you are
passionate about a topic and you want to
share that knowledge then blogging is
the number one place to go to yeah
second if you want to show yourself as
an expert or build yourself as an expert
and you want to grow want to grow an
audience around this you want to grow a
follower base who are interested in
learning about what you have to say
about your topic yeah so if you want to
establish expertise and build an
audience then you have to start using a
Blog for that thirdly a reason why you
must create a blog yeah if you want to
build a community if you want to network
with other people if you want to network
with prospects get them to your website
get them to convert yeah if you want
that to grow your business then blogging
is certainly a fantastic video vehicle
to help you achieve that another reason
to create a blog is that you want to
enhance your writing and your thinking
skills yeah so blogging is not writing a
book blogging is not writing an ebook
because and people may be scared of that
it may be too um too much of a uh um an
unknown field but start writing small
simple articles on your blog thereby you
develop your writing and you develop
your thinking skills very good reason
for you to start blogging you don't even
have to publish it you can just keep it
your private blog yeah but then when you
feel comfortable you can then start
publishing it and then finally and
that's how I started as well with my own
business if you want to start making
money if you want to start your own
business yeah then a blog is a fantastic
vehicle to help position you in your
Market in your industry yeah so it's a
great vehicle that can help you to
become self-employed or make more money
so lots of reasons for you to start
creating a Blog yeah so now that we've
seen what you need yeah for creating and
start blogging yeah why you should start
blogging uh let's have a look at at the
different types of blog posts that you
can create on your blog there are many
different types of posts and I'll give
you a list of them in um in a minute and
each blog post each type of blog post
they serve a different purpose and a
different requirement from the readers
but there are some
reasons that apply to every reader first
of all your blog post must provide
value yeah different readers have
different preferences to the type of
content they like to read but value is
the same for everybody yeah so if you
provide value to your readers you keep
them engaged and very important you keep
them coming back another common
characteristics for BL for all blog
posts is that you need to keep them
fresh and you need to keep them in
interesting so it means you need to make
sure that the content is up to date but
also that you do a variety of post types
because that keeps it fresh that keeps
it interesting it also sort of helps in
breaking up the um the monotone um sort
of style of a Blog yes so use different
content Styles use different formats use
different visuals to keep your content
alive and interesting another common
element for all blog posts is you need
to cater to the different learning
styles some people may read want to read
text-based blog posts some people may
want to see more visual content or
infographics some people may want to see
video content yeah so offer that Variety
in your blog posts so you can cater for
different type of audiences with
different different type of learning
styles and then very important with a
Blog and each blog post sort of caters
for that it showcases your
Authority Yeah by offering different
types of blog posts you can demonstrate
that you're the expert regardless the
type of blog post that you do but people
will come back to your blog if they see
you as yeah this person knows what he's
talking about and that can help you
build credibility with the readers and
establish a yourself as a thought leader
in your industry yeah so overall
offering a variety of different types of
blog posts can help you attract readers
but not only that you can retain your
readers and you may get them back yeah
they may become part of your audience as
long as you showcase your expertise and
keep your content fresh and
interesting so given those common
elements of blog posts let's look at
some different types of blog posts the
most popular blog posts are list based
posts yeah they provide a list of tips
of resources or other information on a
specific topic people love lists people
love the top five things in this or 10
things you may have missed yeah a really
good example of a list based post is
live hacker live hacker gives you live
hacks yes so nine food labels that don't
mean what you think they mean yeah 15
ways to build a better breakfast
sandwich nine of the most dangerous
driving and emergencies little tips list
of tips people love those and the way
they are presented on these blog is
actually quite interesting yeah instead
of having a long article about this they
actually have a short introduction but
they do them as slideshows why not yeah
it's
visual yeah so here is one yeah so here
is the next slide yeah so black eyes
here you see little highlight of what is
uh what what it's about yeah animals in
the
road next one is a car with mattress
flapping on the rooftop may look funny
but you don't want to be behind it yes
so lots of good tips and people love
these type of
blogs the next one is thought leadership
posts so they express the author's
thoughts or feelings on a specific topic
and particularly for businesses these
are very important because by building
thought
leadership which means being seen as an
expert in your field you're also
building trust now one of the best
thought leadership blogs in the industry
is Harvard Business Review yeah so lots
of articles on a lot of different topics
around business yeah here you see the
different categories the different media
formats yeah and here you see the
different blogs that they topic writing
about yes so generative AI can help you
tailor messaging here is the article
yeah and here you see also the call to
action that we talked about subscribe to
Harvard Business riew yeah they have
here options to monetize the uh the blog
and here you talk about subscribe yeah
subscribe all simple call to actions
here is a summary of the article here's
the article itself we talked about that
here's the social sharing button yeah
here's the visual that they use so all
the aspects that we talked about earlier
are available in this blog yeah but
these are typical thought leadership
blogs that can really help in developing
yourself as an expert case study blogs
they are sort of blogs with articles
that give an in-depth analysis of a
single topic yes
so typically to prove a point or back up
an argument yeah so this is kind of
background information to make your
point so good example for that is
HubSpot yeah so HubSpot is a marketing
automation system they have one of the
best blogs in the industry yeah where
they give lots of background information
on all the different social media
digital marketing topics that you can
find yeah so here you see how a homepage
of a Blog yeah can be organized that is
your featured post here you have more
featured post you see it's very visual
here you have the last sort of blog post
here you see last categories and the
blog post call to action call to action
here yeah another category and then to
make it more exciting we'll add videos
to this page as
well yeah so good example of a case
study blog yeah and and a general blog
in with all the features that it need
you then have video and audio blogs
video becomes more and more important as
a Channel of communication yeah
so start using video we also have seen
the growth of podcasting start using
audio Yeah and use those as part of your
blogging strategy as well here's a good
example yeah that is SoundCloud now
SoundCloud is a website which is kind of
the YouTube for audio Yeah for for uh
for podcast for audio files and here you
see their blog which a good mix of news
resources audio files blog post with
text yeah and video files as well so
it's a perfect combination of all the
elements that we're talking about here
yes so very important to use video and
audio blogs as well here are some more
types of blogs news jacking or news
posts they provide information on recent
events or developments in a specific
industry yeah so good news checking
hacking website is wired yeah
specifically focus on
technology yeah and it is a go-to place
for the latest news on
technology it's you see a very clear
style you see it on the visuals as well
yeah and is again it is a news kind of
portal yeah which gives you access to
all the blog posts it doesn't really
look like a Blog it looks like a news
portal and that is particularly for news
websites a very common way of using a
blogging platform to create a news
portal okay we're then looking at
infographics posts now you may have
heard of infographics they um are
Graphics that simplify complex materials
with a chart graphs and and graphics
yep and you can do blog posts around
those as well yeah one of my favorites
and you should follow them on Facebook
for and on LinkedIn the visual
capitalist the visual capitalist has a
every day they come out with a new chart
yeah or a new infographic on a
particular topic yeah so here you see a
infographic on the top 50 most visited
websites in the
world so here's the infographic and then
here is the text sort of the background
information about it yeah so here's the
visual so you see Google yeah you see
YouTube Facebook Twitter so here you see
how that all sort of um how that
develops yes so with the text subscribe
to it yes so good visual
comparison so very powerful website so
use those type of websites use that type
of way of presenting your uh your
information we then look at how two
posts they offer a detailed instruction
on how to do a particular task yeah
people love those a good example of how
to block is set godin's blog yep where
he has very simple design for his blog
but this is all about the content so he
has a story of the week or his top 100
posts yeah so how to tell a great story
advice for outer how to be remarket how
to write an ebook how to do permission
marketing an email check is very downto
Earth simple how to tips when it comes
to business very straightforward very
popular blog when it comes to how to
post and then last but not least a very
powerful type of blog is the guest post
yes so why would you write on your own
blog why can't you be a guest blogger on
somebody else's post has lots of
benefits from a search engine
perspective as well for the author of
The Blog because you have other websites
that recognize your um your your
expertise in your area they invite you
to write about that and Google sees that
as a high Authority ranking signal for
your search yeah good example of a um a
guest both is Neil Patel who has its own
website has his own blog is really well
recognized as a digital marketing expert
yep and here he is writing an article as
a guest on the HubSpot blog yep so very
useful very powerful way and very
powerful type of blog post that you can
uh that you you can
write okay so those are the different
blog posts so let's look at how you go
about creating a Blog there's a number
of steps that you need to look at first
of all you need to look at what is the
CMS or the blogging platform that you're
going to use yeah it's a very important
decision for bloggers because there's
sever several sort of decisions that you
need to make here first of all you're
going to look at am I going to use a
simple
platform which is often free to begin
with or am I going professional straight
away so if you're going simple yep then
you can go for tools like
wordpress.com or wix.com they will host
the website for you and those are the
typical tools that give you some B basic
functionality in the free version you
will have your website up and running
within 5 minutes but then if you want
more functionality you pay a bit
more yep now or you want to decide to go
professional which means you're going to
go to a web hosting provider and you're
going to install your own website on
their servers Y and one of the most
popular platforms for that is wordpress.
orc which is a different version of
Wordpress wordpress.org yeah gives you a
lot more flexibility a lot more freedom
a lot more um plugins yeah but it is bit
more complicated to set
up yep and there is some uh the
WordPress itself doesn't cost you any
money but the hosting will cost you
money yeah the questions that you need
to ask yourself whether you want to go
simple or complex are
hey um what do you want your blog to do
do you just want to get it for your
sharing your expertise or do you want to
monetize your blog yeah do you want to
run it as the website for your business
for instance what are your technical
skills do you have very limited
technical skills you may want to go for
a hosted version on wordpress.com or Wix
or Weeble yeah do you have sufficient
technical skills you may want to go for
the word press.org
version which is the hosted version you
need to think about your budget yeah do
you have budget to use a hosted platform
yep and of course you need to look at
the features of the platforms that you
use can you find yourself in the
features that you want to use for that
yes so that is the first question that
you want to ask yourself where are you
going to host your website and that is
what blogging platform are you going to
use step two is you're going to look at
your domain name of course very
important that is the name of your
website the name of your blog it's a
unique web address that is identified
that identifies your blog on the
internet yeah so when you choose your
domain name make sure make make sure it
is memorable it is reflective of your
brand people recognize it it's available
on other other social media websites as
well yep so it hasn't been taken by
other people on Facebook or Instagram
yeah and maybe use your keywords that
are relevant for your blog so lots of
things that you need to do if you want
to have a domain then you can check on
um on sites like God daddy if the domain
name is
available yeah then when you have it you
can then buy it and you usually Bay the
register for a year or for two years if
it's a very simple name that hasn't
that's that is not very popular then it
often cost you maybe $10 if it is a more
popular name that hasn't been registered
yet you may pay more okay so then you
also need to think about the extension
of your domain is it going to be a do
com is it going to be a net is it going
to be a.org or is it going to be a
country extension like NL for the
Netherlands yes so um or dot for France
common rule is if you're targeting a
local market take the URL of the local
market if you're targeting a global
market go for the do or the net but
preferably the do com if you're an organ
government organization then you want to
usually stick to the.org
then of course you will have checked the
availability of your domain and then
you're going to register the domain yes
so you provide your contact information
you pay a small or a large fee depending
on the popularity of the name and then
in your website your blog setup you're
going to connect the domain to your blog
so that means updating the name servers
in your domain's register account so it
then points to your blog Hosting
account yeah so a very simple uh or good
provider you can go to is GoDaddy do.com
or. co.uk and they give you everything
yeah so type the domain that you want
yeah they can help you create your
website they have different types of
services they do domain names they do
website and hosting and they do email
marketing they have really good support
yeah so if you want to type your domain
so let's take for instance um do uh
company ABC is going to be my
domain yep and you see here company
abc.co is
available yes so um there is here's the
company letter you see if you want to
use that one is a premium name so here
you see all the different varieties on
the name yeah here basic company.com
that would cost you £3,000 because it is
a quite a popular name yeah so it is
available
but yeah value for
money okay so that is your um choosing
your domain name then you're going to
look at your hosting plan and your
hosting plan is very important you will
only select the hosting plan if you go
for a
hosted uh blog solution yeah so which
you do with wordpress.org for instance
so basically when you select your
hosting plan you buy a bit of storage
space on the servers of that hosting
profiler and on that spit of storage
page you install your website and then
the service the hosting provider will
connect that to the Internet so they
provide the technology and the support
to store and maintain your
website yes
so that is a very important part and
again you need to consider your budget
and you also need to consider your
website requirements you need to look at
the reliability and the speed and the
uptime yeah so a reliable hosting
provider they offer you high uptime
percentage and fast loading times that
is very
important yep and you need to very
carefully look at customer support yeah
so make sure they offer 247 support
preferably with a chat option because
often you have to wait a long time to
get access and if you have a chat option
is much easier to get your um to get
your problems solved and a very
important part of your hosting plan as
well is your security
yeah make sure that there is a spam
protection on your website and also look
at your https yeah so get your SSL
certificate for your uh for your
website yes so now some popular hosting
providers you can look at include
GoDaddy blue host host Gater dream host
take the time to research them yeah and
evaluate each option and certainly look
at the customer reviews as well next
step is you're going to design
your blog yeah so once you've created or
you selected your hosting provider
you're then going to set up your blog
and you would install wordpress.org yeah
and then you're going to create your
website now the first thing that most of
those CMS yeah platforms will ask you is
what theme do you want to pick and they
have a whole library of themes that you
can pick and choose from
and there's lots of websites that allow
you to buy themes whether it's a
photography theme a health theme a a
business theme Y and then you can just
buy that theme install it in your
WordPress setup yep and then you
download the demo for it and then you
have your website the only you have to
do is change the content and the visuals
and your website is ready yes so very
important that you pick a very powerful
sort of theme you then can customize the
theme with your own photos your own logo
your own color schemes your own options
so you can make it a unique look and
feel you then add your own images yeah
you customize the header of the
website so and then you can use custom
widgets small Med modules that you can
add to your website that do things like
like sign up for my newsletter or
um what's it click on the RSS feed of
your website Etc and then often you can
add your own sort of HTML coding or css
coding as well to give your website
additional functionality a really good
place to buy themes are Este stees
forest.net yeah so there's a whole range
of themes you can say for instance give
me an entertainment themes here you see
entertainment themes could be um yeah so
you want
WordPress yeah for instance WordPress
themes and then you just pick a theme
yeah you can actually do a live preview
of the
theme yeah and this is here see the
demos we want the uh no coding so take
for instance this one here taste the
difference and here you see immediately
how your website will look like how your
blog will look
like yeah so then you download the theme
install it on
WordPress download the demo and again
then the only thing you have to do is
change the text and the visuals yeah and
some Design
Elements so it's so easy there's not a
single line of programming that you have
to do these days yeah when it comes to
your web development and that is a big
concern that people had do I still have
to program no you don't it's all sort of
intuitive step five start creating your
content of course when your blog is live
when your blog is up and running you
need to start creating content for your
blog to by writing posts adding images
creating pages
organizing your content using the
categories and the tags making it easier
for people to find now before you can
start writing your post you of course
you need to know what you're going to
write about yeah what is your focus what
is your Niche what are your interest
what is your passion you need to do
keyword research around those topics
yeah so that gives you the ability to um
understand what your target audience
want to read about
yeah use tools like Google Keyword
Planner and we've done an earlier video
on how to use Google Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords for your blog
create an editorial calendar very
important know that every week you're
going to do a blog post yeah so every
Monday you need to draft a post
Wednesday you want to publish it yeah so
look forward maybe write four or eight
blog posts in advance and then you are
ready for the next eight weeks then
start writing your first blog post yeah
that introduces the blog and introduces
your Niche create a Content strategy
have a visual strategy and optimize your
blog post for search using the keywords
yeah and using the meta tags for your
blogs so that is really important
because Google loves to show blog posts
higher up in the um in the search
results now remember it takes time
quality content takes time and effort so
take the time to research your topics
and make sure that you write compelling
and informative blog posts and promote
your content on social media and other
channels so that drives traffic back to
your
website and then finally we're going to
look at how to share your blog very
important you need to promote your blog
and you need to track your performance
yeah so share your blog on social media
platforms engage with your audience when
they have comments or when they give
feedback use email marketing to promote
your blog yeah collaborate with other
bloggers or websites in your Niche try
to get those blogging those guest
blogging opportunities and use paid
advertising to promote your blog
yeah so it's an ongoing effort and it
requires consistent
effort yeah on the tracking site use
Google analytics so set up your blog
with Google analytics so you get
information about traffic about your
audience and um about your most popular
pages and your most popular blog posts
yeah so you can track specific actions
in Google analytics so how many people
are at signing up for the newsletter for
instance monitor your social media
analytics how popular are your blog post
uh the Facebook post about your blog on
Twitter or on Facebook or on Instagram
yeah look at open rates click through
rates and regularly review your blog's
performance and adjust your strategy if
necessary yes so very important part
don't keep your blog a secret start
promoting it high and
wide okay so let's close the session
with some writing tips first of all know
your
audience understand who is your target
audience and what are they looking for
in your blog yeah we talked about
customer personas create customer
personas for your key audiences yep and
you're writing for them you're not
writing for yourself you need to hit the
language that resonates with your
audience be authentic writing your own
voice let your personality shine through
don't write Anonymous yeah people want
to see the writer the author behind the
art the um the uh the article yeah make
sure that you research your topic
because that will help you in writing
authoritatively and then when you write
authoritatively you provide value to
your
readers don't limit yourself to text use
images use videos to supplement your
writing make your blog visually
appealing it goes without saying edit
prove read prove read prove read there's
nothing more frustrating than typos in
your blog posts yeah make sure you're
right writing is clear it is simple it
is polished and there's no typos in
there just copy your blog text put it in
a word processor yep and then do a
spelling checker then finally be
consistent consistency is key to
building your audience and for your
readers to come back yes so and be
consistent in the timing as well try to
do it daily or weekly or monthly but
give that consistency to your
readers and if you take all these things
together and you are passionate about a
topic then I'm sure you're going to be
successful with your blog so if you are
looking to grab a career in digital
marketing simply learn has got you
covered with wide range of top-n digital
marketing courses these courses make you
skill in SEO content marketing PPC
social media marketing and much more
with hands-on experience in the tools
like Google analytics Keyword Planner
Sam rush and there is huge list on board
however one year of experience is prefer
to enroll in this course find the course
Link in the description box people may
experience various difficulties in
writing blogs articles or copyrights for
example some may struggle to find a time
to sit down and write something out or
they may struggle to get a creative
ideas flowing and think of something new
and interesting to write about whatever
the difficulty is but it is essential to
move around and try to write something
that you are proud of it may not be
perfect but it is unique to you and can
be a great way to express yourself so if
you are looking for a free AI writing
tool that will automate your articles
blogs or copyrights Etc you have come to
the right place this video will
introduce you to a top five free AI
writing tools available today on that
note welcome to to Simply Lear if you're
new to the Channel please subscribe to
our simply Lear YouTube channel and
click the Bell icon to be the first one
to know about the latest trending videos
now without further delay let's see the
top five free AI writing tools or
websites the first one is writer me
writer is an AI writing tool that can
generate many different types of content
this can be used for website copywriting
creating marketing and sales copy
writing full block post and many more
here you can generate 10 10,000
characters per month which means you can
write up to 10,000 characters every
month and once your 10,000 characters of
that particular month is completed it
will be restored in the next month and
personally I recommend this tool to
write any types of copyrighting the link
below in the description will directly
take you to the writer's free plan sign
up to the website and enjoy the free
plan of writer and the second one is
just. justo can write original content
creatively including blogs articles
social media Post website copy Etc to
claim a free access to justo please
click on the link in the description
here you can claim up to 10,000 words
for free that is you can write up to
10,000 words available in its free plan
most of the people don't use their free
trial of jbook because while logging
into the website it will ask for the
credit card number but you can give the
credit card number because unless and
until you complete your free trial and
shift to premium the money won't be
deducted
if you like the feature of jper you can
continue with the premium if not log out
from the website and the third one is
right Sonic right Sonic is an AI powered
copyright tool that will generate a
unique and engaging marketing content
for any types of business in seconds
with a few lens of text right Sonic will
generate ads blog post landing pages
product description and menu here you
will get a free trial for all the
features with 6 to 50 words per user
once you done with a free traal you can
op the Premium plan which is available
for
$12.67 where you will get 40,500 words
per user the link mentioned Below in the
description will directly take you the
free plan of right Sonic and the fourth
one is right cre the right cream is a
creative AI powered marketing tool that
utiliz the advanced machine learning to
write a copy of Google ads landing pages
product descriptions blog post social
media and many more here you will get up
to 20 credits that is 40,000 characters
in which you can write two long articles
of 5,000 words and four short articles
of th000 words if you are comfortable
with the r cream you can go for its
Premium plan which charges $29 per month
and R cream has an amazing offer of
getting all these features for Lifetime
only for
$59 and the last one is scaler it is the
combination of Next Generation
Technologies like Ai and NLP and the
seamless content creation process to
create a Content that exceeds the RIS it
enables you to improve your contents
readability efficiency and overall
output you can get a trial of scale nut
by clicking on the link below in the
description here you will get 2,000
words 40 plus AI tools two SEO reports
and menu you can also go for the Premium
plan for 924 rupees per with this we
have reached the end of this session
today we learn top five a writing tools
that will help you write any copyright
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement Okay so so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you could even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
content should have some call to action
so content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know I've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and end with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after you're done
engaging with the good content that you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content content well credibility so you
know anybody can write but are you
writing about something you know what
you're writing about are you a good
talking point a good expert or have
experience about this content so you
also want to use you know information
from a legitimate Source okay so you
don't want to grab something in your and
use it in your content that's just not
legitimate because it does hurt your
credibility and the organization's
credibility and then also originality I
mean right something that nobody else
has written so obviously you don't want
to plagiarize CU if you plagiarized and
there are tools out there where people
can easily just put their content in
there to see what else is out there see
if somebody else has plagiarized it so
it's very easy to find people who
plagiarize so don't be that person what
I would recommend create a good content
calendar and come up with some ideas
before you write them next question
related to content marketing so what are
the types of content you can create well
there are a lot of things you can create
start with the blog blog to me is always
a great place to start it's a blank
canvas for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a Blog it it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know a Hidden
Gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're you digital marketing expert
you done social media for another client
you know write about it you know show
the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social in in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook Okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook is a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to cont content a lot of choices okay so
what are the advantages of having a
Content calendar so I alluded to that
just a couple of seconds ago so let's
really break this down here cuz content
calendars to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so if you're planning something you're
going to have important dates in mind
okay so content calendar almost ensures
you don't miss anything you know that's
a good opportunity for you to leverage
like you know black Friday Cyber Monday
you know it's probably important you
know when those days are if you're in
e-commerce so that's why having a
Content calendar helps it helps you plan
out your content based on important
dates or based on dates that work for
what you're trying to do they also help
because you could stick to a consistent
schedule okay so if you don't have a
Content calendar you're probably just
arbitrarily writing content here and
there well what if your users crave and
really engage the content they're going
to want more sticking to something
consistent is going to really get people
to come back for more they know when
you're going to post they're going to be
waiting for it and if it's every Tuesday
morning 8:00 hey post it Tuesday morning
8:00 your users will get used to that
schedule and it it does help build up
your following it does help help build
up your community and in the end
cultivates a longlasting relationship
and having a Content calendar also
allows you to mix up your content okay
so you can see and plan ahead different
types of content in different formats
that way it allows you to mix it up
whether it be a blog post uh an
infographic a video about different
topics okay some other advantages here
saving time it just allows you to
prepare for the future when you can
prepare you're efficient and when you're
efficient you're not wasting time and so
to me having a Content calendar is a
must because a lot of us are busy who
has time and especially if you're going
to work in a new company let's say
writing content you definitely want to
have a Content calendar because you're
going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning post puts less strain on you
and your team members as well as company
resources because when you plan and you
post you're going to get data and then
when you get data it's either going to
work or not work and if it doesn't work
then you know in the future you're not
going to put that piece of content or
the topic in the content calendar again
it's that simple okay some other
advantages fresh content okay so having
a con content calendar allows you to
always keep content fresh again you're
going to be on a consistent schedule and
you're not going to be writing about the
same things over and over again so it
could be just simply Twitter if you're
putting a Content calendar and it
together for Twitter well you don't want
to have the same tweets every other day
so it does ensure that you're getting
tweets out there that are fresh that are
new that are different and again figure
out what works a Content counter makes
it easier to measure results and
optimize performance so you always want
to you know maybe put some metrics in
with your content calendar so you can
see side by side content historically
that is performed content that is not
performed okay so next question you may
get what type of content Works in each
stage of the customer life cycle so you
have awareness engagement purchase
post-p purchase advocacy okay so let's
break these down here so awareness okay
so you want people to understand who you
are okay that could be guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a Blog where people can
comment or Lanny page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of Engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you worked in a for a
specific product in the past and it's
works you certainly want to put that out
there for potential clients in that same
industry purchase trying to get people
to purchase what are you going to do
well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
content okay onboarding emails get those
emails out there and get people to go
back to the website and purchase of
course you can have product and service
details as well meaning you know One
onepage downloadable PDFs that describe
the product okay you have post purchase
okay so people whove already purchased
you could certainly send out follow-up
emails you can do blog roundups you know
give people an opportunity to see what
features or updates are happening to the
product okay of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service okay so
if somebody's already purchased Andy you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complement the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community they're going to be
your advocates so give them exclusive
discounts and then pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not going to share that so you're going
to have people share that information in
other words you can generate content
where you hey people can help you out
here and be your Advocate okay so how do
you decide what topic and subject to
write on okay well going back to the
content calendar that always hows you to
see what you've put in that content
calendar but there are some other
methods you can use and you could
certainly identify your target audience
and not only identify your target
audence but what their needs are okay so
you can write content based on audience
so you could certainly do some research
with keywords okay what's trending what
keywords are not trending okay and write
around what's trending for example okay
you could certainly take a look at
social media for example Kora I always
look at Kora Kora is interesting
entertaining informational he people are
certainly having conversations on Kora
and you can certainly analyze those
conversations because they certainly get
in depth and you can decide hey do I
want to write a topic around something
that really just won't go away in terms
of conversing core is a good example of
analyzing conversations they tend to be
a little bit more in depth so some other
things you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitor's blogs or or your
competitor's social media platforms and
Pages you can keep track of blogs and
articles from subject matter experts
commentators critics and so on okay so
you can get ideas from them another
question you may get which is very
important if you're going to start
working for a company you need to
understand the tone the tone of your
content because that is going to fit and
be in line with the company you're
working for okay so you're always going
to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience audiences okay and how the
brand wants to be seen by that audience
so you know if you have an older
audience you're not going to use younger
audience I.E street lingo or today's
lingo in in the younger generation uh
you're going to use you know language
that's going to fit the audience you're
talking to and then of course the
channel itself so the content you create
must be irrespective of the channel and
consistent with brand attributes okay so
you got to pick and choose the channel
if it's LinkedIn for example hey you
know linkedin's more business oriented
okay so you're not going to be you know
as humorous as you would be say on
Instagram or Facebook all of these have
one thing in common again that's brand
guidelines you have to stay within the
brand what is the Brand's personality
how do we want to talk to our audience
and what platform are we using to talk
to our audience how do you promote your
content once it's live well that's
always a good question hey you doing the
the work the putting in the hard work to
create this you know it could be a video
and videos take a long time it could be
an infographic an ebook Okay so send it
out via email okay if you have an an
email list send it out and let people
know this content's there put a link in
the email or or even a piece or snippet
or preview of the content in the email
so you're using the email to broadcast
and encourage people to you know if it's
an ebook get the rest of the ebook Okay
you can certainly leverage social media
to engage with your community that's the
best you know just as good as email get
out there and let people know hey I got
I got my book published come and
download it you know you can give a
discount to the first 100 people that
download it okay you can always promote
your content via ads so whether that be
Google or Facebook you always have an
opportunity to meet more prominent by
advertising the content that you have to
offer so you can always reach out on
social media again targeting interesting
people directly so you can always
interact with people on social or you
can write for others attract people from
the web to important pages of your
website by guest posting so you can
always go onto a popular blog post and
write something and you know link it up
or or have it be relevant to the content
you've written so next question H how
can you determine how well your content
is doing okay very important again
you've done all the work you put the
content calendar together you got the
content ready to go it's published
you're promoting it social email guest
blogging but you want to determine how
it's doing well depends on the channel
really is what it comes down to so if
it's organic search you want to be able
to see if it's ranking for the keyword
you optimize that content for if it's
social you want to be able to see if you
have engagement shares comments Etc of
course you can always look at analytics
and see how much traffic that blog post
is getting or that page with the white
paper is getting okay so you can always
look at your analytics and look at the
traffic okay and again you can always
look to see if there are conversions in
the form of an inquiry or lead or sale
so at the end of the day you want to
align the content with the channel and
you want to align the kpi with the
content in Channel okay so if it's
social you're not likely going to get
conversions unless you're doing paid ads
if you're post organically on social
then you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what I was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes you need to
Define buyer persona is to determine the
audience best suited for your content
okay so you're always writing for an
audience and you're going to Market that
content for that audience so you always
got to keep that in mind okay run
content audience audits to determine the
best type of content that can be used in
other words how did it perform what kind
of Engagement did you get with the
infographic or did that video really
really perform well or do we want to use
you know a blog post next time around or
an image next time around so continuing
on here you want to choose an
appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it WordPress or is it
another platform okay you can start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
calendar to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to choose the format and
then of course you want to publish and
manage your content after it's all said
and done so these are the steps involved
again just quickly decide on the goal
the kpi decid on your audience look at
what's worked and not worked in the past
get your content set up in the platform
okay or get the platform ready to go I
should say Okay generate ideas with that
content calendar I ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when I say manage I mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
Right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based Bas on
who's coming to your website based on
who subscribed to your emails based on
who's following you on social media so
in other words you have people
interacting with you okay in different
channels and you need to understand who
these people are so or they fit a
certain age range or generation are they
skewed more female to male education
level what's their Affinity or interest
okay do they have a certain income so
you need to really break down your
audience here and you could do that in
Analytics you could do that on social
you can do that just by looking at your
email list okay the all those will paint
a picture as to who your audience is
welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
from Simply learn and today we're going
to talk about affiliate marketing so
let's jump right into it and take a look
inside an office environment right now
we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done Page search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I got to come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
John's just taking over now and he's
going to let Chuck know everything there
is to know about affiliate marketing so
the first question John answers for
Chuck what is affiliate marketing so
affiliate marketing is a form of digital
marketing that involves a merchant it
involves a merchant paying commissions
to a website or other entities so if I'm
selling a product basically somebody
else sells that product for me I'm going
to pay that person a commission for
selling my product it's that simple
that's what affiliate marketing is okay
so basically what these Merchants are
doing or other enties they're
advertising your product so they're
advertising your product with a referral
so they're passing on their own
customers to you so that they can buy
your product and again The Exchange is
you give that website or other entity a
commission that's more or less what
affiliate marketing is so John's going
to have us take a look at each of these
components of affiliate marketing in
detail take it away John so John says
first we have the merchant AKA The Brand
the seller the Creator the founder the
owner the inspiration the innovator hey
this is the person who came up with this
brilliant idea This brilliant idea has
to get out there we're the merchant
we're trying to get this brilliant idea
out to the masses so this is the
component of affiliate marketing that
creates the product the merchant could
be anyone okay so it could be startups
to large multinational companies
International companies nonprofits
for-profits individuals independent
contractors Freelancers a group of
people who have a passion for something
okay it could be anybody there's no
limit the affiliate aka the publisher so
the affiliate is basically
that third party webbsite or entity
which promotes the Merchant's products
and tries to convince potential
customers of the Merchant's products
value so this affiliate's going to
represent the merchant on their behalf
and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign up sales and
subscriptions so it doesn't always come
down down to you know sales you know if
I'm just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I'm got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your perspective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers digital marketing
tools are essential Assets in the modern
marketing landscape these software
Solutions and platforms Empower
businesses and marketers to plan execute
analyze and optimize their online
marketing strategies from search engine
optimization and social media man
management to email marketing analytics
and content creation these tools
streamline processes enhance efficiency
and drive better results in the digital
realm in this digital age leveraging the
right marketing tools is the key to
staying competitive and achieving
marketing objectives effectively so if
you are looking to become a digital
marketing specialist and learn all the
essential digital marketing tools then
look no further than simply learns
post-graduate program in digital
marketing with this you will gain all
the necessary skills in digital
marketing like website creation
behavioral marketing keyword research
search engine optimization search engine
marketing campaign management social
media marketing and more so if you are
looking to become a digital marketing
specialist and learn all the essential
digital marketing tools then look no
further then simply learns postgraduate
program in digital marketing with this
you gain all the necessary skills in
digital mark marketing like website
creation behavioral marketing keyword
research search engine optimization
search engine marketing campaign
management social media marketing and
more with knowledge of tools like SE
ranking hoods suit chat JP Google ads
Google Keyword Planner Google Trends and
there's much more on the list don't miss
out on this incredible opportunity as
only one year of experience is preferred
to enroll in this course take action
today and enroll in a course to unlock
the digital marketing success accelerate
your career and gain the skills you need
to thrive in the industry ready to get
started click the link in the
description box and embark on your
journey to professional growth and
achievement without any further Ado
let's begin the number one tool in our
list is Google analytics website
tracking plays an important role in
digital marketing it helps in
understanding the user behavior on your
website do you know that there are
around 38 million websites that you use
Google analytics including Airbnb Uber
Spotify and udmi analytics is an
analytics tools used for tracking a
website the standard version of Google
analytics is free we can integrate
Google analytics with Google ads as well
the key features of Google analytics
include tracking website traffic user
demographics page views bounce rates
conversion rates and much more with
these valuable insights businesses can
optimize the digital strategies improve
user experience and ultimately boost
online performance towards the next tool
which is Google ads Google ads is a
vital tool in digital marketing it lets
businesses display the ads on Google
search results and partner sites key
features include keyword targeting
budget control audience targeting and
robust analytics advertisers can
optimize ads for mobile conduct AB
testing and benefit from the features
like remarketing and AD extensions it's
a versatile tool for reaching the Right
audience at the right time driving
traffic and boosting conversions in the
competitive online landscape on number
three we have Google search console
Google search console is a free web
master tool provided by Google it is
important to timely monitor your website
and make it error free this is where
Google search console comes into the
picture it helps businesses to Monitor
and maintain their websites present in
Google search result some features of
Google Search console includes getting
confirmation that the Google search
engine can crawl your website fix the
problems in the page indexing sense page
for reindexing can VI Google search
traffic data record the number of times
your website appears in the search
results records the search engine
queries for which your websites appears
in the search results show the list of
sites linking to you and many more on
number four we have Sam rush to grow
your business it is essential to keep an
eye on what your competitors are doing
this will help you to understand their
strengths and Implement similar
strategies for your business as well for
this you need to carry out competitive
analysis s Rush is a competitor analysis
tools that gives a complete work through
of the competitor's data like keywords
backlinks top performing content
campaigns Etc it has free as well as
paid versions on number five we have
MailChimp MailChimp is a popular email
marketing platform known for its
userfriendly interface it offers
features like email campaign creation
marketing automation audience
segmentation analytics and integration
with other tools it's widely used for
engaging with audiences and nurturing
leads through the personalized email
marketing on number six we have canva
canva is a userfriendly graphic design
tool that empowers digital Market
marketers to create eye-catching visuals
for social media email marketing ads
infographics and more it helps to
maintain Brad consistency enhance
content engagement and simplifies the
design process making it a valuable
asset in digital marketing efforts next
we have is HubSpot HubSpot is all-in-one
digital marketing and sales platform
known for its inbound marketing
strategies it provides tools for Content
creation automation CRM analytics and
more Hub sport helps businesses attract
engage hubs sport helps businesses to
attract engage and convert leads into
customers by streamlining marketing and
sales efforts on number eight we have
ahrs gaining high quality backlink is an
essential factor in digital marketing
and SEO ranking as it shows the trust of
other website in your content moreover
it helps in building the authority of
your website ah DS is a comprehensive SE
toolkit that includes features like
backlink analysis keyword research site
Audits and competitor analysis it's a
valuable tool for improving website
performance and achieving better search
engine rankings the next tool on the
list we have is grammarly grammarly is a
vital tool in digital marketing ensuring
error free engaging content across the
channel it enhances quality SE
optimization and consistency
time saving and improving audience
engagement in email social media and
content creation last but not least we
have moss moss is a key player in
digital marketing specializing in SEO
tools and resources it helps marketers
with keyword research backlink analysis
onpage SEO local SEO content strategies
and Technical SEO MOS also offers
educational content and supportive
Community to stay updated with SEO best
practices and Industry Trends greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders with simply
learn thank you for joining and today
we're going to cover digital marketing
interview questions and answers so
thanks for joining again and here's how
it's going to work so we broke out a few
questions and answers uh in different
categories a lot of you are going to be
interviewing for some jobs out there and
some of the jobs maybe an SEO manager or
search engine marketing manager or email
marketing manager or content marketing
manager or social media manager so we
broke up those questions into those
areas and so that's what we're going to
do we're going to start with SEO we're
going to go through some questions and
I'm going to explain the answers to
those questions so if you have any
questions to these questions or answers
feel free to just comment right below
this video video and we'll get back to
as soon as possible so let's get started
we're going to start with SEO search
engine optimization we're going to go
through a series of questions and I'm
going to answer those questions for you
okay so the first question that you
might be asking an interview is
differentiate between do follows and no
follows okay so if you taken or listen
to my SEO courses on YouTube for SEO we
we talked a lot about do follows and no
follows and and simply put I mean do
follows or just signals to the search
engines to follow the link so there's a
link on site a pointing to site B we're
going to basically tell Google Bing and
some of these other search engines hey
go ahead and follow that link now a no
follow is just the opposite so no follow
link doesn't allow the search engine
crawlers to follow it so if we have a
link on our site s site a pointing to
site B we can put a no follow tag in
there and what that's going to do it's
going to signal to the Crawlers hey
don't follow this link so in the end if
the Crawlers don't follow the link then
there's not going to be any link juice
passed and so Google is not going to
give you credit or give that site credit
for having a link pointing to it or
pointing to another site or from another
site and so it's all about linking so we
can control if there's links on our site
whether we want the Crawlers to
recognize those or not simply with no
follow tags so just a reminder link ju
is the reputation or Equity passed from
one website to another so if you have a
link on another website and that website
is of high quality meaning their page
Authority their domain Authority is high
they have a lot of content you know
they're not spammy they're really rich
and they're relevant then you may want
to make sure that the link pointing from
that site to your site is a no follow so
that way that Google can recognize the
link from that site to your site and
basically that reputation is going to be
passed on to you okay so that's a do
follow versus a no follow and why would
we do a no follow well it depends it
really depends a lot of social media
platforms like Facebook have no follows
if you have a lot of content you may not
want to be pushing out a lot of do
follows it could actually look bad from
an external linking standpoint and so a
lot of sites are really particular about
who they want to pass link juice on to
and give credit for the link so it's a
business decision at the end of the day
there's really no hard fast rule here
except from an SEO perspective if I have
a site and I have a lot of external
links pointing outward to other sites
I'm going to be particular about who I
allow the search engine to follow and
what links I allow not to follow so
here's an example of what they look like
so do follow is simply just the hre
notice the no follow has the the tag
appended to it the hre tag with a no
follow so if the search engines crawling
your site and they see that no follow
there they're not going to follow that
link and vice versa if there's a link on
another site pointing to yours and
there's a no follow there you're not
going to get credit the search engines
are going to pick up that link okay so
question two what is 301 redirect and
how is it different from a 302 redirect
so 31 redirects tell users in the search
engine specifically that original page
has been moved and this is the key word
here permanently so permanently moved
we're going to explain that in a minute
so it's just move from one page to
another and so if we don't have a page
anymore but we have a new page let's
just say you built a new website with
new URLs you want to make sure the old
page is pointing to the new page with a
301 redirect so if a 301 redirect is
permanent then a 302 is temporary so so
we want the search engines to recognize
that we have 301 permanent redirects in
place why because if we have temporary
then it might alert Google to not keep
that page in its search engine rankings
because it's temporary so why would
Google want to keep a temporary page or
even a page that is pointing to another
page on a temporary basis so they REM
May remove both pages from its index
okay but if we have something permanent
in place Google may say okay this page
is permanently linking to another page
or redirecting to another page therefore
it's stable it's permanent we're going
to keep that new page in the index and
eventually remove the old page so really
something permanent is more stable in
the eyes of the search engine something
temporary may not be as stable in the
eyes of say Google and if they don't see
it a stable then they may remove both
pages from the index okay so the ideas
we want to be found Google search index
and we get it sometimes Pages go away
for a variety of reasons and if it does
go away just make sure you have a new
page for it and that new page is a 301
permanent redirect okay so question
three why are backlinks important in SEO
well we kind of hinted on that a bit
with the no follow because if we have a
link from another website pointing to
ours and that link from that other
website is really relevant and and it
has a high page and domain Authority
then it's going to benefit us and so
backlinks are important because if we
have backlinks from high quality sites
it's going to improve the credibility of
our site especially if it's a do follow
tag so the search engines are going to
recognize the relationship between the
site that has a link pointing to us okay
so it's just going to build our
credibility it's going to increase
increase our domain Authority and then
the net effect of that is if we're
credible and we have High domain
Authority then that's going to increase
the rankings of our pages and when the
pages increase in ranking then we're
going to get more of a Lon share of the
traffic for certain keywords that our
pages are found for and if our pages are
found and getting traffic then because
we have increased rankings we're likely
going to have increased traffic and then
it's just a snowball effect so more
traffic leads to more engagement and
conversions so the whole idea for SEO is
remember you have an onpage strategy and
an off-page strategy building external
links is part of an off-page SEO
strategy and we want to make sure that
you know we are relevant in the form of
a link or in the form of content on
other high quality sites being on a high
quality site only benefits us because
again increases our D domain Authority
Google sees this is more relevant
therefore pages are going to benefit by
ranking higher and therefore when we
rank higher we get more traffic so it's
it's a snowball effect so having
backlinks is important because it
snowballs all the way through to
conversions okay so what are the best
practices to rank your videos on YouTube
this is a great question really great
question given the importance of videos
especially with SEO CU videos are found
YouTube in itself is a search engine so
if we have a video how are we going to
get it to rank on YouTube well first
things first you never want to put a
video out there and want it to rank if
it's not in engaging or informative so
make sure you go ahead and follow the
best practices of having engaging and
informative content in your video now
once you have that video in place you
want to optimize it and then some of the
key factors for optimizing the video are
you want to choose a title that has high
search volume and low difficulty just as
you would keyword for example for a web
page you want to choose a title with a
keyword in it that has high volume and
low difficulty I.E low competition okay
so you want a nice ratio there and you
know what you want to choose a title
it's going to get people to watch the
video too so it's not all about just
choosing a title just for the sake of
high volume you also have to choose
something that's relevant that's going
to be catchy as well and then with that
title goes the description so you want a
description that's very relevant to your
title okay because most people aren't
going to click on a video just for the
sake of the title they're going to want
to probably get a sneak peek via the
description of what it is so again you
want to optimize that description but
make sure the description is is just as
snazzy as the title okay you also want
to use accurate and relevant video tags
just as you would on Twitter or Facebook
tag these videos okay so make sure your
title tag length doesn't exceed 100
characters because it will get chopped
off so again that goes back to just
writing something really short and to
the point that's going to grab
somebody's attention Okay you also want
to upload a captivating thumbnail
something that's relevant then that's
going to grab somebody's attention and
then again we set it similar to the
video tags we want to use relevant
hashtags again just as you would with
Twitter and Facebook go ahead and throw
some hashtags in there that people could
see because people search via
hashtagging and then this goes about
saying you did all the work created a
really great video it's engaging it's
informative you optimized it feel free
to promote your video on other social
media platforms okay don't just stick
with YouTube per se so the benefit here
is if you post it on Facebook or
LinkedIn or whatever platform of your
choice and it gets engagement people
click on the link go to YouTube they're
going to like it and then other people
are going to see that engagement they're
going to see how many people liked it or
how many subscribers you have so promote
your videos to help you with the ranking
of the video on YouTu YouTube so that
does play into it so go ahead and
promote it so other people can watch it
like it comment Etc and that's going to
engage other people to want to do the
same so what is mobile first indexing
this is a really important and timely
question mobile first indexing means
Google's just using mobile friendly
content for indexing and ranking
websites so in other words Google for
example has two Bots they have the
traditional desktop bot and they have a
smartphone bot and eventually everybody
that has a website is going to be
migrated over to the smartphone bot and
so if that smartphone bot goes to your
website and starts crawling what do you
think they're looking for their
smartphone bot they're looking for
mobile friendly content if it's not
mobile friendly meaning the page isn't
designed for a smartphone browser or
let's just say the images are way too
large or you have to expand the text
just to read it you know a lot of these
these issues that somebody would have
just simply trying to read something on
a web page on their mobile device
Google's not going to grab that content
so you want to make sure it's mobile
friendly so it gets indexed and so if
your website has a responsive design
Google will rank your website based on
its performance on mobile devices okay
so you want to make sure that your
website is mobile friendly and if you're
in an interview and somebody asked you
this question you could even take it a
step further and say look I'm going to
measure how friendly my my website is
for mobile devices in Google search
console because Google search console
has a report that will show you what
pages on your website are not mobile
friendly and it's not a guarantee but I
could tell you if I'm Google and I'm
crawling your site with my smartphone
bot and that page or one of my pages is
not mobile friendly I'm probably not
going to index it or rank it so you want
to leverage that that report in Google
search console to see what pages are
mobile friendly so that's a little bonus
for you to really impress the
interviewer who ask you this question
because how you going to know if one of
your pages is mobile friendly or not if
you don't look at a report so keep an
eye on Google search consoles mo mobile
usability report okay number six list
down the most important local SEO
ranking factors okay so organic local
rank in is just as important as anything
else in organic search because if you
have a local business you want to use
the likes of say Google my business to
show up when somebody types in you know
looking for a florist or you looking for
a coffee shop so what you want to do is
you want to create a web page for every
product and service okay you also want
to opt for your business listings on
Google my business and and there are
plenty of other local business Direct
cies out there like Yelp for example or
Bing even has one so go ahead and also
make sure you have a business listing as
well but since Google in the United
States has a huge market share you want
to start with Google first you want to
update your nap citations on your
website maintain consistency of your nap
okay so nap is name address phone number
so you want to make sure that that's
current and consistent so if you have a
number on your website make sure it's
the same number on Google my business
okay you can embed a Google map on your
website you could certainly optimize the
metat tags and content not only on your
web pages but within your Google my
business directory so you can add your
business to other local directories like
I mentioned Yelp and then also just as
important op for reviews and ratings
okay so the more reviews the H you have
the better off you are okay so I always
say this with or with local search three
of the main factors in showing up for
local search on say Google is obviously
the keyword the second is the proximity
of where that person is and then third
is the reviews so you can't really
control the proximity but you can
control the keyword and you can control
the reviews to some degree so work hard
at getting reviews for your business but
at the same time you can certainly work
in some keywords let's just say for your
product and service pages on your
website but also you can translate that
over to Google my business okay so
working in those keywords making sure
you're your number your address your
name they're all consistent and and
really just spreading your the the
business out on other directories that's
really all these are really key factors
for local SEO okay so question number
seven how to avoid duplicate content
getting penalized for duplicate content
so for example if you have two different
versions of a web page you may result in
a duplicate content issue so it's just
SEO 101 you never want to have two two
or more pages with the same content so
what do we do well we can avoid this in
having Google penalize us by again
setting up a 301 redirect remember 301s
are permanent we can also use what they
call a canonical tag and a canonical tag
basically alerts the search engines as
to which page is the original okay so if
we have an original page we want to
point to that page with our canonical
tag and then the third option is opt for
preferred domain in Google search
console okay so if you have multiple no
names make sure you set up a primary one
in search console so those are ways to
work around it of this three I would
always go with the canonical tags
because that's just a tag that's going
to sit on the page it's going to alert
Google as to what the original is just
in case they get their hands on the
duplicate so all the pages that have the
same content are going to have the same
canonical tag pointing to one page so
again three ones are permanent you can
simply just redirect one to the other if
you end up having duplication or you
could just tell the search engines hey
this is the original page or you can go
through search console okay number eight
what are the tactics to increase a web
page speed okay so what is some of the
tactics well when you build a site
especially for mobile you want to keep
it as simple as possible and what I mean
by simple as possible really I mean hey
use a simple website design don't get
overly creative if you will most
websites all websites have images you're
not going to be able to get around that
but just make sure you optimize your
images in other words don't have such a
large image size if you don't need
something very large don't have it okay
you want to improve server response time
and what do we mean by that well your
site's sitting on a server somewhere you
can own that server or you can be
renting it out from say Amazon web
services or let's just say GoDaddy as
your register they also have web hosting
well if you have it on say God daddy
server you may be sharing that server
with other businesses and at certain
times of the day other businesses may
get a lot of traffic and suck up a lot
of bandwidth what is that going to do
that's going to reduce the server
response time for your site and so you
want to make sure you have a an idea of
you know what server your web page your
website is on and you want to be able to
can have some control over that because
if your server response is slow that's
going to slow down everything else in
terms of loading in the browser and
that's not going to be good for SEO okay
optimize your code what you mean by
optimiz minifying when we see minifying
we mean get rid of some of the Redundant
code if you have CSS you know get rid of
chop some of the get rid of the Java
Script you're not using so that's what
we mean by optimizing code reduce
redirects okay ideally you just want to
have one redirect in place you don't
want to create a daisy chain so to speak
of redirecting and redirecting after
that that's never going to bode well and
it's going to slow things down as well
enable browser caching so if you enable
browser caching basically if somebody
comes back to the page they've been on
say two days ago they're probably going
to see a cash version of that page and
then op for the content delivery Network
as well so these are some of the ways to
reduce page speed now if you're curious
about the page speed of your website you
can always go to Google's page speed
insites tool and all you have to do is
just Google page speed insights or even
just something generic like Google page
speed and you're going to get this tool
page speit insights and all you need to
do is just plug in a URL when you plug
in the URL Google's going to analyze the
URL for both mobile and desktop and so
here we could see Google gives a score
so we could see the score for mobile and
we could see the score for desktop just
by clicking on desktop and so here I
could see some of the issues that the
site may be having in terms of page low
time for their desktop if I flip over to
mobile you here I could see some other
issues for example they have a server
static assets with efficient cash policy
now if you're not sure what the heck
that means you can always just click on
it and you can see some specifics here
and or you can just always Google it as
well uh here you got the reduce the
impact of third party code okay so
that's another thing uh reduce
JavaScript execution time so again going
back to a lot of some of the comments we
met about coding okay some sometimes too
much code or code not functioning as
well as it should will tend to slow down
the site okay so you can use PP insights
you can always get a glimpse of how
pages are loading simply by also going
to for example Google analytics under
Behavior okay you can go to site speed
and if you click on overview okay Google
what Google does is they do a sampling
of pages over time and in this case
based on 89 Page views they have an
average page load time and so you can
get a sense of how quick specific Pages
load your site overall simply by looking
at the site speed overview report in
Google analytics to get a sense of how
quick your pages are loading now there's
certain factors that do affect load time
so obviously the way the page is built
with the code the images Etc but also
the browser each browser loads
differently okay so you want to take a
look at it by browser also by country
every country has a different network
you can be in the United States and have
worse network service than you do say in
you know co uh Ivory Coast in Africa
okay so it really depends on the network
you're on so and also the page every
page is built differently so you want to
get a sense of what pages are loading
quicker and which pages are not you can
simply just go to page timings in Google
analytics and you get a sense of what
pages do not load fast which ones do and
maybe hone in on the pages that aren't
loading fast and address those pages
first okay so you have two tools at your
disposal one Google Analytics and one
page speed insights okay so let's look
at question number nine here so when
should an individual Target short tail
and longtail keywords okay so remember
short tail are usually one to two
keywords very Broad in nature long tail
keywords maybe three four keywords in a
query or maybe an entire sentence those
are considered longtail keywords so
usually short tail keywords have higher
volume but also higher competition
longer tail keywords usually have lower
uh volume but also lower competition but
the great thing about longtail keywords
the conversion rate will tend to be a
little bit higher than say a short tail
because it's less vague and more
specific so you can use short tail
keywords if you're trying to drive a lot
of visitors because those keywords are
going to be vague or Broad in nature
longtail keywords are use for targeted
Pages such as product pages and articles
so if you have a specific product with a
long name you can certainly optimize
that page for that product name again
the product name may have low volume but
if somebody types in exactly that
product name you show up the chance of
you them converting are going to be very
high so you don't have to always be that
specific of the product name but try and
be as specific as you possibly can in
order to get somebody to click on your
link in the search engine results and
get them over to your site to convert
okay so those are are really the big
differences short tail very broad very
vague a lot of volume but also a lot of
competition but hey if you're ranking
for short tail keyword you're probably
going to get a lot of traffic the
conversion rates may not be as high as
something say longtail where hey maybe
you're just toned in on a few set number
of products and you're not care you
don't care of a lot about the traffic
you just care about getting the relevant
traffic to your site to convert okay
number 10 what are the important
elements to focus while developing a
website so we're talking in terms of SEO
okay so if somebody asked me this
question in an interview what am I going
to focus on while developing a website
well the answers are right here yes we
talked about mobile mobile is so
important because a lot of websites are
going to be indexed with Google
smartphone bot so mobile usability is
very important so we need to make sure
our website is responsive for mobile
just some basic practice is when it
comes to site architecture navigation we
want to have a simple URL structure okay
no overly cumbersome the navigation
should simply be clean and need okay if
you have five products okay maybe you
have uh in your navigation you have
something called products with all five
listed or you have all five products in
the main navigation the key is you just
want to make it clean and neat easy for
somebody to find the the rule of thumb
is if it's good for the end user
probably going to be good for Google but
if complicated for the end User it's
probably going to be complicated for
Google you always want to create a
sitemap now what is that sitemap a Sit
map is simply just a formatted file with
to that's includes all your URLs and
assets your images and your videos
they're going to be sitting on your
server as well so you want Google or
these these Bots to be able to find your
pages and assets and by the way you want
to take it a step further and make sure
you upload that s map which is sitting
in the root directory meaning domain.com
SLS sitemap.xml okay you want to take
that sitap and make sure you input that
sitap location in Google search console
that way Google search console has a
oneway ticket to grab the elements in
the sitemap another important element to
focus on while developing a WIP side is
having a robot's text file and all A
robot's text file is it's like a lock I
always say to a house so if you lock a
door in your house nobody's going to be
able to get in that door so it's all a
robots text file is you're telling
Google and these other Bots that are
coming ACR your site what's locked and
what's not locked meaning what they have
access to what they don't have access to
so you want to be able to make sure you
have a robot's text file if you're
trying to not index specific pages of
your website because if you tell Google
don't crawl these Pages or this
directory they're not going to get
crawled and if they don't get crawled
they're not going to get indexed so
robots text file is an important element
to focus on while you're developing your
website and while you're developing your
website it could be on a you know in a
directory just called new website so you
probably want to have new website as the
directory in the robots text file and
just to let Google no don't go into this
directory because it's my new website
I'm not ready to go live yet so you
don't want it indexed so there a lot of
reasons to have robots text files that's
the main reason sitap you want Google to
get the these pages and assets quickly
okay you want to make sure that your
site architecture navigation is in order
you want to make sure your site is
mobile friendly and you also want to
make sure you have content on your
website that's the key because that's
what's going to keep people on the
website and engaged and when I say
content I don't necessarily just mean
words I also mean videos I also mean
images you know something interactive
okay you want to keep people engaged
that's the key behind it trust me if if
an end user finds your side engaging
Google is likely going to find your side
engaging okay so those are good brownie
points to bring up if somebody asks you
this question in an interview so just a
recap here it's important to have a
better site structure so that Bots can
easily access and mix content okay with
a responsive design helps to make your
website mobile friendly and user
friendly would also increase the amount
of time a user spends on your website
which may improve your s's ranking
sitemap is simply just a file that helps
search engine Bots to understand the
structure of the website okay how many
pages there are on your website and
where they located along with the videos
and images okay and then the robots text
just instructs the search engine
crawlers to understand what pages should
not be indexed okay this is simply just
a text file and it's added to the root
directory again think like a door think
of a lock okay you can tell you can lock
whatever doors you want in your house so
here we wrap up digital marketing course
if if you have any queries regarding any
Concept in the video feel free to add it
in the comment section and our experts
will be happy to help you do subscribe
to Simply learn to stay updated with new
technology Trends thanks for watching
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here